thank you
all right um 36
second warning consume your positions
okay it's uh 10 past 10
Tuesday morning I'm going to convene
the division three work session
um we have
made a lot of decisions we've which has
allowed the LBA to really begin locking
down uh all of our amendments
um uh and so today is really our last
day to to make decisions to make sure
that the whole LBA paper chase is
completed by Friday
so
um so what I think we may end up having
to do is is get through these kind of
rapidly make as many decisions as we can
and then uh we'll probably need to
recess while Mr Ripple and the OLS works
together
um and then we'll probably end up having
to come back sometime this afternoon and
and I'll get an estimated time for Mr
Ripple when that might be based on the
workload that we uh we end up giving
them
so so that's kind of how I I think the
day is going to go you're probably going
to have a really long lunch but you're
going to need to come back before
closing business
and and we so let's let's let's let's
make sure we do some time checks
representative Mooney has a bill to
introduce the Senate at two o'clock are
there are there any other schedule
conflicts during the day that I should
know about
because I'd like to work around what we
can I don't think your two o'clock is
going to be a problem because I suspect
that's part of the time that OLS is
going to need to finish their
documentation so you're you're okay I
have a three o'clock but
um for about a half an hour but I would
be here if it's open okay I
okay I also have a two o'clock I believe
you you have a two o'clock as well yes
okay any others
no okay
okay so
um does everyone have
um the uh as of March 21 tentative
actions related to hb2 this guy
okay
and where is representative erf he's
here
I can sense his presence
okay
you only have two I thought you had
three
okay
um
all right so
the most complicated thing we have to
work on I think or by we I mean the team
with Mr Ripple and OLS is the Medicaid
targeted rates and so uh representative
verf do you want to introduce us to what
you've
I would love to I was having Jana man
copies for everybody else there I didn't
have enough to give to uh representative
uh uh the chairman and and our other
colleagues so she'll be done just
momentarily she's literally rubbing them
out right now okay so let's let's let's
do what we can and that is
um on 212 the Choose Love program I it's
great out here but I I thought this we
ended up tying 4-4 on that would you
remind me of what we did representative
tolerski
this is this was a program you loved and
and I and in my head we left it 4-4
the the the blue sign
okay all right all right oh I even sang
what the world needs now is love sweet
love so okay all right so
um
we're hand I I will keep that I don't
care to revisit it then
representative Edwards um uh regarding
um uh the rate
um requests as well
um you know we have an amendment and
some of the values from what what came
from Monahan changed from from our work
from the additional research so I don't
know whether
um uh whether we should combine these
together or and um we had a couple of
minor a couple of changes this morning
so I don't have the final version but we
do have a printed out version of
amendment on the Medicaid rate requests
so so thank you for all the work you've
put into that and what I think would
probably allow us to wrap our heads
around this the best is the document
we've looked at the most as a as a group
uh related to the Medicaid targeted rate
increases has been sort of the initial
Monahan Community document and I know
that representative verf is prepared to
talk to his View of that and so let's
use that maybe as a as a the initial
starter and then and then we'll have you
come in and help us crosswalk what
you've done relative to what we hear
sounds great okay representative are we
ready now yes sir
so you should all have a black and white
version of this
which is basically the Monahan document
I supplemented it with
uh you'll see at the bottom of page one
uh one of the people who was here
yesterday she's probably back again
yeah there she is thank you
um she talked about
two the TB tbds that were in there so
that was the home health age and you'll
notice that below where the row below
where it says home health aids there's a
first row there says MCL payments that's
the number she gave me and then if you
flip to the top of the next page page or
flip it over I guess to the top of the
next page you'll see the Medicaid ffs
provider payments that's another number
she gave me so my understanding is that
those are the two tbds that make up the
TBD the two values the two sets of
values that make up the TBD I'm sorry so
that was one change and then sorry go
ahead
um okay so I'm seeing uh decimal points
the reason for that is if you go back to
page one you'll notice everything's in
millions so I wanted to be very precise
I took the number she gave me which was
uh you know for instance in one case it
was 774 000 480 dollars and I put a
point at the beginning okay I I'm just
trying to track uh actions Laura uh you
you your number was I think something
like
984 and then I forward that to you and
that's there's two numbers that need to
be summed there's a seven seven four
thousand the bottom of page one and then
the at the top of page two there's
another 191 000. so the total of that
would be about what you just said okay I
all I'm doing is I'm not disagreeing I'm
just simply trying to make sure that the
late breaking data that we got has
gotten to you and and is Incorporated in
your analysis I read her email okay and
I also spoke with her yesterday
afternoon I think I have the numbers
right if I don't okay
all right so that was one of the one of
the additions to the Monahan document
the other one is continuing down the top
of page two where it says Granite State
Independent Living that was what Mr
lippman discussed with us yesterday the
three million in each year for the
uh
pcla services
so so far so good
okay so philosophically and this is
where I might jive with what you've been
doing over there
um philosophically here was what I did
and it lends itself to
um to changes as I'll describe so I took
a total of 40 million dollars per year
as the as the sum will allocate at this
point I still have no idea where we
stand on the whole what we've done in
terms of availability of of of General
funds but just taking that as a number
to begin with
you'll notice down on the right hand
side a number of uh in that column a
number of them say irf hold constant and
those appear next to the
um the home health aide Rose along with
the granite state Independent Living row
and then if you skip quite a ways along
I think towards the end
uh on page four the rebasing does not
say hold constant but please write in
there hold constant that was one that
was pointed out to me this morning that
that's at the top of page four so that
makes with me on that one
oh it is written in I guess I wrote it
and then it got copied thank you it's
it's not on page four under rebasing we
we should write in the right hand column
Earth hold constant right
and change the zeros are you no no it's
six it says six what do you mean six and
then zero No No it should be six and six
actually oh oh oh I I didn't change that
I just assumed that we basically took
place in the first year it takes place
in the first year but it still costs us
the same amount of money in the second
year Oh I thought rebasing was a was a
costume
error okay so put six in there you're
saying yes okay and oh thank you and
whole constant just means
I'll explain I'll explain I will explain
and then there's a couple more just so
I'm clear
at the
page seven I guess are all the rest and
this is the midwives provider and birth
centers
and the
the ambulance
so those three
so it's so so far so good
okay so here's what hold constant means
so we're going to do account so those
are the Rel as I understand that first
either they want to be fixed like the
rebasing or
um the uh one that Mr Lipman brought up
which was the uh
granted State and independent living it
was important that those be fully funded
for lack of a better word at the rates
that were at the amounts that were in
here because the amounts in columns two
and three are actual dollar amounts
so the notion here is those ones that I
put down hold constant they'll be fully
funded so the total of all of those will
get subtracted from the top level number
the 40 million dollars per year in this
case and that will leave some amount of
money per year and that will then be
proportionally in proportion to the way
the other values are set in here to all
the other
things proportionally allocated in this
case downward
since obviously there's not 100 million
dollars worth of 40 million dollars
then I also chat with Mr Lipman briefly
on the way out the door and this relates
to how that's done now you may I call if
I'm wrong I'm sure somebody will pipe
them tell me I'm I'm wrong it won't be
the first time
that for the first it'll take the first
half to get everything
done
but that they could sequence them in
and when I was on the way the door he
said to me well just tell us to do some
percentage in the first half and some
percentage in the second half of the
first half of the next of this year so
the first quarter and the second quarter
of 24.
and I figured well half of them half of
the value not half of the not half of
the rows but half of the value will be
set up in the first quarter so July
August September and then the other half
in the last quarter uh the rest of the
months
um so so that means there'll be less
money you're going to have there'll be
no money going out there doing the first
quarter because there's just still doing
rate setting and there'll be some money
going out in the second quarter because
some of half of them will have been set
up and then there'll be the total amount
if you will which would be 20 million
dollars for the final half of that year
and then
40 million the full 40 million in the in
the year 25. so so that's the notion
behind so that's the way to
get the rates even essentially give us
more money because we know we're not
going to be spending it so we'll apply
it further on down the line
does the does the explanation of the
philosophy make sense
I I could just use a small example and
if we add the 6 million back
what do you think the total amount is of
the hold constant no idea but let me
give you a very simple small example
so let's say we have a hundred and ten
dollars to work with
and ten dollars wants to be held
constant
we subtract the ten dollars
and that gives us a hundred dollars
now let's assume we have two other
entries
uh one is forty
and one is
60.
we're going to
apply
I bet I made this too tough for myself
didn't I Kevin well you're you're too
sleepy that's why I can't do the math
quickly in my head you want to just
finish it up well you report you're
portioning 90 of the money among 90 of
the services
so that's an uh a 10 decrease basically
if if it's that small
okay representative you look like you
had no no you actually asked my question
about what number are we talking about
with the hold constants yeah
as I as I flip through there to hold
constants well I can't do the decimal
point on the MCO payment so I can't come
up with a number either so
um I think I just added it up real
quickly and it looks like of the 40
million of just about round numbers 10
million is being held constant right so
you've got one on page one you've got
three at the top of page
um 2 which is a total of four and then
you've got six on page four which is ten
and and the stuff that's at the very end
is is
um maybe it's 12 because there's a 2.2
million in EMS but it's it's on the
order of 10 to 12 million being held
constant round numbers
um first one degree one significant
digit type stuff
and then the balance of that 40 million
which is on the 28 million is what's
going to be leveraged for increasing
rates so I understand that example
thanks
I
I think that just to go back to the why
40 million well because we can
anticipate that the Senate is at least
going to do 40 per year uh
Senator Rosenwald I think proposed 145
million and I think that was for the
two-year then then Bradley counter
proposed 80 million of which it was 40
40 and so so I'm trying to trying to
anticipate and skate to where the puck
will be to use the hockey term and I I
think I think we'll be in line with the
Senate if we're thinking in terms of 40.
now I I don't I don't I I wish it were
more I wanted to be more and so as we
complete our decisions today I would
like our priority to be to shift
whatever money we can into the Medicaid
rate reimbursement number so that
there's more more to distribute
that that's where I'm coming from
representative
I agree with all that but back to
represent representative stringham's
point at the beginning so clearly if if
if the numbers in the under the 24 and
25 change in other words you're changing
that proportion so if you all have input
there and also the whole constant what
you know is that have we chosen it an
inappropriate set to hold a constant so
it's if the philosophy works
then there can be we can muddle with the
rate with the ratios and with what's
Constant if that makes sense
representative thanks I just have a
question for representative do you for
the once you pay the hold constants
um what's your thought process for
Distributing the remainder
is it
but that was the ratio part
so oh what's figuring out what the ratio
is for all the others based on what they
hold here for 100 percent
all right make sense yeah
which which that's what I say you you
can so you you all we all can impact
that if we feel the ratios are wrong in
other words if you feel like whatever
see if I should be getting more a
greater percentage of the of the total
pot whatever the pot may be then by
changing the numbers the ratios you
affect that does that make sense
sure it can get pretty complex and and
basically I think we have about 20
minutes before we have to make this
decision and we still have to hear from
representative Stringham and we need to
hear from representative walner now
no I just I just want to so the 40
million is per year
40 million yes a year thank you I just
wanted to be sure I understood that
representative stream yeah so uh you
know our our Amendment comes out
substantially more but more like 75 and
100 just rough ballpark numbers
um and so you know I hope things like um
um if we pass for example the uh the
movement of the disability funds that
that could 100 be a portion to this and
and uh that uh that we can reach these
numbers
um
um can you pass out the the draft of of
our Amendment and what it looks like and
structured uh so
um
you know a few of the few of the changes
from this for the values
um uh the disability Community asked for
18 but three percent turns out it's
already in the budget because three
percent
um uh used to be taken out of those fees
and then given to the area agencies the
area agencies are separately
um
paid now with a separate code and line
item and there was no corresponding
decrease in the services line so
essentially there was a built-in three
percent increase
so
um that actually
um
uh you know reduce the budget by about
28.6 million so and um so because that
number is eerily similar to that's the
same 28.6 from the reduction of the
three accounts you guys are we're
talking about the same thing oh oh you
might be right uh that that 28.6 was
from the three accounts
um
uh yeah I'd have to I'd have to look up
and see what that is but it made a
significant down down uh size and the uh
we had we had already added the home
health aids that you talked about that's
in that's in our current Amendment
and um
um
let's see
uh we there's 19 categories of services
uh in here
um and if adding in the granite state
Advantage uh would um uh added another
uh
uh 5.25 million over two years so we
used a 25 kind of reduction using Yuri
numbers yesterday uh representative
Edwards
um talking with Kevin
um
uh this morning we thought the best way
to do it actually is for the increases
have the first year be 50 of the second
year uh because
um uh if we just made each one three
quarters of the year then
they would be limited in how much they
could spend in that individual provider
category so instead we took them down by
50 percent and then took 25 percent said
okay here's you can apply these in the
first year to whichever uh rate increase
you're implementing sooner so that we
still end up with it with the same
numbers
um
so
has that gone come around so so this
this this is a sufficiently uh dense
document with a lot of great Concepts in
it that I am not able to process could I
ask a question yeah
are there as many
uh Roman numerals on your Amendment as
there are rows in this document
in other words did you account yeah
everything's accounted for
um that's that's in this document so
really and did you hold any constant
well basically did you fully find any
that's a better way to put it if if you
if you if you're
um if you fully fund yours then ours
should be should be close to Identity if
we fully find everything you mean that's
not my asking though yeah did you fully
fund all the years are fully funded
yeah except for we you know we changed
the disability by by uh three percent
and um
um so it's it used to be 18 was was the
ask and we reduced that to 15 okay
because there's money elsewhere in the
budget okay so we also took out the one
and a half million uh for beds uh that's
in there because that's also in another
part of the budget
so it's not needed
there's a slight there's a somewhat
increase in emergency services for
ambulance uh based on a fee schedule uh
amount that that
um we think is critical uh
to bring a Lifeline to that to that
troubled business
so here's one way of looking at this and
I'm assuming your second number in every
case
is a full Year's value
that's right okay and all of these had
pretty much the same value in each year
not 100 but is that what sort was that
your intent I realize you it's lower
because the same reason I lower them but
was your intent that if if they could be
Zapped to the full amount you know on
day one January uh July 1st which intent
that it would be equal a year year one
year too it would be if you could if you
could apply it on July 1st it would be
equal year to year okay so essentially
with with a few exceptions some of them
like if you look at the CFI requested
rate increase at 7.6 and 9.3
for example
you mean you match this
right okay so in some sense the
your numbers are just the numbers that
we could plug in as the ratios if you
wanted to look at it that way in other
words you have instead of 60 well you
actually have the same number for the
for long-term nursing care so that would
be an approach it would obviously would
not come out with your 100 million or
come out with 40 million but that is an
approach that would if you think you
change the ratios and that's really
important and I know the 100 million Top
Line number is really important as well
but if it's also important that the
ratios be somewhat slightly different
that's an easy thing to change
so so I'll come back to you on that I I
I'm again I'm just trying to map this
document that I solved for the first
time four minutes ago and making sure I
understand it on like for example uh
page two
uh my my fifth grade teacher will be
proud if I get this right it looks like
Roman numeral 17 on page on line 30.
relative to
Medicaid birth rates and non-hospital
environments so so because they went for
a hundred thousand hundred thousand and
you're anticipating uh just a percentage
in the first year that's you've you've
you've kind of respected the request but
you've made it 75 100 because you have
some assumptions about the rate at which
they could spend in the first year
anyways right they have to um they have
to announce changes in fee schedules
sometimes
I get all that okay so so now we're at
19 on line 35. This appears to be
greater than the 2.2 2.2 and so I is
that a typo or did something else go
into your analysis for ambulances yeah
so the the
um the the ambulance uh figures which
you know we've got a lot more input on
um you know we we felt that they should
be addressed at the service level and
that
just just upping them to the Medicare
rates where you know for example last
biennium ambulance services were
increased to 188 percent of Medicare
because of
um
problems with the Medicare fee schedule
for this one type of service so
um so on on page three at the top the
ambulance codes the primary service
codes
a0425 through a0429 we actually set
rural and urban urban levels for that
sure I'm just again trying to make sure
I'm tracking with what you're thinking
and what I think I heard you say is that
I'm just going to refer to it as the
Moynihan document because I think
everyone understands the term but they
their their work effort resulted in 2.2
and 2.2
and so with you've gotten supplemental
clarification on that did that also come
from the Moynihan effort or did it come
from something somebody operating
outside of the the Moynihan coordination
Circle
uh well I think probably both but most
of my input comes from talking to
ambulance providers who I've been
working with on other legislation okay
I'm reluctant to do that because I I I I
I like the fact that Mr warnahan got
everyone together and got everyone
looking at the same thing and and and
and and and and dismissing just one part
of it and bringing in external to that
it just feels to me you know sort of a
bad process but that's just my opinion
uh representative hole thank you Mr
chair
um member question for Mr Stringham
representative Stringham did you put
this together in a spreadsheet form
anywhere or is this only in the
amendment Word document form
and if you have it in a spreadsheet can
you email it
yeah I'll send you what I got but I
didn't
um but it's pretty much just a number
cheat so okay
and then another am I is somebody over
here wanting to ask questions because
I'm looking down mostly
okay so so on line item 27 I think
that's Roman numeral 16 that's 675 000
sounds familiar is is that is that the
representative Amendment finding its way
into this document as well
just because I think 675 was the same
number you pitched yesterday
and this is substance for Prevention
Services
yeah no so it just happens to be the
same number it was well my number is
actually 625. right that has nothing to
do with this okay
yeah this this is on on the um Moynihan
sheet sud outpatient
um uh line at least you know depends
which version of this you have but yeah
if you use Earth sheet uh representative
okay it's 900 900 and then the first
year at this point is three quarters of
of the second year
you know I you know just as a general
statement you know I hope we can come up
close to these numbers because I really
you know the the first way I started is
saying well what if we match Medicare
rates and you know that that a lot of
times are pretty um
uh stingy in some in many fee schedules
and you know pretty much we would need
the budget of Vermont and Maine on top
of our budget to bring it up to that
level so you know this is this you know
we're we're starting from an extremely
low level and
um uh you know most of this you know is
pretty much just you know on average a
uh cost of living you know it's 12 12
you know if across the board if we fund
it at this level and we have service
problems now uh with the rates that we
have and if we're going to start you
know two years then this next biennium
at you know a lower real rate than where
we start where we uh started the
previous biennium I I I think it would
be um
uh you know difficult for us to see a
kind of across-the-board improvement in
service fulfillment so would you believe
I agree with everything you just said
but but I I also need to worry about we
all
also have to worry about we can't spend
money we don't have and and so that that
to me that's the issue of how much money
we could we have we can stand to invest
in this we're already investing more
than the governor just talking about it
you know so so the governor's budget is
higher our Revenue estimates are higher
than the ones we're working with so if
we take something this significant and
add it to the governor's budget
we have to go back and also be looking
for sources of the funds for this so so
I I Now understand your your document
thank you are there representative
walner
the subject but it's something that I'm
seeing here trying to Grapple with
yesterday
we
um talked about
the the DD funding and how we were going
to
bring forward
the um
the lapse basically we were going to
bring that forward
and
I can't remember how much it was but it
seemed like it was around 25 million
dollars is that right 28.6
so how did you account for that in your
40 I mean it seems like it's really
important that the DD community at least
no of course we have don't say we
haven't it's right there it's actually
higher than your number
I mean proportionally it's okay so
it's not higher in an absolute sense
it's higher so you're basically 35 and
put in 29. so I just went through your
document and a lot of this lines up
except it gets into a situation I don't
understand some of it but just to go
down from the start
you've got 16.5 million from nursing
homes you've got 9.3 million for CFI
which I realized in the first half of
the of this one it's actually lower
um you've got 2.5 for
the Assisted Living you've got 966 for
the MCO payments in conjunction with the
Medicaid payments you don't have the
granite state listing in there yet I
don't see it you do have the private
duty nurses although I also note that in
the original document the first year was
less
um you have the case management at six
hundred thousand
you got Community Mental Health rates
wages at 14 soon is the document you've
got the housing at 2.2 million
you got the rebasing at four so that's
actually a little bit lower
and again I'm just saying low with
respect to the Monahan document not
lower than respect excuse me sorry I'm
just trying to wrap my brain you were
going down I went too fast you're right
you were going down the second set of
numbers and then on that last one you
switch to the first number
yes you said no she's right because it
says zero but we actually switched that
to six because at the beginning of the
meeting your colleague here explaining
to me that it was six both years so
rebasing was six and six and then the
next one does that make sense that's
Roman numeral x 10
and then I I skipped over 11. that is
the um the rate adjustment that is the
same 4 million
and then we get to what you I think you
were talking about representative
wellner which is the DD and brain injury
which in the document that Monahan
provided us was was 35 million and I
think well you just explained when you
roughly took what we
took out if you will yesterday and put
it in here the 29 million which that
makes sense uh no no that's that's not
what she was referring to that's not
what I meant Oh No but that is the DD
and brain injury what she was taught can
I yeah well in case I just want what I'm
what I'm saying is if uh using your
way of doing it they won't get
back
the amount they have put in
from
lapsing over I don't think I don't see
unless you well that's probably true the
attempt was not to right the whole point
of that was not to put it back because
it's not going to get spent
that's that's the idea that was dollars
that was sitting at the bank at the end
of next year along with monies that
won't get spent in the next biennium
they have this huge pile of cash sitting
in those accounts come
the 30th of June in 2025 and it seems
the point was to in every case here the
point was to try to get
funds and spend them not necessarily
spend the same account but spend them
the Medicaid rate adjustments
does that make sense so you are taking
that to put into your 40 million dollars
it's part of your 40 but it won't
necessarily be used all for what the DD
Community okay thank you because I don't
think we voted on that yet and I think
if we vote on that to take it to take it
out that that would go in addition to
the 40 million it'll be additional money
that's available to spend however we
want to spend it no no
okay I do want to finish my leave your
list but um to be clear
when so the 40 million is a number I
just picked out of the air I realize you
didn't pick your 200 million out of the
year but it's kind of the same thing
it's another number
um
I did that because
I wanted to try to get something going
here we've sort of been beating around
the bushy on this for a long time
over the last few days you may have
recalled my saying repeatedly let's take
this out of so we can have more cat more
General funds available for this purpose
I don't yet know that number even though
we've taken a bunch of votes I haven't
yet seen how much General funds have we
freed up is it 200 million is it 80
million is it zero okay so it's some
number
separate from this
does that make sense okay could I just
finish on the list because it kind of
ran into a part where I where I lost
track of what you were doing
so so right Roman numeral level I'm
equating the 29 million to the 35 so
that's essentially a reduction
and then I'm skipping down to uh
opioid starts to fall apart on me
there's nothing there in the
in the Monahan is is that where you
substitute in some numbers or the 40 for
4.85 and then the 400 000 or is it does
some of that fit in with the MedEx
population and Medicaid population stuff
so I'm I'm looking at Roman numerals 13.
14. 15 16 I kind of lost track of how
those tie to
the Monahan
sure
I think I did the same thing that Miss
sorry representative erf did which is I
took the Moynihan document put 75
percent in
and and multiplied it by column C right
just to get us the numbers and then ran
down and started looking at differences
and there is a significant change
starting in line 13 on page two can I
explain 13 sure so the opioid treatment
um the one that's blank there's two
numbers below if you add those two
numbers up that's 13. and the reason why
they split it out that way is so that we
could see the impact on the fact that
some of these are 90 matched and some
are 50 percent matched and uh with the
with the rough numbers so there it's not
that the opioid treatment wasn't
unaccounted for it was accounted for in
the next two blocks so those two
together make up okay appropriation
under 13. so that the Medics and
Medicaid population
correct yep okay
so then continuing you got residential
okay cool got it
and then you've got a mask whatever that
is representative Stringham I guess I
don't understand sud the difference on
La in section Roman numeral 12 right the
21.9 that goes to 29 which is a very big
difference from the 35 that they had
agreed to
uh so when um this year or this biennium
they're implementing a change to the
disability
um developmental disability payments uh
the the area agencies which are under
contract uh to oversee the management of
those systems regionally used to get a
three percent payment out of any service
that was provided to their customers
that's the way they got paid this year
this this year they're they're going to
get paid directly
from
um uh By You Know by us a fee about
three percent but um but there's nothing
in the there's no they didn't reduce
those other payments by the three
percent so it'd be even so effectively
there was already a three percent
increase in the developmentally disabled
waiver fee schedule with us doing
nothing so giving them 18 or I'm sorry
15 percent
um uh really three percent was already
accounted for in the current budget so I
reduced it
um to just their ask is that helpful
that was very helpful thank you
so just to follow up your your list and
our lists are pretty much the same it
appears
other than the the you have big totals I
have smaller totals but
but it does fit in with the philosophy
if you it seems like in some case well
you held everything constant so I guess
the question would be if you can buy
Into My Philosophy our philosophy
um are there some that you would hold
constant and some that you would allow
to go up or down mostly down mostly down
thank you
well yeah you know if we don't have
enough money and we're trying to reach
consensus we have to have some
methodology and so but um I'm hopeful we
can find enough money that that your
your amount percent reduction is zero
percent
so so while we keep hope alive I think
the question I didn't hear yes or no
from you on is the to the question of
and Earth has representative erf has
proposed some very specific line items
that he would hold constant
and these are being held constant by a
combination of relatively small dollars
and relatively High priorities I think
so
so I think I think what we're looking
for from from the Democrat Caucus
because we did caucus on this is is that
these that representative Murph has put
here is hold constant we we would like
to hold constant and to the extent that
there's any variability or difference
left that that we would we would talk
about that later and hopefully find some
more money to close the gap
so kind of the first pass at this is can
you agree with us that I hate this we
versus them thing but
um but in any case can it be agreed to
that uh the the items that says Earth
hold
constant that you can you can buy off on
that that you're okay with that
you'd like to talk about that because we
did not talk about that concept
a represent a hole
before we would break for any potential
caucus
um I appreciate what representative
Stringham had to say relative to the 15
versus 18 versus kind of the three
percent
double Accounting in the DD and brain
injury and if I understand his comment
correct right the 35 million that was in
the Monahan document might actually want
to be 29. did I get that correct right
and and it says 29 million in Roman
numeral 12 uh for the second year of the
biennium so that's where that yes okay
so trying to be Equitable right because
in some cases the percentage increase
isn't going to be 18 like we're seeing
there we're going to see right 15 across
the board
um maybe we want to make a tweak to this
proposed sheet by representative erf for
that line item which is on the top of
page five
um and I'm I'm willing to propose that
change from the 35 down to 29 which is
in keeping with what representative
Stringham had to say
um
I I think it feels to me like we've
achieved a point of kind of
understanding of the two proposals that
I believe we should just uh recess for
five minutes
I think it'll take longer than five
minutes what do you want I would say
probably fifth
okay so
um
we're going to recess to uh 1105. I had
to cut your budget a little bit
in the middle
okay
foreign
should so this is the 30-second warning
so sir representative walner I was just
waiting for you to come to a natural
conclusion
oh okay
um uh recess is over uh time to get back
to work
um we we have some more math that that
Jr or representative hole is doing for
us but so I I want to I just want to say
where I where I think we are in the
total process
I I think
the governor's team had many many months
to come up with a proposal to Target
some rates
um and didn't but encouraged us to do so
so this committee basically is the first
time in this budget cycle that anyone
has tried to do the rate targeting
the the effort
that was undertaken in the private
sector and we were referring to Mr
Moynihan as as the the creator of the
Moynihan spreadsheet
um obviously uh deserve a lot of credit
but I'm sure there were 10 20 people
behind the scenes that helped give us
this spreadsheet that we have all used
to normalize our thinking about what we
want to do
um so so I think that's good we've
gotten Community input we've considered
it uh and uh and further to the point I
think representative stringham's
initiative
to uh transfer the Moynihan document
into
[Music]
um
hb2
is is is positive we we have some
differences of opinion on the amounts
and and we'll we'll share those with you
with with you all here after
representative whole does the math but
they're they're not going to be the same
ours are going to be lower
um and we kind of knew that but but the
but the good news is I think we can send
something along in the process where the
Senate isn't going to have to invent the
wheel because I think we've invented a
wheel here on how we're trying to do
these Medicaid targeted rate increases
and I think we should feel kind of good
about that but but in any case we're
going to give them our idea our
methodology our contact information
and and that should help I think this is
going to end up at the end of this
process with Medicaid targeted rate
increases that you know probably
everyone can live with so
um so I just want to say I I I like the
process I I although we're not going to
end up agreeing today on the amount I I
don't think it's essential that we do
anyways because the process continues
and the Senate has different numbers are
going to look at anyways so are you how
far away are you
because I don't want to stall anymore on
that subject that's boring
foreign
I'm going to take my shot at describing
the concept of what we're doing
and uh and then and then hopefully the
numbers will be ready by then
I
our concept is that we're we're gonna
we're gonna you know take the the
boilerplate of The Proposal the
amendment that Scott Wallner tolerski
Stringham and nordgren we're going to
take take your Amendment we're going to
accept this Baseline
we're going to
um add a little bit more flexibility in
here because the way this is currently
written is that
um there's there's sort of these
artificial uh buckets where uh we're
we're creating some inflexibility and so
in order to give the department more
flexibility
one of our key Concepts is to take take
the amount of money that's being
proposed like let's say I'll I'll do
line 16 because I think maybe I can do
the math accurately there's there's
there's 15 million
that you propose in
line two or line 16 rather between the
two-year biennium
what what we'd like to do to give the
department more flexibility than what's
in here
is to say okay
um Mr chair go
I'm I'm not Am I Wrong well I'm not sure
if that's the intent behind the math I I
think I'm not done though well no I know
but but biennium total I believe would
be 18.6
I'm saying on line 16 5.7 to plus 9.3 is
15 million I'm just trying to explain
the flexibility part of this I know what
you're trying to do but we have to
clarified Mr Ripple so the number he's
starting with should be the full as
though it was
for the whole biennium
we're doing the math on
can I can I suggest a structure for the
resulting Amendment I'm going to go
ahead and finish because I I think I've
heard you I think I've got the process
and I I think I'm going to get there so
so to follow this example just a little
bit further on line 16 there's 15
million in the total in the two years
of that 15 million to 25 of that total
would go would be sort of the earmarked
for Year One
fifty percent of that 50 50 15 million
would be earmarked in two in year two
which leaves another 25 and then I
understand Mr Ripple can write language
so that if the department is able to
implement the other 25 earlier
then they can do that is is is that the
structure that we discussed that's
exactly correct and it's also the
structure that I suggested to
representative Stringham uh earlier this
morning so he will also have another
version of his Amendment coming forward
that does the same thing I would suggest
that in the case of Roman 2
that's not the clearest example because
there were supposed to be two different
amounts in the two different years CFI
had two different amounts in 24 and 25
to begin with
um if you took an example like
let's say on line 28
that was originally intended to be 600
000 per full year for each of the two
full years
so for fiscal 25 you would keep this
assuming you kept these numbers which
they will change
but if you kept these numbers in fiscal
25 there would be 600 000 appropriated
in fiscal 24 there would be
300 000 appropriated
for the second half of the year
then you would take
150 000 and an equivalent figure for all
of these amounts and appropriate it in
one lump sum to the department to
implement rate increases earlier than
January 1st if possible okay so the key
distinction of what I said and what
you're saying is that rather than keep
the extra 25 percent floater money
associated with each account you'd pull
them all out and give flexibility for
that cumulative number across all the
accounts that's correct
I understand that okay representative
Waller Okay Kevin
um so providers would expect
a rate increase on January 1.
yes everybody would get a rate increase
on January 1. right and then there would
be this pool of money
that some providers or maybe all
providers would get an additional
amount of money
as
the department was able to make those
allocations yes
I think I've got it thank you
okay so I'm still representative norgren
thank you Mr chair and then can we have
a comment from the Department after we
figure out what you're saying and what
everyone is agreeing to we we can
solicit a comment yes I I I I I I just
want to finish the the train of thought
here and okay so so what I would say is
that
if we can agree to this past discussion
about adding the flexibility then the
the red approach
to this bill and the blue approach are
compatible now we we've agreed to agree
with each other on the structure
the only difference that we haven't
talked about yet are the numbers and and
that conversation is coming but I just
wanted to clarify that I think we've
agreed to agree on the the framework
so I think what what you're the way I
hear what you're saying is the framework
is the fact that every Roman numeral one
two three four and five is the same in
both proposals and
um not the same number but the same
topic
and uh the Roman numeral relates to the
same topic yes and uh so there's an
appropriation part where we're amending
um HB to line 257 uh together or or um
uh in the same way so there's at least
some kind of structural close similarity
uh between the two bills or two
amendments and and I'm seeking agreement
on the framework of the structure and
and I I kind of think we've got it and
and if if we don't then I probably not
explained it properly but I'm trying I'm
trying to hit the same structure
do you are you hearing the same
structure I am I think the in my mind
the only question that remains is
whether
the resulting amendment should replace
the existing section 257 or be in
addition to it
representative verft do you have a
opinion on that
I'm not sure what is it what is existing
one 257 is the 17 million per year for
across the board rate increases yeah
interesting you should bring that up so
apparently from what I understand
speaking of Representative Stringham
their plan did not include they were
starting from a baseline of zero whereas
we were starting from a baseline of
the 17 million but netted out by the
hospital piece which I think worked out
to about a 7 million so I'm actually
comfortable going either way it doesn't
really matter to my mind because the
idea is if we start from a baseline of
zero as I I understood them to have done
then the 17 million is part of what can
go towards the 40 million which might
actually get us up more like to 57
million or 50 million or whatever
with this distributed approach as
opposed to
what I thought our philosophy was and I
thought actually the whole group's
philosophy but I guess I was mistaken
that the 3.1 percent wanted to be
assured that it went across the board so
essentially what we're what we're saying
here is do we just take that across the
board thing out and I honestly don't
know what the impact of that is because
I don't know if this includes
every rate that should be increased or
just the ones that are really important
and that's sort of what you're what
we're deciding here in other words other
people that would get a 3.1 raise
outside of this
or not and should they so so my
assumption throughout throughout this
has been that that we accept the 3.1
percent Baseline and that everything
we're talking about is an incremental
addition to that the the thing that we
learned in the discussion though was
because the hospital was willing to not
forego their portion of the 3.1 percent
we could either either like like
just account for it in what we're doing
with with the rate increases by freeing
up the hospital's portion and adding it
to the 40.
I would add it to the 40.
well that that's part of the problem but
the first the first question we need to
answer is
do we exclusive of the hospitals
do we want to give an across the board
3.1 rate increase I have said yes and I
and I agree with that but I believe the
other folks have a different perspective
and even if we agree to that
do we know how to express that
in we'd have to modify the 250 7
language to express that as well so
first of all exclude the hospitals and
give everybody else across the board and
then tack this onto it
go ahead and I think you could easily do
that by reducing the Appropriations from
17 million per year to 12 and saying
that the rate increases shall exclude
hospital inpatient and Hospital
outpatient services
so then we'd be amending 257
and then that whatever we're proposing
to do with the this this structure that
we've seen today this would be a new hb2
item that should be close to the number
257. it could be included
it could be included or it could be a
new section either way a new section but
its own section we're making a new
section yep okay our Mr chair I think we
still need to come to some agreement
with the with the whole group do we are
we do we do the across the board 3.1
percent exclusive of the hospitals or do
we not do that because I believe the
other folks just so representative
you're and I are in agreement I'm just
more methodical about how we're getting
there
okay but I do incur I do support the
encouragement because we're going in the
very same direction
so
if you all understand what we're talking
about on 257
what we'd like to do is leave 257 alone
and we're recommending an amendment to
it to reduce the numbers from 17 million
in each of the two years to 12 million
the difference between the 17 and the 12
is the amount that the hospital said
they don't need in this go around
so this 257 the amounts would change and
we'd we'd have to write in a provision
to make it exclusive of the hospital
portions
so so that takes care of that and then
what what we would like to do then is to
add as a new section
um this you know if not the the Walnut
tolersky Stringham Northern Amendment
you know our our vision of using your
structure with different numbers
so so when we get done with this
there'll be two sections dealing with
Medicaid rate increases
and so it's in a new number so comment
so basically we have we'd have 24
million left in in um
uh in the existing line item there and
the question is whether a hundred
percent of that would apply to the
services that we currently describe uh
in this new Amendment or not and um if
if it is a hundred percent described
then the final number should come out
identical and I have no estimate of how
much whether whether there's any minor
services that haven't been Incorporated
uh uh in in the rate increase request so
um that might present a bit of a
challenge for you know doing a final
determination but we'd be looking
probably at only a few million per year
Max difference so and and I I do think
that structure is a little bit harder to
to follow mathematically but
we can get there we have to might the
department have a perspective on that
sure Mr Lipman are you following all
this I mean this is all pretty detailed
and gnarly
um
yeah so so let's break this into two
sections
the first section and it may be three
sections the first section is I just
want to deal with the proposal that for
257 we reduce the amounts from 17 to 12
in each year freeing up five per year
from the hospitals to put back in as
other rate increases Above and Beyond in
other words we're trying to give
everyone their what they're expecting
because the media has been saying 3.1
percent right so so I want to be able to
stick our finger in something to say
okay there's that 3.1 percent that we've
been promising you in the media for six
months so so just on that section
are you what are your what are your
thoughts
with that number I guess the only
um
subtlety on it was weather and those
brought up by representative Stringham
was well the DME was included because in
the governor's proposal it was just
services
we didn't talk about that earlier
because I rep and I'll tell you why I I
because as I was looking at this trying
to understand the framework
I noticed that the Disposable medical
equipment in the pharmacy amounts
weren't in here and those were topics
that represented Stringham suggested
initially and not being in his amendment
I just assumed that you would either
want to deal with them separately or not
at all
yeah I think I think uh the conclusion
we had from the other hearing that any
adjustments in the DME in Pharmacy
uh expenditures were accounted for
separately in the budget
so
um I think that they're not accounted
for there's no increase planned for
um rates we do have inflation Factor
built into the Medicaid rates for
General Medical inflation to cover the
cost of do drugs and things like that
but we don't have a rate increase
and that's consistent with the the
governor's budget and the DME portion I
I believe you said something like the
the rate of inflation in DME is pretty
you know pretty close to zero because
their standard you know type of type of
items and they haven't been
uh being modified much is that right
um
my testimony was a little bit different
than that it was that um that there's a
lot of commoditization and that we have
a fee schedule that under our Managed
Care program that requires to pay at
least 80 percent of the Medicaid fee
schedule
um and so that I mean that's that's kind
of that was my testimony
um and that it would probably cost to
bring it up to 100 of the fee schedule
somewhere around three million dollars
to to bring it up to 100 that was what I
had testified when I did the budget
presentation
do you if we were to take those two
accounts Pharmacy and DME
and applied 3.1 percent to that
then that would be less than the 5
million that the hospital is freeing up
is that true
I think it would cover DME Pharmacy I
think it's a different story and I think
would not suggest to to if you were to
do something there would be around the
dispensing rates not the the underlying
product itself
foreign
[Music]
go ahead can I ask a clarifying question
so are there any other
providers outside of what's in this list
in other words do we need to worry about
the 3.1 percent because they're already
gonna they're already they're all
included in here
the for services they're included
oh so that any any rate
that we needed to adjust is included in
that that figure that the governor had
suggested so let me ask a question
different way as
257 exists now
as it exists now
outside of anybody that would be
included in here
would anybody get more money
yes who
um
I'm trying to think of uh say Aba
providers as an example
um that provide the therapy for people
who have uh
okay so so there is a list so there
isn't and there wasn't intention then to
get that 3.1 percent for all services
okay
so so I like what you're doing
is there any opposition to taking 257
trimming it from 17 to a year to 12 and
adding the provision that the 12 is not
intended to include the hospitals
service providers as as part of 257. is
there any opposition to that I I'm not
looking for a way to
take that five million and five million
to 10 million and not spend it on
Medicaid rate increases I'm just saying
that this is intended to be our
satisfaction of the 3.1 promise that's
been floating around
is there any opposition to that
I just want to understand where the
house the hospitals will get the 3.1 no
so you're taking the you're taking that
completely away
and okay I was just looking at the first
rate sheet we got thank you
so so that was a question do you have
any opposition to The Proposal
representative nordgren
so the 12 million would be the
difference of taking the hospitals out
of that plan okay thank you
and and the testimony is really clear
they're they're okay with that and and
so that finds US 10 million to go into
this this independent rate increase
exercise
and the other thing it does is that it
reduces all these numbers
by the amount that the current 12 and 12
would provide just because we already we
had included the 17 and 17. uh as you
know starting from zero so now we're not
going to be starting from zero for for
those types of providers or we could do
language saying uh that uh including the
3.1 percent this is how much uh
Appropriations are allowed for these
groups is it Kevin does that make sense
so so my intent has always been to use a
3.1 percent as a Baseline and the
Monahan document as the incremental
supplement above and beyond the 3.1
percent and when we receive this
document I tried to ask the question is
this above and beyond the 3.1 percent or
did you anticipate the 3.1 percent in
these estimates I thought I heard an
answer but now that I now that you're
right here welcome from Puerto Rico
do you do you just want to tell us come
on up
and and
um you're not nearly 10 enough
canned enough
and I'll try not to answer in Spanish
um the uh
the spreadsheet that the group put
together uh started from zero it didn't
start from 17.
well that's that's kind of happy news
because I I've been seeing it a
different way I've seen this above and
beyond the 3.1 percent and you've got
the 3.1 percent included in these
numbers so some something tiny like you
know the midwives for a hundred thousand
dollars you're you already anticipated
at a hundred thousand some some amount
on that hundred thousands that include
the 3.1 percent to their rate was
already included in this hundred
thousand total
I think the answer to that is no
um if you read the explanations for each
of these sections so for example on the
nursing home for example it was based
upon recapturing 50 of the budget
neutrality so we so the WC here of 16.5
million that presumed that
did not presume any portion of the 17
million
okay so if we gave the 16.5 that's
suggested here plus the 3.1 percent they
would end up better than what you all
intended
that you all requested yeah if you fully
if you took section 257 down to the 12
million
took 10 and took those two fives and
pushed it into you know this chart you
know I think you start getting closer to
the Walmart
at all number
um by doing that so
um I don't know the and some of the
small ones they may do better you're
right yeah okay no I I think I get it do
you get it
so one question could could we handle
this just by saying all non-hospital
services not mentioned uh in this
provision shall re receive an increase
of 3.1 percent effective July 1. 20 uh
Mr Ripple I I think you're in the best
position to answer that did you hear the
question
I did I that is something that you could
yes you could write that in and it would
have that result I guess the question is
what amounts would you want to
appropriate for that appropriate for
that and how would it work in the
context of the overall Amendment but yes
you could do it
and you probably couldn't do it on July
1 right
well I'm not sure I would ask HHS to
weigh in on that but if you're treating
it like everything else on this
spreadsheet it would go into effect
January 1st or earlier if possible
so kind of it could be a no later than
one January 24 and if they can do it
earlier they can do it earlier
yes
so what what I like about that is IT
addresses you know should somebody have
been left uh left out inadvertently that
at least say at least in this law they
get 3.1 percent and we think it's a
pretty small number but but yeah so so
back to the question is there any
opposition to The Proposal
because I want I'd like to take a Strava
without representative Weiler here and I
want to know if I'm walking into a trap
are you including what represents I'm
just talking about 257 right now that I
want to get a 257 moved
and we've talked about the concept A few
times
go ahead well I mean it could include
what he just said which is
all all that's going to apply to is
those that are not hospitals and not
otherwise included in here
these no this this is this is going to
be incremental right now we're just
dealing with the 3.1 percent across the
board exclusive of hospitals we're going
to deal with the the the the amendment
as a new section
I understand what you're saying I just
want to take into consideration I don't
think that's what representative
I think he did he just added one July
and and I don't know that we can do one
July representative Edwards well no I
think the key thing the key thing was
including in this one Amendment all the
services that get rate increases so if
we do it this way we don't have to
change any of these other other numbers
we don't have to try to back out how
much 3.1 percent is of the assisted
living facility I don't want to back
them out I want to I want to establish
the base and I want to add to it with
the new section that's that's what I'm
trying to get done
yeah I guess what I'm saying is 3.1
percent you have you if you're adding to
3.1 percent to get to two and a half
million
then how much of that was 3.1 percent
because you're saying okay that other
thing was already accounted for in this
other other segment of hb2 because the
Deltas between this spreadsheet and
anything that would be 3.1 percent are
so small
I would just basically assume it into
the math and and just still still work
off of this spreadsheet
uh targeted increases
just trying to keep it simple
you know let's let's just go ahead and
meet our commitment to the 3.1 percent
promise across the board and get that
all out of out of the way and then we
can figure out on the one hand
spreadsheet using your framework
you know how much we can agree to on the
line items so two steps is there any
opposition to modifying 257 as we've
discussed which is to keep the 3.1
percent
change the numbers from 17 to 12.
exclusive of hospitals all services
representative Edwards I don't mean to
just for clarity there was one group of
providers that were not on the
spreadsheet that would be captured by
your example of 3.1 percent it's a small
group but it's Physician Services so we
had talked to the medical society about
this and so here's the good news Mr
morning by keeping 257 a general in all
services exclusive of hospitals those
Strays there may be even a second one
that you don't know but if there's any
Strays they'll all get the 3.1 percent
absolutely yes so
go ahead sorry I was I was busy on a
spreadsheet so that ends up totaling at
12 million instead of 17. right because
we're assuming the number 5 million per
year is the hospital was the hospital
share thank you
all right
is there any opposition to 257 is
discussed do you know do you know what
we wanted I want to do with 257 do you
understand it
I think since you have to write it I
think all you want to do with 257 is
reduce the appropriation from 17 to 12
per year and exclude hospital inpatient
and outpatient services that's all I
want to do
oh
go ahead sorry I thought that um
I guess I don't have 257 in front of me
never mind I will
so you may have opposition to it
so I'm looking at 257 and it doesn't
actually say 3.1 percent anywhere so I
guess my
I just want to make sure that it's also
that it's going to account for the 3.1
percent across the board less the
hospitals that are foregoing theirs
I think representative Stringham has
mentioned that and doing it perhaps a
different way I think
correct me if I'm wrong and I think
representative Edwards wants to subtract
5 million from the total exclude
hospitals but leave the section
otherwise as is
okay
that's my proposal
and then we can have a totally separate
conversation that'll be just as
scintillating as this one on the I'll
call it the Stringham framework
where where it's almost identical we're
accepting the framework with some some
extra flexibility are just our numbers
are just going to be different
so
now I have to wait for my advice chair
do you have any opposition
representative Waller are you opposed
no
I think the worry is just how exactly is
this all worded such that it's clear how
much money goes to each type of
providers and until it's all written out
it's going to be it's going to be two
different so so the way this always
turns out we we kind of talk about it we
agree on the concept we charge Mr Ripple
to go to OLS we get paperwork back we
read the actual language and then we can
revisit it if it's not what we think we
agreed to
yes I think that we need to see it in
writing so but it's a concept you're
okay with the concept so we can
authorize him to get going with OLS
I think we can taking out the three
taking out the hospital from the from
I think we are okay with that
also by taking it out you've taken out
five million a year
yes okay
all right so
um
sure thanks I just wanted to ask a
question and I know we're going to get
to this because you're directing us to
the this amendment that we're going to
work from but I am curious if
representative erf on your spreadsheet
that you were working on from the
Monahan Amendment were you guys looking
at any of the um can we not have that
conversation right now it's this is
confusing enough I'm trying to take baby
steps
keep everyone on 257 let's get that vote
and your question will have a great
opportunity once we bring up the second
half of this
go ahead you want to talk go ahead
all right so uh I move
that we accept
257 with the concept being
what we've discussed several times
already that we exclude the hospitals
which drops to 17 million a year to 12
million in each year and otherwise
that's intended to make keep our
commitment on 3.1 percent across the
board on all services
if you are in favor of that you will
raise your hand
okay and no one's opposed so so that's
that's nailed down
now we're going to bring up the second
part which is the you want to call it
the Waller framework is that because you
didn't like the Stringham framework
okay the Stringham framework on on
1121 Hotel eleven Twenty One
okay
what what are your questions
representative I was serious
getting two in
two and to go back to the original
philosophy that representative erf had
and my question to him would have been
on the categories that had blanks ones
that I know my side of the table dug
deep in over the weekend trying to fill
in those blanks
were you considering any of those or
just taking them as zeros in terms of
what totals you were looking at the
moment I noticed that you didn't keep a
zero was not blank it was zero that's
the Medicaid Meals on Wheels I didn't
see any places that were blank that you
included but it says raise the rate we
were we ran numbers on how to raise the
rate on that so page two there's an
adult medical day rate that's blank what
Roman numerals page two I'm looking at
the spreadsheet correct okay but what
Roman numeral is that on yours on this
one yeah Meals on Wheels uh Meals on
Wheels I know that's a different one
Meals on Wheels was not blank it was
Zero well it was it was Zero but there
was a note that said they wanted to
raise that they needed to raise it okay
I get that and so the answer is that one
no but are there any that were blank
that you included no medical day is
blank adult yeah and where's that in
here what Roman numeral it's not
representative Stringer do you remember
where we so whoever's here for CFI stand
by because because we're going to come
to that in just a moment did Mr Monahan
leave
okay I don't need him yet but I will
need him not on him yet
so Mr or representative right the zero
that showed up in that spreadsheet
actually had a number it was just it was
a quarter but it didn't
it was a number of significant digits
shown that feel free to sub it in but my
point was I was pretty sure that there
were no blanks that you included over
here that's all I'm saying Meals on
Wheels we can stick that in there I I
concur
I don't remember specifically but I know
representative Wallner was
tracking down
different numbers you got them all I
appreciate it all right then I
appreciate that that was all my
clarification wanted to make sure that
we were both looking at the same amount
of numbers okay are you ready I'm ready
numbers if people want to okay I don't
want to go through the exercise of of
reading the 42 numbers you're about to
read so so can we is it something that
can be photocopied and handed out uh I
will send the spreadsheet over to Mr
Ripple and he can with tweaks to this we
can make it but I have something that
works out the 40.1 million dollars and
it holds the Earth sections constant and
it
um increases all the others at an equal
percentage and includes a small increase
for what was zero on the Monahan sheet
that was originally handed out which
really wasn't zero it was just only one
significant digit for some reason so
it's actually 250 000 and that one has
an 80 thousand dollar increase but when
all said and done we are
effectively at 40 million dollars
could I ask Mr Monahan just one question
sure Mr Monahan Mr Monahan you got two
mics if you could turn one off and turn
them both on and get you in stereo
there's a couple of rows that have
differing numbers like for instance
private duty nursing shows 2.6 in uh in
24 and then 5.3 and in the following
year is there some significance to that
uh there's a person waving their hand
behind you yeah I think Lauren probably
knows better than I do maybe if she
wants to
morning it's uh Laura McIntyre for she
and Finney Capital group and
representing the home health and hospice
Association for the private duty nurses
the reason why we have two different
numbers is we were anticipating that we
wanted to have the utilization be it the
same that it was an FY 22 or I believe
and uh the point of that was just to
kind of stabilize the program the second
number which is larger is to grow the
program
foreign
follow up the other place that that
disparity change shows up as CFI right
every all the other numbers in this
spreadsheet are your
24 and 25 are the same
is it the same rationale representative
the answer is yes thank you
so representative
the 5 million per year that we just
pulled out of 257. what effect does that
have on the 40 that we're seeing on on
your spreadsheet does that make it
effectively 45 or do does it keep it at
40.
it has no effect in the following sense
the 40 has nothing behind it it's
literally a number I pulled out of the
air now it was kind of related to a
number you pulled out but the point is
that that's it
at some point and I'm hoping very soon
we're going to see the impact of all
these votes we've taken the DD piece
yesterday the uh what we just did right
here
um the uh there's been a whole bunch of
votes we've taken where we've taken
things out of the governor's budget and
those GF funds and those should all add
up to a bucket and I don't know how big
that bucket is maybe somebody here does
but it's that bucket that I'm looking
for to get the job so the 40 is a
placeholder until we get better detail
all right
um I'd like to suspend this if I'd like
to suspend this conversation CFI has
been waiting representative waller or
Weller well I'll try one more time
Weiler had some questions yesterday for
CFI so so they've been invited and he's
running back and forth he's got three
divisions he's running around then so so
representative Weiler
thank you I'll wait till the person
comes to the mic
or persons
thank you for coming
so I'm looking between nursing home and
CFI and I know there's a lot of empty
nursing home beds so if somebody comes
that needs a bed do they automatically
end up in CFI if the bed is unavailable
hi good morning my name is Wendy Altman
and I'm the bureau chief of the Bureau
of elderly and Adult Services
um
I can describe to you what we experience
and what we see with individuals who
um
end up needing to have long-term
supports and services whether that's in
the community or a nursing facility
typically
individuals may experience depending on
the nursing facility they want to apply
to or go to
waiting and we oftentimes will work with
them to
um assist with the choices for
Independence waiver program if they have
the eligibility for Medicaid to address
some of their long-term care needs while
they're waiting
um I hope that that answers your
question so if if we are able to fill
more beds because we're giving more
money for the nursing homes than likely
CFI may see a little reduction initially
as these people go and fill bits is that
likely to to Mr White if you want to
speak why don't you just sit at the end
here to your left
and and just use that microphone
so I I just wanted to um provide we were
asked for just for some historical
projections
um and the team went back and looked at
this last night and this morning and so
basically on the CFI utilization side we
saw 14 increase from 21 to 22 and we're
currently projecting a five percent
increase for State fiscal uh State
fiscal year 23 over 22.
um so so this question had come up in
the context of the 15.1 million dollar
uh uh the 15.1 million dollars to be
used for CFI and whether we could
utilize any of that for rate increases
and based on what we're seeing now we we
would not recommend that because we do
based on the past couple of years we are
seeing higher levels of utilization at
the end of the day CFI is an inherently
a cheaper option than than the nursing
home route so so I I just wanted to give
you that information based on that
conversation yesterday
the other question I had was I remember
years ago
um
one local lady was having trouble
getting some of her weekly chores done
and she applied for money and they said
well we don't have anybody now that can
do that she went and recruited a
neighbor that would put in six hours a
week like doing her laundry in her her
ironing and so on and
was able to pay the neighbor and it made
her a lot more comfortable not having a
stranger come in is that still possible
or would that neighbor have to go
through all sorts of Licensing and all
that stuff
thank you for the question
um
individuals who are getting home and
community-based services through CFI can
choose to have somebody they know be
paid to provide the care they don't have
to be licensed as a as a person to be
able to do
what you're describing as homemaking
services and helping with those chores
but they do have to be employed by one
of our enrolled providers so they would
they would be employed with an agency
such as you know a centria or you know
Easter Seals or and they would um
receive their their paycheck through
that enrolled provider
but they don't have to be personally
licensed to be able to do that
would that be much of a task to get
signed up with say Easter Seals if a
person wants a trusted neighbor to come
in and help them
um if that neighbor would agree to being
able to do that
um I don't think that that is a rigorous
process it happens all the time we have
many people who choose to have a family
member or a neighbor or somebody they
know be enrolled and employed to provide
those services so
um uh I've I've asked the question over
time and you know typically you know
depending on
um the individual and the kind of
service it it can take you know a couple
of weeks to get enrolled thank you
do you have further questions sir okay
so so thank you go ahead representative
ask uh Mr White a clarifying question
sure
yeah
just so so I'd put it in my words but I
think you said
over the next biennium you expect to
have the Staffing available to to take
care of all of these 15 million dollars
is that is that accurate
so so can I back up and go because
you're touching on a task that we asked
Mr White to look at over the week
overnight and then that task was uh 234
was just an increased utilization number
and we talked a lot about well if we
don't increase the rate we're probably
not going to expect a lot of utilization
and so we asked Mr White and his team to
come back with two numbers
two sets of numbers the utilization
number and the rate number to where they
can try to balance the two to get what
we really think is going to happen so so
you've asked a good question but it's
it's really two we're asking you for the
result of your analysis
sure and and so what I provided earlier
was the fact that we are seeing an
upward Trend in this area
um and I had said yesterday whether I I
would give an opinion on whether we
could utilize some of that or not for
for rate increases I I mean based on
what we're seeing I I think I I
personally just sitting on on the dollar
side of things that that we have to
manage throughout the year I I would be
a little nervous about making reductions
to that
um I believe we spoke about this
yesterday but the the 15 million if you
took the whole 15 million and put it
towards CFI rate increase it would be
something like four percent so if you
were to take a portion of that say seven
you know you could think two percent
increase for CFI rate increase or if you
took 75 percent think three you know one
percent or what whatever it may be but
but
um when it comes to the workforce issue
I would kind of look towards towards
Wendy and and Melissa uh to speak to
what their seeing on the ground is
they're a lot more informed about that
than myself so so that's not the answer
I was expecting and and maybe maybe I
didn't ask the the ask it right but I'm
I'm I was looking for two sets of
numbers from you one is are the numbers
on 234 if that's meant to capture only
the utilization
and we went over to the Moynihan
document to look at the numbers on it as
the rate increase contribution
I'm just trying to get from the
Department your best sort of
professional Judgment of whether this
these utilization numbers will feed
utilization if we do these CFI numbers
which is 7.6 in the first year 9.3 this
second for 16.9 if we if we invest 16.9
and more rates is that going to
make sure that this the the the the 234
numbers are end up fully committed sure
I I think you're looking for a calculus
level answer and and I don't have my t89
here but
what we're seeing is we are seeing
increased utilization and you know if if
it is you know the purview of the
committee to to take a component of that
and apply that to rates um I think
there's just a certain level of risk
there but but these figures were based
off of what we're seeing for our
maintenance and our projected needs so
that those increases that we're talking
about
can I take a stab at it so everything
you've said makes perfect sense and I
think you said it like two or three
times now but I'm really just asking a
very simple question do you feel you
have this you will have the Staffing the
people to do that provide the services
to use up the funds
it's sort of a yes or no question
and I'm not asking you to be 100
accurate I'm just asking what's your gut
tells you
I I I I would have to have Wendy and
Melissa speak to what they're seeing in
the field because again I'm I'm not
involved with the provider community on
a day-to-day basis I think their
perspective is really important to
consider here and I I realize I'm not
answering your yes or no question and I
know that's annoying I apologize
um uh based on what I'm seeing the
answer diplomatically would be perhaps
it might
um what we hear from our agencies and
the struggles that they have with their
Workforce in their agencies
a lot of their needs and their talking
points are related to what they need to
be able to recruit
additional staff to meet the additional
need and I think ultimately
um
what we can maintain in our budget may
not get us to a place where they are in
a position where they can recruit more
staff
um what they are talking about in these
increases that have been requested as
part of our prioritized need
um and in some of those other bills that
have been introduced
um I think will get them to a place
where they may be able to recruit and
retain the staff to meet
um the demand or the the upward Trend
that we're seeing in enrollment
thank you so I I get that you're seeing
a need
and here's what we're struggling with
we hear that rates are too low to
attract people and if you don't spend
the money it basically it's like we put
it into a bank and it's still sitting
there at the end of 25.
we're trying to figure out is there a
way to get some so that might just wind
up in the bank we don't really want
money in the bank at the end of 25. we
either take that money now at the
general funds portion of it and put it
into addressing rates across the board
so whether it's impacting CFI which
obviously is a good I mean I agree
that's a that's a great goal because
it's the lowest cost absolutely for sure
but if you're not going to spend that
money be just it'd be wiser to put that
money to other areas where perhaps
there is the potential to more fully
utilize their services does that make
sense
that was also yes or no question
that makes sense but I'm also
um thinking about
um
what Nathan
um provided for information in terms of
we we need to balance that and be
conservative in terms of making sure our
prioritize needs Baseline
um it can be there in order to maintain
what we see as an upward Trend in
addition to what is being asked for for
rate increases okay so Sansa you're
saying no
so representative erf would you change
the numbers in 234 yes or no
I guess not based on what we're hearing
okay so uh I would like to go ahead and
have us uh vote on uh 234. uh is there
any opposition to leaving 234 as is
I'm not seeing any okay so if you I
would just say I you know I think we
could you know especially since the part
of the rate increases we might be able
we might be able to reduce those numbers
uh
um somewhat say what is your proposal uh
I would say cut them in half
um especially if they're part of the
rate increases as well so I I intend I
intended to keep these two things
distinct just you know the the this is
just meant to be more utilization while
the rate increases are more
I understand and and Mr White was right
it's calculus I don't know how to do
that that's why I asked the department
to do it uh
okay so representative Waller
I just I just wondered in a case like
this
um I understand the idea of you know
Indy getting to the end of the biennium
and finding out we didn't spin down when
we could have used that for for rate
increase
um
I'm just wondering if we could and I
think we did this with another service
and I can't remember which one it was
right off the top of my head but
a statement that
if they begin to
draw down more than is appropriated that
they could come to fiscal
for
additional additional funds
um I think we did it for some other
service and I can't remember which one
it was we had a statement like that it
was the DD services
okay so we have to decide on 234 today
uh and and right now the only issue that
I see is the dollar amount
otherwise I'd want to keep the language
the same
well it is a dollar
it is a dollar issue but it's also if we
take the money and then they find
themselves in a situation
where
a year from now or a year and a half two
years from now they're they're drawing
down because utilization was higher it
seems like we could do something
in the but we could do something to give
them at least
some options for
um making sure they don't run out of
funds in that line so you have an
amendment to 234 you want to propose
well I don't have it with me I don't
have it right now but you have it in
your head that you could yeah I can talk
to Kevin about it because because we
have to vote on this today we have to be
this has to be in the rearview mirror
okay great I'm just trying to make it so
that people feel a little more a little
bit of comfort and if that if those
funds are taken for real we've already
built some flexibility into how we're
going to draft the Stringham structure
by having some some money able to be
moved around in the between the
bienniums depending on the readiness
wouldn't wouldn't that give you the
flexibility that you're looking for
because I just want to vote on 234 now I
do uh let uh I'm ready for a straw vote
I I I I I hear a proposal to reduce the
amounts I hear a proposal to keep the
amounts the same
I think CFI is probably one of the
smartest things we spend money on I I I
would I would like to get a straw vote
on keeping 234 as is and the dollar
amounts the same
show hands if you support that
okay opposed okay all right very good so
234 is off the table I think
um
do you want while we have the CFI folks
here do you have any specific questions
like representative Stringham or Earth
about their Contra their elements of the
Monahan document
because CFI is listed as its own line
item for 9 16.9 for rate increases
um can you just comment on whether the
rate increases you requested
um you still feel that you kind of need
that full appropriation given that 234
has been uh kept in the budget as
originally requested
so so just to clarify so 234 covers the
service levels the rate increase would
be completely separate from that so I'm
not quite sure I understand the question
at the end of the day there it's going
to be merged numbers yes for the
purposes of being able to talk about it
and see the interaction between these
two variables we're keeping them
separate that way we can explain what we
did to the Senate and why we did it so
this is meant to be the utilization
number and we still have to deal with
the rate numbers okay I think the
question is still a fair one knowing
that at some point these numbers are all
going to merge and we're not no longer
going to be able to distinguish between
utilization and rates I think the
question is given that we're on a on a
trajectory of providing 16.9 million or
thereabouts or some factor of that is a
rate increase
is that as as critical given that we've
we're trying to lock in
234 rates
is that did I get your question right
representative Stringham
yes that's right and and some of the
previous conversations I had I I felt
like there was a little bit of
flexibility
um uh given that there were two separate
buckets and that uh there might be a
little more wiggle room here
so do you want to comment on that should
we look for Mr Moynihan again
so I I didn't prepare that document so I
I can't necessarily if if you're gonna
have a conversation about like the
origin of the rates that are in there I
would have to defer to Mr Monahan is is
Monahan is he around oh there he is I
couldn't see him behind Alex
's beard got so big I couldn't see
around it
and Miss phillipman you're welcome to
jump in on this at any point you you
know when you need to say something to
us
so okay so Mr Monahan you you followed
the conversation I imagine
we've just locked in the the monies in
234 which is I don't know about 15
million dollars
increase for CFI
you've given you've coordinated with the
community and you have another 16.9 that
you did in the rate increase do you
still do you think based on the
methodology and conversations you had
that that this 16.9 is still the right
number given that we just provided 15
million for utilization
uh yes so as the spreadsheet indicates
its rates my take was the same as yours
that the section in House Bill 2 dealt
with utilization
um but I do think they have to work
together you know you can't utilization
won't grow if you don't have the
workforce so that's so I heard a yes I
want to thank you you're the first
person to answer a yes or no question in
weeks so thank you
so representative Stringham do you did
you you okay with what you just heard
yep no Mr lippman what do you want to
say to us I was that for a yes or no
answer
can I say yes to start
um
I agree with uh Simone about it because
CFI from a rate setting purpose is one
area where it gets adversely selected
against because
um based on historical rate changes CFI
often finds itself for the same service
at a different rate and I think the
legislatures have talked about trying to
achieve parity and that's why I think
the money that's here is important to to
get parity with other services
so representative I'm going to just make
sure I touch base with you before we
come off this conversation just you
gotta all the data you need you're still
comfortable with all your analysis for
them for the Medicaid rate increases yes
okay
all right so so so we're still working
on that but thank you so much
um
let's do 232 representative erf
wasn't this you carry forward on the DD
services
because because we haven't actually
taken that off of a hold status
right
um
so there's two parts to this and I'll
just do it from my head since uh camera
kind of caught me off guard
so this is the there's three pieces of
this in HP one and then there's this
piece in hp2 this is the funding we
talked about yesterday from three
accounts it's three DD accounts that is
essentially what would lapse this fiscal
23 but wouldn't lapse because it's
continually appropriated forward and in
one of the accounts we would take 25
million
and transfer to that account
agency income in 24.
and in that same account General funds
reduced by 25 million
same thing with another account we do
nine hundred thousand dollars same game
and then the third account we would take
2.7 million dollars if I'm not mistaken
and do the same thing which would result
in freeing up 28.4 million dollars in
general funds and that again goes to my
thing I've been saying all along that
hopefully we'll be put in that that's
another piece of this of the of the of
the total that we wind up putting in at
that Top Line where the 40 million is
right now does that make are there any
questions does that make sense
foreign
go ahead and keep driving to a yes or no
so I'm 232. okay so I would propose that
we oh I don't have the numbers and hang
on a second
uh I believe it's amendment number one
zero six four
it is yes and if anybody doesn't have a
copy I I do have some extra copies
and then there are also three related
hb1 amendments
oh well done
so I don't know if we're doing this by
motions or whatever but I would I would
suggest that we
did
the package deal I would suggest that we
accept those three hb1 amendments and
the hp2 amendment number
1064 to accomplish what I just described
representative
representative stream I
just everything I've heard yesterday and
you know without
um and continuing to search on it this
looks like a a good way to uh better
manage our state's resources still fully
fund and fully support uh the
developmentally disabled community and
the other programs covered in here I
plan to vote in favor of this amendment
and the other three related amendments
foreign
I got distracted you weren't asking me a
question probably did you did you have a
question for you you or did you just
make an observation I mean this is a
good approach
all right thank you
um representative Waller
okay so uh
so we have let's just vote this as a
package the three spreadsheets that we
saw yesterday that if you add them up
they're 28.6 million that we're taking
uh to fully fund the DD they're going to
still be fully uh supported that wait
list we're going to take that money put
it into the next biennium and
um and and have that money available and
then what does what does one six one one
zero one six four do again
I just looked at it
that does the work that does the work of
it okay
all right is there any opposition
so uh those in favor of except accepting
one zero six four raise your hand
okay opposed no one good so so
we just changed 232 then
uh let's go down to 250 what sorry if I
could so am I correct that in voting on
that as a package you also approved the
three house build one changes as well
yes okay thanks
um okay so down to 254 Family Resource
Center infrastructure
we have we put this on hold
uh who who who was who was opposed to
254 that would like to speak for just a
moment representative hole
sure
um
a lot of parts are moving so we may have
made up the the Gap so far that
um in terms of total funding but last
time I looked we were still trying to
find enough money to to cover some of
the costs that are being concurrently
voted on in the various divisions so
this was one that I was willing to take
out to try and find two million dollars
toward this total budget
so if we were to eliminate this you're
saying we'd have a million dollars a
year that we could add over to the
Medicaid rate exercise correct
is there any discussion around that
proposal any opposition to what
representative Hull just said
I'm going to vote no
um
I think it's a very much used program
and needed and it's it's really primary
prevention of child abuse
okay so the so the proposal on 254 is if
you're in favor of of deleting it or
eliminating it raise your hand
if you're in favor of keeping it it's
the five four okay
now my my intent is for that money to be
relocated to the Medicaid rate increase
I I and and as important as this is I'm
I'm I just have this tendency to think
investing in direct Health Care
is better than trying to manage social
emotional issues in the society at large
and that it's not particularly the
state's business
to to be that worried that involved in
society but so I I'm comfortable with
that decision did you have a comment
my comment is I would disagree with you
that was yeah I'm all for prevention
um attacking Aces
um you know getting to families before
we have them in crisis before we have
children abused before we have children
in the system before we have children
moving into the sununa youth center but
we we disagree on that that's okay I I
agree with everything you just said the
distinction between your point of view
and mine is just simply can the
government resource and fund our way to
that objective
yeah so we've been trying
you know so all right so we just
disagree on the effectiveness of money
in that situation but
all right so I think we've hit
we've hit all of the items on the on
that sheet and then we have some hb2
amendments on the second page that we've
not yet
voted on
um there is there are two amendments
related to the prescription drug
affordability board uh representative
leishman I'd like him to be able to come
in and talk about that and then there's
some discussion that representative
Merchant armor Shaw might want to show
up so
um so why don't we talk about Amendment
zero nine four seven I don't think we've
actually voted on this except I it felt
like we had a consensus that we want to
make sure that the alcohol and drug
abuse commission has
a clear shot at keeping all five percent
for their programs Mr chair zero nine
seven four eight hotel I think I think
you transpose two numbers
did I I'm talking zero nine
seven four yes yes I untransposed them
just before seven that's okay yeah yeah
you're right
okay so do you do you have those
I'm gonna I'm gonna let uh
representative Mooney lead this
discussion I'm going to go check on
representative leishman's status uh my
position is uh this is essential because
earlier we eliminated a couple of
State directed expenditures of that
alcohol and drug commission money and
and backfilled it with General funds I
want to keep this out of the general
funds business
okay thank you Mr chairman I just want
to be sure we all have the it's been a
while since this came up it actually did
not come up yesterday so we have in
front of us like you say Amendment
0974h and then there was a
I thought I
supplemental document to that was there
not
right ah here it is yes hb1
looks like that I know they all do and
and then there was an additional
document that looked like that it was
about a third of the page
in length so we're looking at three
documents that were given out along with
that amendment to my knowledge
yes the um the third of the page says
proposed budget changes impacting the
governor's Commission when alcohol and
drug abuse prevention treatment and
Recovery prepared for representative
Edwards
and then again the hb1 amendment and
then
0974h so we're looking at all three and
then I would ask I see Mr Ripple sending
Distributing those again for those who
may not have them perhaps take us
through those documents again Mr Ripple
if you could just to refresh our
memories
before we head to vote
thank you
okay so starting with the amendment
itself 0974
the sole purpose of all of this is to
ensure that the alcohol fund
receives five percent of gross liquor
profits and does not have to transfer
them to the granted Advantage Program
so
sections one
and five
either amend or repeal the existing
statutory references to the transfer of
those funds from the alcohol fund to
granted advantage
section two
states that for fiscal 24 any such
transfer shall be reduced by the amount
of federal or other funds used by HHS to
fund the programs approved by the
governor's Commission in practice that
refers to the 5 million dollar
contribution from hospitals that will
take place at the end of this calendar
year so rather than getting
11 million dollars in liquor funds plus
5 million from the hospitals the alcohol
fund and the governor's commission would
get the total of 11 million
sections three
and four
are
changes to statutes that are related to
the granted Advantage Program so by
removing the alcohol fund as a source of
revenue for a granted advantage that
changes the calculus related to how
other parts of Grant Advantage are
funded and I don't want to get too far
into the weeds with that but these two
sections would only change
these two sections would only be
effective if the grand Advantage Program
is reauthorized and so you can see that
on page two
lines 14 through 16.
so the upshot of all of this is to
ensure that going forward the alcohol
fund receives an amount equal to five
percent of gross liquor profits
thank you and these are new sections to
House Bill too correct just so
everybody's we're all staying together
here okay Mr chair
do you have a question
or just just a comment
I guess I feel really uncomfortable
about
um the whole area around the granted
Advantage we haven't even seen we
haven't even seen the uh bill yet
it hasn't come over here
and until
I have a better handle on that I don't
feel comfortable changing the funding
sources
what can you share with us
foreign
all I would say is that this language is
included verbatim in Senate Bill 263 as
passed by the Senate that reauthorizes
granted Advantage the only difference
being
section 2 the provision that reduces the
liquor prop the transfer of liquor
profits by the amount of the five
million dollar donation and the
contingency language on page 2 lines 14
through 16 that in this amendment States
those sections will only go into effect
if granted Advantage is reauthorized
obviously that language is not needed in
the case of Senate Bill 263 itself
right
I I would like to go ahead and have us
vote on zero nine seven four
uh is there any further discussion
if you're in favor raise your hand
if you're opposed
okay so so we'll accept this and just
put a new section number together
mm-hmm
representative walner uh you had three
amendments
do you want to do any or all now
you plan to take a lunch today
I wasn't actually going to but do you
okay well we were going to have a caucus
at noon and so some people are waiting
on us oh you're is it a division caucus
or no it's a full Finance so you should
go I'm sorry I I think you may have told
me that and it slipped my mind so we'll
recess till one
that sounds fine and I will I will be
ready to do them at one okay all right
and the only modifier is if I can get
representative leishman to come do the
pdap okay that's fine all right you
could do that first yeah okay we're
recess till one
yeah well
well if you had a
thank you
foreign
okay uh we're we're back in our work
session uh we're we have to take a pause
at two o'clock we have three amendments
um
by representative walner would you
please introduce your amendments
statute I just if you can access it
quickly
no all right you
thank you
hmm
essentially okay
so I think we all have a copy now do you
want to just start sure
so um the first one that you have is
about the reimbursement rate paid for
child care per paid to child care
providers for providing services to low
and moderate income Working Families
so in the budget we didn't spend a lot
of time on the child care
area which I was sort of sorry that we
didn't at the time
um
it seems like we there was a lot there
was a lot to do that day so
um so child care has hasn't really had a
lot of attention during this budget
session
so what this would do real quick
um which section in hb2 are we does this
tie back to
this is a new this would be new
this would be a new hb2 okay
so
what this does there was no rate
increase for child care
in the budget prep budget
um that we had before us
and the reason for that was
that at least the reason I have been
told was that and I know this to be true
that
Child Care rates are set with a market
rate survey
and they do the market rate survey every
two years
and in the last several bienniums the
market rate survey was done
and then when we would come to the
budget
they would have the information they
needed to set the rate
well in these past two years there was
no market rate survey done
they're hoping to do one
in the coming year
but there's no market rate survey done
so there was no information for rate
setting
what this would do
is use
the the market rate survey from two
years ago
to set the rate at the 75th percentile
of the market rate
meaning that
25 of the providers would be charging
more than than the 75th percentile and
75 percent would be charging less
providers get paid either the 70 at the
75th percentile
or their actual charge whichever is less
it's important to remember that that
they get whichever is less so if the
market rate at 75th is 200 a week
then that's what the provider would get
if their rate was at least two hundred
dollars a week or more
if it was less they would get the lesser
amount say they only charged 150 they
would get 150. so they only they get the
lesser of the two but in order to give
them
a
reimbursement
rate
increase during the next biennium this
is um the way we would we have available
to do it at this point
um this is
I think the Senate has a bill
that has some of the same Provisions in
it
so
why'd I just open on this one for
questions representative Walnut oh let
me let me just say one I the most
important piece you don't have to worry
about your general funds
because there's something called the
TANF reserve and as
um Nathan has told us in the past
there's 67 million dollars in that
and one of the uses for the TANF Reserve
is child care there are four uses and I
can't remember what they all are but one
of them is child care and we have not
been using
um our TANF money for child care we
haven't had to in the last
um
a couple of a few bienniums so we
haven't had to do it we did have a
provision in the last budget
that said if
all the child care money the general
funds and the federal funds got drawn
down
then they could come to fiscal committee
and ask to use TANF Reserve so that
there wouldn't be a wait list
you don't want to have people have a job
an inner job and then you know and
the end of the year in March of the
second year the biennium find out that
they're losing their child care so
we had that provision we did not have to
use it so I have that provision here
that if
at the end of the if during the years
the couple of years they draw down all
the money they can come to the fiscal
committee and use TANF Reserve funds
so of course question
yes I do several questions
do we have an any estimate on what how
much money we're talking about annually
for this yes it would probably be I
think it's in the neighborhood of
they the department has done an estimate
of
2.9 Million
but that's for the
um that's per year
and the child care budget I think is
around
between Federal and
General is it um
is it around 34 million
34 35 million
so it's this is a little bit less than
okay you say like seven or eight percent
increase and it would just be a one-time
Child Care always got a one-time rate
increase the first year of the biennium
which then carried out in the second
I guess this is for either
Mr White or Mr Ripple right how much is
actually in the TANF account do we know
sure so so as representative Wallner
indicated that there's approximately 67
million dollars of TANF dollars
and how much of that 67 is already
allocated for the next biennium
that that's the the the balance amount
that hasn't been obligated thank you
and I think with that answer though it's
important to remember that they're only
it's not like you can take that money
and use it for the rate increase or
anything it's there are very very
specific reasons that you can use it in
child care
is one of those reasons because the goal
of that whole is to get
to get people working and keep people
working
sorry I'm Dreaming up other things would
that there was a discussion about
us covering child care
at something like eleven thousand
dollars per child
two weeks ago is that money eligible for
funding some of that partially as well
that line item
well that that's what that's what it
covers okay that's what it covers and I
think you and I had a conversation about
that that it had been nine and then it
jumped to 11 it seemed like a large jump
but I think during the pandemic I I
don't know of what all the reasons might
be that it went up that much
the reimburse you know why it would have
gone up that much per child but I think
during the pandemic it was very
expensive and also
um
a lot more I think families were a lot
lower income and child care is on a
sliding fee scale so people at the
lowest income pay very little
but everyone pays
every family pays
on the sliding fee scale so it's there
may have been more low and very low
income kids on which would push the cost
per child up
other questions I have about five okay
um do you happen to know what account
section in HP one we're dealing with
foreign
the child development program which is
on page 890 I heard you say 2977 yes on
what page page 890.
okay
um
are the other two amendments you have
related to this same subject area yes
okay
um I've heard multiple times there are
four uses of TANF and and one of them is
child care and I'm I've I've considered
asking every time it's said what exactly
are the four potential uses of TANF
and I guess that's a Mr White question
sure so provide assistance in needy
families so that children may remain in
their homes and Independence of needy
parents on government benefits through
work job preparation and marriage reduce
out of wedlock pregnancies and promote
the formation of families darn I was
looking for bullet statements four
simple bullet statements that's pretty
close everything's so complex uh okay so
who
and how do people access this money who
who is really eligible and then what
what do they have to what Hoops do they
have to jump through to get to the money
well they have to jump through a lot of
Hoops
um you have to follow they have to be
eligible they have to be financially
eligible
and then on top of that they have to be
working
this cannot go to families who are not
this goes to Working Families or
families where the adults are in a
training program you could have someone
you know or I guess
completing High School
so they have to apply through the
Department of Health and Human Services
they have to provide all the
documentation about their income
they have to you know show
pay stubs do all the do all that kind of
stuff
and then
they have to find a provider the
provider needs to be licensed
and
um
they can they can use they can use
unlicensed care
if it meets the regulations of
unlicensed care which would be someone
who was in their own home caring for
three or less children so if your next
door neighbor was willing to you know
just take care of your child then they
could receive the reimbursements the
reimbursements are different for
different levels of child care so in
home is a different rate than a
center-based
okay the babies are babies are paid more
than a toddler and toddlers are paid a
little bit more than preschoolers and
preschoolers are paid a little more than
after schoolers okay and then uh I I
don't know if there's already a system
where we do market rate surveys or that
we have experience doing this true cost
of care mechanism analysis
well the market rate survey is well
defined the federal government actually
um that's where the idea behind the
market rate survey came there is a move
now to start to use
a cost of care model and I think the
department is has been exploring that
but up to this point its rates have been
set using this market rate survey and
they've done it like I said every two
years and they were they were they were
required by the federal government to do
it every two years
they had to do it I believe now it might
have been changed every three and that's
why we're off cycle here and we don't
have one a recent one to work with
so I I don't know that there's Mr White
go ahead question if I'm wrong in any of
this I I I'm not as familiar with the
specific details of the program but but
everything seems consistent with what I
know
okay
um
so so basically with the reserve did I
hear 57 or 67 million
67 million 67 67. okay thank you
um so 2.9 out of 67 million is not much
but what other
that Reserve is there for a reason what
what's the primary purpose of that
reserve and who are the primary
claimants upon that Reserve so we we
budget those TANF dollars in the various
accounts and we cost allocate TANF
dollars
um to positions that that are serving
one of those four purposes within our
budget
um however what what we have seen in
recent years is we have seen that cash
assistance dollars start to go down and
so traditionally we would be using a mix
of TANF and general fund dollars for the
cash assistance purposes
um so as a result of of some of of some
of that and in order to hit our Moe
um you know we've had additional TANF
dollars come in over the years that have
caused that balance to increase
so long term is this a viable funding
source or are we going to be coming back
to needing the budget for this at some
point in the foreseeable future
um at the current juncture it seems like
it's a viable uh solution and then would
you consider a Sunset date on this is
this only for two years or is this going
to be permanent law maybe Mr Ripple
could tell us how this is crafted is
this ongoing or just for this budget
as drafted it would be ongoing
would you consider just doing it for
this budget I would consider that
because
they are doing a market rate survey I
believe
this fall or in the upcoming winter and
then next budget cycle will be back on
cycle
with having the market rate information
it's just that this year we didn't have
it for the Department to include in the
budget you want to do your one or your
other two yep
were there questions more about that
because I I thought it might make sense
to see that all three of the other ones
but I did have a question of Mr White is
there anything else that the that money
could be allocated to in our within our
current budget that we have overlooked
uh nothing that my team has identified
typically we try to Leverage The TANF
dollars as much as we can because again
we behind the scenes during the summer
and and fall we kind of go through a
very painful process of trying to
leverage all of our federal dollars as
much as we can in order to hit that
three percent Target or whatever Target
we were required to hit per the
governor's directive thank you
thank you
okay am I right to say that this is the
basically on the assumption that your
your first amendment passes this one
makes it 85 instead of 75 percent no
okay I'll let you describe it though
this one the first one was for the
provider rates it increased so so that
the providers are paid what this one is
is basically family eligibility
allowing families up to 85 percent of
the median income
to receive
child care assistance
remember it is on a sliding fee scale so
as you get up the higher your income the
less of your less subsidy you will
receive it slides
um and at the top people do not get a
very very much
but
what's happened in the last few years is
with inflation
with wages going up with housing costing
so much more
families are really struggling Child
Care is a very expensive
child care costs for an infant is
probably around 300 a week
and
well that may and that I'm that's
probably that's probably the
that's probably at the low end but it is
very expensive and families are really
struggling and if you have two children
it's really even more so I think what
we've heard we want people in the
workforce
people need and want to be working but
Child Care is a barrier and this would
allow families to be on until they until
they're at 85 percent immediate but they
want would not be receiving a full
subsidy they would be receiving
like I said on this lighting C scale I
do want to remind you and I one reason
that I
brought this in was because
there's obviously a recognition in the
legislature
that
families cannot afford
care
and probably education
when their their incomes are lower than
85 percent of poverty and actually I
believe that in the past several weeks
there's been a lot of discussion here
about the education Freedom accounts
being available to families who are in
this range I think it's 350 percent of
poverty is what I heard it's been 300.
300 I passed the house recently was 350.
okay 350. of the federal poverty level
and so I was going to ask you just to
get the two synchronized can we put this
instead of 85 percent of median can we
make this uh to the FPL
yes and what would that be do you know
I've got it right here
they are very similar 85 and 350 are
very close the reason I used 85 was
because that's the federal the way the
federal government
refers to it in the child care
legislation but we can use we can use
percentage of poverty so
um at 85 percent of poverty 85 percent
of median for a family of
four you want to do a family of four
it's a hundred and two thousand dollars
a year for
for a family of four
which is what has been talked about here
it's a hundred and five thousand dollars
a year
so
I started looking and it did they did
line up almost exactly I guess
um
85 percent is a little bit less than 350
than the 350 percent but they do line up
since you have both of them there uh
could you let's do the scenario of a
single mom with one kid okay
so a single person with one child
that would be a family of two
would be um 69
835 at 85 percent of median
and at um
350 percent it would be 69 000 and 20 so
they're very close they're very close
yeah
representative walner is it possible
since you've collected that great data
to share that or get copies that's
really nice to know
yeah sure I I will have
I will ask somebody to make copies so
the practicality of changing your
language from 85 percent of median to
the F the family poverty level number of
for the 350
that would I think Aid in communicating
it to others in the legislature but it
sounds like it would make it more
difficult for the Department to match it
to the federal guidelines I think the
department now uses like
they do use percentage I think now they
do use percent of of poverty so I think
it would be natural to go to the 350. I
think it would be
just as easy for them
and I I don't know if the I do know that
I don't know if the federal how would we
have to go to exactly 85 I think we
would have to it wouldn't be 350 exactly
I think it would be a little less I
would if it were me I I would want to
see the exact same numbers used across
the board okay so that legisl it's
simpler for legislators to say oh that's
the same as what we're doing in this
other program that's the way I would do
it and if the amount of money was just a
little bit different and they're very
small differences then that's okay
so I think 350 I mean I would I think
that would be
that would be acceptable to
me at least representative walner will
representative norgren has had her hand
up for a while and then we'll come to
your representative hole Yeah I just
wanted to
remind us all that the bottom line is
the it's more economical for the parent
to be able to work
and put their child in child care then
have the costs so expensive that they
can't work and pay for it so I mean I
think the numbers that Mary Jane's
brought up are really important to the
bottom line for that family yeah there's
another non-determinable
benefit here that's qualitative and not
quantifiable and that is there's there's
inherent value and self-worth associated
with being employed that you can't
really put direct numbers around because
it's a sort of a long-term investment in
self-esteem I think you know not to
sound too sociable emotional yeah but
representative hole thank you
representative walner so um is it safe
to assume that we could rewrite
Amendment 1093 hotel to move over to the
350 percent of the federal poverty level
as
um a separate Amendment but similar in
nature yes that would be fine
so and the same two questions of the
other one do you know what the price tag
the incremental price tag of this is and
are you and are you intending this for
this budget or to be permanent
well I I think it's written in a way
that it's permanent it's my
understanding
um
but it could be reevaluated
in another in another budget I mean if
that's more comfortable for people that
we look at it and maybe we'll have some
history I think it's difficult to
estimate but the department has done an
estimate
and let me see if I can find it the
estimate is probably
I believe it's
it's probably going to be around seven
million dollars
which
I think
we'll see I mean it's going to take a
while for
this new eligibility to go into place
it's going to take a while for families
to hear about it it's going to take I
mean it's gonna it's not gonna happen
really overnight
it's not like July 1st people are going
to be running in the door it's going to
take a long time for it to really ramp
up so I don't think that we will draw
down so so if this is an 85 what's the
current standard seven zero 70 or
something what's that I think it's like
65 for one group and I think there's a
couple of different the 65 for one group
I can send a texter and find out in
about 10 seconds okay I think it's 65
percent
okay if if we do this it's at 7 million
a year I I on an ongoing stable State
basis seven million I I I'd feel more
comfortable doing a sunset on it just so
that the next budget committee could
look at it yeah I think that makes sense
we can because then we'll have some real
figures too do you have a third yes I do
have a third I if if you've passed these
two I may not so I don't know what I
don't know whether you're going to pass
them or not but
I uh
if you pass these two we might not need
them need the third one but I will I'll
tell you about the third one
Okay the third one
yes Kevin will hand it out
while that's being handed out
just
um the 350 percent of FPL lines up with
85 percent
um where does 300 FPL line up is that
approximately 80 do you have
that information because we're using 300
of FPL and other portions in our
statutes
in which statute we just proposed for
the efas to go to 350.
the current law is 300. right and that's
why I was just just out of curiosity
what's the difference that's a great
question I just you said other statutes
and so I just wanted to know if we were
using that FPL number somewhere else
um I'd have to go back and look I
believe there is other places that we
were referencing at FPL
so I've been wrestling in my head what
you just addressed which is our current
law is 300 FPL the house bill that we
passed is 350 FPL yep
so the analogy would be since that house
proposal has not been accepted by the
Senate nor has rhb2 if we had them at
the same level then we're making the
same argument to the Senate
and hopefully the argument I was
thinking of making
do you have what do you want you want to
know what 300 percent of poverty is for
a family of four and a single mom with
one right what is 300 FPL and what is
what percentage is that equivalent to
um 300 of poverty is 90 000 for a family
of four
and it's 59 160.
for a family of two
okay
and I don't
I don't know what it is to relate it to
median income because I only had median
income at 85. I'm sorry I didn't print
them all off okay
all right I if there aren't any more
questions why don't you tell us what
you're thinking about your third one
okay the third one is very similar to
what was in the budget two years ago
so
um two years ago
we weren't sure whether this child care
whether the child care budget was going
to actually be able to cover all the
cost of child care during that biennium
well the pandemic hit a lot of things
happened the drawdown wasn't nearly as
fast as we thought it would be so I had
this amendment put in two years ago that
if
the child care budget was drawn down
that
they could come to the department could
come to the fiscal committee and have
TANF funds transferred so that we didn't
have to develop a wait list or ask
families to leave child care
so it didn't end up happening we didn't
need it but
it's sort of like dealt and suspenders
we don't this does not appropriate any
money it just allows the department the
ability to come in case that
um account gets low and there's a
reporting mechanism in here that they'll
be reporting on a regular basis to the
fiscal committee
okay so that
um I guess if the first two
were put in place I wouldn't really need
this one anymore but
I thought I'd better bring it in
okay unless
unless the department feels different
what's the perception of the risk of the
of the funds in the child care account
running out in the next biennium we
don't really know but I mean this is
sort of a safety net do we need the
safety net
it it would depend on um I mean I I
think part of that depends on whether
there's any action on these two
amendments
um
I I of course in from my perspective
always appreciate this type of scenario
where if if budgeted amounts and needs
are not in alignment we do have an
Avenue to come back through fiscal uh
for for approval so
so under any scenario you think this is
a
reasonable amendment to give the
department flexibility it's it's in
current chapter law
um I I of course would appreciate it yes
I I want to make sure I just heard you
did you just say this is already in
chaptered law or that you want to put
this into chaptered law so so this is in
this is chapter 91 uh section 325 so is
this redundant
no so this expires at the end of the
biennium
uh so so this would reintroduce that
into the current hb2 which would expire
at that point in time
okay I understand that do you have more
you want to say
or a question no I just you know I hope
that I mean we've spent a lot of time on
a lot of different services and this is
one that I think
is really important to both families I
think it's really important to children
because they're cared for in places that
are inspected and are safe and
parents get desperate sometimes when
they don't have
these kinds of
financial help to pay for child care
they get desperate and use
child care that might be inappropriate
because it's cheaper or
you know mistakes have bad things happen
um and I think it's also really good for
New Hampshire and for employers
everybody talks about how many employees
they need including the state I mean a
lot of this might help some State the
state in in recruiting some people
to restate jobs
there's a lot of state jobs probably
fall Within These these five these
income levels
so
so I hope
get your support
I I I think I think I would like to
caucus for your first two
your third one
seems to have no general fund
implication it's a flexibility measure
it's already in existing law that's set
to expire so this is this is simply
looks to me to be a con continuity of
the okay
um
I I I'm I'm predisposed to having us
support the walner
1060 Amendment
is there any discussion particularly any
in opposition
no
all right so show hands if you're in
favor of one zero six zero
okay all right so that's one thing
I think the other two we probably need
to talk about but we're going to break
before two anyways so we'll have an
opportunity we won't listen you can just
talk amongst yourselves
it's just hum louder
um we're I I'm still waiting for
representative leishman to come in on
the on the pdab I see uh is it Merchant
or Merchant I've heard people doing the
whole French thing on you and then I I'm
butchering you up with Merchant
you'll take either
but what is proper
okay all right but I don't want to get
into your ancestry that could start a
fight
um all right let's let's let's
did you have a question you got your
hand in the semi
you ready to jab me
uh all right so let's pick up
Mr Ripple before I jump knowing that I'm
keeping the pdab off to the side
um
are we complete with everything up until
the status of actions related to hb1
so in other words are you complete with
everything on at the house bill 2 sheet
yeah front and back with the exception
of the pdab at the back
and and with the exception of the rate
increase on hold
um yes okay so so we're I think we're
waiting on the rate increase paperwork
from OLS
I have not yet sent the amendment
requests to them
um because I will need further
information on that um oh you need the
dollar amounts yes so um
you think you can just guess we told you
how to calculate it I will send him over
okay all right
um
we have one other I believe right we
were going to revisit to to
223 relative to total budget as well as
this body scanner
but at least that's what my notes have
so you just said 223 the sununa budget
let's do that because I at least want to
be able to throw away or lose track of
one piece of paper
let's go to the sununu center
uh we we got a spreadsheet earlier
to show how we would how the department
proposes to move the money into hb1
I don't know where my sheet is of course
and uh
we had a discussion yesterday about the
scanner it sounds like the scanner cost
is about three hundred thousand dollars
to the best of the departments on
knowledge the first few years at least
enough years to get us through this full
budget cycle the the maintenance is
included I've asked a couple of
questions I didn't get answers back and
and that is uh are are there training
costs in addition to that or or does the
initial training so that people know how
to safely use the equipment is that is
that part of the initial acquisition
so so we're we're still collecting
information but
um from what I understand to date
it would cover the initial installation
costs and then the basic walk through to
show to show folks how to uh how to
utilize it
um I think I think that 250 to 300 000
range would probably also give us
sufficient funds for service any sort of
service work with any new purchase there
there's a maintenance warranty that goes
along with that
um and hopefully a brand new machine
would not result in a heavy service cost
and then I also asked if if this the
Imaging was x-ray or something else
because if it's x-ray I get just a
little concerned we may need a quality
assurance program that requires a
physicists oversight along with
dosimetry monitoring sure so if I
remember correctly I believe the
brochure that was sent to you I think it
said it I don't remember what the what
the measurement unit was but I think it
could be utilized a thousand times a
year or something like that and still
fall within standard Safety Code for
that particular model that we had
identified was this a millimeter
waveform representative hole do you have
a question I do thank you sorry was this
millimeter wavelength typical of the
airport scanning type I it's it's
similar I I cannot recall I'm honestly
not very familiar with with it
okay question
I would doubt it's x-ray or it wouldn't
detect a lot of the things that they
wanted attach I'm guessing it's the ones
that go around you in circles in the
airport
no the email was with the information
was sent yesterday at 12 29 from Mr
Ripple with um the two attachments to
the product I don't know if anyone wants
it yeah I I saw the two attachments I I
did not read them I did skim them but
um okay so I've corresponded with Mr
Ripple or not Ripple I do that all the
time but Mr ribson and he said that
if we could provide some flexibility
within his expense account lines expense
lines
that he would not need an incremental
300 000 above what he's requested
is that is that what he told you is that
what do you understand yes that's what
we talked about last night so so we
would have to I guess Mr Ripple I guess
that's a footnote to to provide the
flexibility to move money without coming
to the fiscal committee
yeah you could do that as a footnote but
do we need to do it in a footnote if we
want them to have that flexibility uh
typically
I think you do yes yes okay
um okay so then
representative hole do you want to do
you want to talk about your observations
and thoughts sure
so
um a couple things
um
I'm gonna work through
um this sheet that was just handed out
that also includes positions
um
we have a we have a student population
that's averaging
12 students thereabouts yet we have four
full-time kitchen staff members and two
part-time so we have six people who are
helping cook meals for 12. um
teams High
um I could go through there's some other
areas similar the other area was in the
allocations of outside vendors
um we're spending two thousand dollars
per year per child although there are
children going through so you're going
to need it's not right you may have
multiple children filling that one spot
but we're we're on the order of two
thousand dollars per child per year in
labs and we're spending almost 1.8
million in outside contract metals
medical costs when we have two hospitals
within a couple of miles
I would like to propose kind of uh let
the department manage this the way they
want but cap the total spend at 10
million dollars or 9.99 million dollars
and ask them to include the body scanner
okay so I hear your initial bill bid to
be 10 million dollars plus they get the
300 000 scanner but in exchange we give
them whatever flexibility they need
within this total funding to to move the
money within the expenses that is
correct
do you I it's not fair without Mr ribs
in here but I'm sure you know what to
say
I mean this this is a 24-hour facility
safety is key in Paramount here
um the facility I mean we already
experience a 33 loss in our cpsw
positions last last summer into the fall
and we're still dealing with the Fallout
from that to try to get the to try to
get everything fully staffed
um I don't think 10 million dollars
would be sufficient and what we'd end up
doing is based I mean it'd basically be
in a back of the budget cut and we'd
have to transfer funds from from other
areas the the the 890 and 900 000 that's
part of a contracted
um I mean those are contracted costs and
those are paid only if if those
positions are filled those positions are
currently filled we went out to
competitive bid for those costs just as
far as a major driver and I think Joe
already spoke to the the youth counselor
costs
um I mean I I think
I I mean I think having a footnote to
purchase that body scanner and any
maintenance services surrounding there
would would certainly be helpful but
overall I know that
um be kind of concerned to to a cut the
actual funds to it because we probably
wouldn't have funding sufficient and B
sent another message to staff that we're
not supporting this fully
so we're not done because we're done
we're done because it's two o'clock and
people needed to take off at two o'clock
she did you did
okay so this is your topic though
I don't want to recess
um if we still have people we need to
continue what it'd be a good time to
vote on the rate increases
I like the way you think
I'll just I'll just say this
um I think under all the legislative
scenarios I've seen
that the Youth Development Center
is going to be encouraged to begin
transitioning to the new methods of
operating
um
and
in that
we've included virtual you know remote
services
one of the targets for that
to me has always been your medical staff
seems excessive
if you had L A's there with some
telemedicine capability to more robust
treatment
and you had reasonable access to
ambulances
it just seems to me like a huge enormous
over expenditure on the medical lines
and if you got that right sized
in my view without having the detailed
discussion
you would be halfway between where you
are now and what representative hole is
talking about
so do you have any thoughts on
trying to use telemedicine to reduce
your medical staff sure we I mean we I
can't really speak to the clinical needs
of the of the children however they they
are acute and you know just just from uh
a dollar's perspective with the
contracts we just went out to bid for
this and we just had new contracts
signed
um this past January or February of last
year so those have been competitively
bid to try to get the most reasonable
rates to bring in the clinicians and the
Psychiatry psychologists and
psychiatrists for those services and and
those are the rates that were contracted
for today
so so I would make a distinction between
the clinical and the psychologists the
psychologists are all part of the new
mission mission I think
I want to see the final proposal at some
point but
um it seemed to me like there was there
was an over emphasis on the clinical
capability there
instead of the psychological or mental
health
and so that clinical side
seemed overstaffed to me when when you
could you could do a telemedicine
station there and somebody who can
handle first aid well
coupled with evacuation capabilities and
you have adequate medical support from a
clinical perspective that's the kind of
stuff I used to do in the olden days
the the mental health side of it is
probably what it should be but
um all right I I think I think we need
to just sort of table this and set this
issue aside until representative hole
can come back yes sir go ahead so
Dartmouth who's usually the only bidder
000 going to 916 000. does that include
all the nurse staff or is that in
addition to
so there there is
um there's a part-time registered nurse
uh position in the staff count there on
the right and then there is also uh five
registered nurses one nurse specialist
and one nurse coordinator
and then I see the Dartmouth medical
staff at you know the 890 000. is that
inclusive of that staff that we just
noticed no so those positions there
those are classified state employees
um the the contracted line includes the
psychologists clinicians uh that that
Joe had referred to the other day when
he was here
those are the ones in the Dartmouth
contract that is correct yes how many
um off the top of my head I believe
there was a part-time psychiatrist a
psychologist to clinicians and there may
a pediatrician and a pediatrician thank
you
Dartmouth has never treated us very well
since they're paying taxes on their
dormitories
okay so did you also have a question
representative
yeah so representative walner
as I recall it was this budget
discussion two years ago that triggered
everyone to saying let's close the thing
down
where are you this year
is this what do you want to do about
their their budget request
well if we put the book they like the
idea of putting a footnote in there to
allow them this flexibility
um
if they also include buying the scanner
you know I don't think I had enough
discussion with them at this point to to
really make a decision about this but I
think we have to go I I personally think
we're going to have to go with what
we've got before us
so there's been a vacancy rate over
there
do do we need all the Personnel money in
the first year
yes because what we've had to do
um is we've had to bring staff in from
across the department who have either
familiar familiarity with working or
formally worked at sysc to provide the
overtime so there's been a series of
transfers through the fiscal process
we've also had to renew a staffing
contract a number of times whereby we
have pulled in youth counselors through
a contracted service to cover shifts as
Joe had indicated before because we're
kind of having to bring in both
contracted staff and we've had to bring
in staff who this is not their primary
job but they have some familiarity with
it and can fulfill the functions because
of that you know when when we've been
dealing with
Staffing we've had to make sure that we
have at least one extra if not more
depending on the circumstances to
address that so um long story short no
so I'll tell you a story I don't know if
it's true or not but
on the line for medical payments to
providers
here we've had physician and nursing
staff
on site
and I had heard stories from multiple
sources
that the people that we had on staff the
Physicians that could handle it were
very prone to just referring people out
to get rid of the work and weren't
particularly
didn't particularly exhibit sort of the
clinical dedication one might expect and
if that is the case I would hope that
somebody in management would take a look
at that medical payments to provider
line that's about a million dollars and
wonder if that's really what it ought to
be if we had the right people on site
you can't comment on that I can I just
don't know where the stories come from
that's all yeah well they're at least
two years old so maybe that person is
rotated but it you know that whole
medical support concept to me was just
really
um
just it just smelled of waste and that
that's that's part of the reason I got
upset two years ago
um Mr chairman I have a comment go ahead
you were asking representative Wallner
you know her view on things and
the way I look at this is we know that
the new facility is coming
and because we know that and that we
have another at least two years ahead of
us we know that we have to work within
the the confines of the existing
um situation which has its own kitchen
its own laundry and all those things
that we've we've heard over and over and
over again and unfortunately in order to
keep a facility that's safe and doing
the work that we have to do to make sure
that these children are cared for and in
a safe controlled setting being educated
getting treatment
we're I think we're sort of stuck with
what we have here this is the hole that
we've dug for ourselves for the time
being
so I am very appreciative to hear that
the committee is open to going for the
scanner that to me what we heard
yesterday
upset me extremely so I'm very pleased
that that is now in play
um but as far as finding other ways to
cut I just I just don't see it without
sacrificing the safety of the children
so that's my two cents
there's more going on in this account
than safety though
everything about the safety part of it
uh we're absolutely in aligned with I my
sense after looking at this budget now
over four budget years
is still
that it hasn't been staffed at an
efficient level to accomplish the things
it really needs to accomplish it just
has always felt like the head count is
wrong and I'm not in a position to go in
there and make changes and say okay
instead of you know four RNs you only
need two you know but I I I just think
I would have liked to have seen the
department come back with a tighter
better head count
my response to that is it's a 24-hour
facility of course and we need we need a
medical professional in there 24 hours a
day and I'm sure that
um you know as I was taking notes here
you know there are multiple services
that need to be provided by those nurses
so I guess all I'm saying is
that we have a unique situation that
we're Bound by the structure that we
have and and the the system that we have
and I just I I am a little wary of
of cutting
um those professionals that um they say
they need to keep things functioning you
know we're not that far away if we go
the whole route that's 10 million this
is 11.1 that's it's not a huge Delta go
ahead
asked Nathan if he could tell us what
did we spend in 22 or actual
okay
well I mean that's the actual right
because 23 hasn't closed out yet
foreign
a couple of reports
so so if you could continue to work on
that I think we can wait for Jr
and Nathan 2022 also had Revenue though
right
yes I
all right I I just need a couple minutes
to look that up
it's on page 896.
okay I
we're ready to I think to pause the
sununu issue anyways until
representative hole and Mooney come back
and we still need to work through the
blanket the horse blanket front and back
foreign
ninety seven
that was the actual expense if you
recall from the Senate bill one
discussion uh the 23 Figures were
projected to be a bit higher because of
overtime costs and I think some other
factors
representative norgren and
assume the numbers for a lot of
including this
this has a covid and the issues every
facility was dealing with so they might
not be
the same as we would need now
I don't think we ever hit the covid
stuff in either budget it last last time
around the budget had been developed
before pre-covered I was still
pre-covered and now I think this budget
is intended to be sort of post-covered
and so somehow the covid
missed
yeah
but who knows what our next infectious
control
problem ought to be
I I would like to stop talking about the
sununu center for a little while and
start talking about these other items
because we need our two
certainly representative holdback
um
all right so
item two these are just technical
corrections I don't if the if those are
just technical corrections I don't see
any reason why we just wouldn't approve
those and two is grayed out you've
already approved them oh okay good I
like remaking the same decision it's
faster
uh okay the home visiting formula grant
for a million dollars over the two years
we put this on hold
why did we put this on representative
walner wanted to discuss it
so so we've gone to the horse blanket
here the bigger paper on uh status of
actions related hb1 and we're looking at
item five and we remember that that you
had some discussion on this you wanted
to do
I just think that it's
home visiting I think we can really
reach some of the families that some of
our families that are really
most in need and try to prevent these
things I mean if we get to these
families early
it's going to help and home visiting is
has been proven to be a very
successful way of reaching families
I think
yesterday did we talk about there being
up to 500 children who would receive
visits with this program and it was a
three-year
three-year program for the family for so
he'd get home visiting I assume from the
time they were infants up until they
were ready to go to preschool or three
years old so I think it really
probably one of the best ways of really
reaching fam those families that in our
communities that are the most in need so
um and okay so I think um
I think Trish
no um Tilly talked about this when she
was here you talked about how important
these programs are yes that is correct
it was originally for 1.25 million
dollars each year
um but based on some updated information
relative to that to the match required
on the federal side uh that has been
reduced to the 525 each year you see
there
count is it
it's accounting unit uh 58.96
thank you
and is this sheet I'm I'm sorry I need
to know this already but is this is this
the prioritized needs sheet as well or
or is there yet another piece of paper
somewhere with prioritized needs for us
to look at
um so I believe in Kevin correct me if
I'm wrong I believe you took the earlier
DHHS prioritized needs hb1 request and
moved it into the status of actions
related to hb1
yes that's right
so this is all currently federal funds
is that accurate
I don't know I don't know that I heard
the answer because I'm I'm deaf uh yes
is this the is this that this is the
prioritized needs sheet
this item was taken from the
prioritizing each sheet okay so it's a
subset of which
earlier you had a documents
um that looked like this it contained
technical requests that you voted on
yeah some other that you've mostly voted
on and some prioritized needs
um
those prioritized needs are shown here
okay so I'm sorry I'm being sort of
kindergarten on this if if if we
complete all of the items on the
tentative actions related to hb2 this
and all of the actions on on this horse
blanket for status of actions related to
hb1 we will have done our work
outstanding amendments
that's correct with the exception of
rate increase amendments and
um
a revised a revised version of the back
of the budget amendment that you talked
about yesterday
and one other amendment that I'm working
on my Amendment isn't anywhere on these
sheets either which is still out in
ether it is I believe on the status of
actions related to House Bill one under
the division of Behavioral Health on
page two so yours is on line 46.
thank you
is medical expansion some around here as
well sorry Medicaid expansion is that on
here as well
so Medicaid expansion is a new would be
a new house bill 2 Section I do have an
amendment related to that
um I have two versions of it and I would
ask representative Edwards which one you
wanted me to hand out but yes that's
another that's another outstanding item
so so back to the home visiting thing so
we had the you got the grant the Federal
Grant and I assume you're already doing
a lot with that the 2.8 million dollars
roughly per year yes but historically
um this other component of it we've
received Governors commission funds for
that and then most recently ARP dollars
and the ARP dollars you won't you won't
see here
so during the current binding you have
arbit dollars that now you're trying to
replace essentially with the general
funds yep
so
okay so my bias at this point in the
process is anything that didn't make the
the governor's budget that and is hung
around as a prioritized need
um I I I'm I'm not prone to wanting to
approve it because I want as much money
as we can to put into the Medicaid rate
that I'm just being transparent that's
sort of where I'm at
but
um but I'm I'm always open to listening
let's drop down to 10. System of care
that's where the big money is
what what
you want to talk about this long item Mr
Mr White sure so uh just a year prior uh
for the first time the department
contracted with the the residential
um residential providers and
we entered into those contracts it was
the first time it had ever been done
previously we were paying them through
the bridges system the purpose of the
contracts was to provide the department
with better leverage better
understanding
um of of the services provided and then
require certain standards to be met and
so during that process
we established rates and we didn't have
a lot of good information from the
providers for a variety of reasons uh
part of it was just due to the
restrictive nature of the procurement
process itself and keeping certain
information confidential
um these these contracts they they
provide services
um they're used to provide services to a
number of different number of different
types of children and some of those
qualify under Medicaid some of those
qualify under title 4E some are are
Foster Care others may not qualify under
any of that and may be generally funded
and so what this request is
um the purpose of this request is to
provide additional funds because in the
in the year since we have looked at Cost
reports
um of these various facilities to
understand what are the costs that they
are incurring related to the services
that they are providing and based off of
many months of analysis
um we we've we've determined that that
these amounts here would would make the
providers closer to whole for the
services that they're providing
um and and I believe uh Joe and Katya
both spoke to both spoke to this
prioritize need
so if we do the Medicaid rate increase
is this somewhat redundant or some
overlap to the system of care money
a small amount and that is dependent
upon the the child because one child may
qualify under Medicaid another may
qualify under title for e and other you
know may qualify under a different
Federal funding source so I would say
yes but it depends and we don't
necessarily know
in the next biennium you know what the
the the situations of the children
moving into these facilities will be in
the coming years and and then I don't
know if if what I think I heard you say
is that we're just Contracting for it
but we're paying for it just like we
have in the past except we're using a
contract vehicle why isn't this money
already in the budget and then I'll come
to you representative Waller because we
we've we've done the since then because
again this was the first time it had
ever been done this was an overhaul to
the system of care
since then we've done the analysis and
we've looked at what what is every
facilities costs
and and this is the rate setting team
um that was here previously Christy Roy
spearheading that working with cover
Leonard our finance director on the
division for Behavioral Health side and
they've done that analysis and these
These are the costs that that would
essentially make them closer to whole
for the services that they are providing
go ahead representative oh I said walner
I'm sorry I just want to count easy
question
account number account number oh
this is uh 2053.
Let's uh let's go to 15 Family Planning
there
oh all right I didn't see you
so Nathan do we have any idea how many
children we're talking about in these
lines
I can look it up it'll take me a moment
though and and representative Earth just
to clarify there are a few other
accounting units that that are used to
support these contracts again it'll take
me a couple of minutes to find that if
you'd like that though no no go ahead
and answer um representative Wallner it
just seems it's down to be up 100 and
it's a pretty gross variation variance
foreign
let's let them come up for air yeah
if you look at him accounts for me don't
worry about go ahead and take uh
representative all this question
I'm I'm sorry I'm sorry what was that
you don't need to find the accounts for
me if that's what you're doing yeah no I
was I was just looking up representative
wallner's question
sure after you get your question your
follow-up then representative Moody has
a question
thank you probably for Mr Ripple
and
with regards to this
spreadsheet division three status of
actions related to House Bill one
is it possible for you to identify which
of these are included in the budget and
which are outside categorize them by
that
um in what sense so you have
you have a number of items such as
family planning the prescription drug
affordability board the sununu center
that are in the budget but at different
amounts than those suggested on this
spreadsheet
okay
so I'm not sure
any others that fall into that category
I guess or maybe just point out what's
new to the budget on this extensive
spreadsheet what would be new to it
um
I look at the prioritized need and some
of these were left out of the governor's
budget and but we have them here before
us initially the prioritized needs are
new requests although each of the each
of the three programs are currently
funded in the operating budget they're
just funded at lower levels than the
department has requested
so
they're all included it's just the
funding at this point it has to be
discussed on each of these items nothing
is new
some of the amounts like home visiting
formula grant is exactly the same it
prioritize need but was not funded and
it's in this
this other sheet at the same amount the
525. so that was something the governor
left out so it's an addition here
I I guess the only thing that I would
consider
to be newly funded is to be new to this
sheet not included in the budget at all
is uh representative tolerski's
Amendment for the 625 000 per year for
the substance use coalition
obviously there's other substance use
funding in the budget but there's no
funding in the for the Coalition in
there currently
okay understood and I don't want to take
any more time away from representative
walner's line of questioning so
hopefully that commercial break allowed
you to find the answer so she can
continue thank you sure and and so I I
went back and I looked up the original
GNC letter from the year prior and and
we were at that point estimating about
approximately four four to five hundred
uh individuals served each year
and are all of these contracts in all of
this
funding is this all with 24-hour
facilities yes yes so these are all
residential 24-hour facilities that is
correct
okay so this is probably more of a
question for Mr ripsom but
without these contracts I mean do you
think that we're going to be able to are
these providers going to be able
to hang on and keep providing service if
we don't
get these rates up I mean we just saw
how much it cost to run sununu I mean
these these folks are maybe a little bit
maybe the kids are a little less complex
but
it's expensive to run a 24-hour facility
and
these these facilities cost less than
sununu and these are the kids we're
trying to keep out of sunodu
so what do you I mean do we have any
idea how close I mean are these guys
just hanging on by a thread my
understanding is that these um these
providers are are experiencing the same
challenges as many of the other folks
that have come here to speak before you
over the past number of weeks
have we in the last year or two lost any
of these type of providers have they
closed
I I don't I don't know the answer to
that okay not that I'm aware of okay
thank you
I'm just still not clear how could the
budget be off by this much it seems
sound like a little bit it's like
dramatic
well it when when you look at the the
totals
um amongst all of the contracts it it's
the price the total price limitation is
145 million dollars
across all providers
so it's less than ten percent well so
what's the 12 million showing
the 12 million so basically were were
that to be approved uh we would make
amendments and change the rates that we
per that we pay those providers and
increase their price limitations by the
equivalent amount
but but the 12 million must represent
something in the budget
something out of that 143 million is
that what you're I mean I'm trying to
understand I'm looking at just the
numbers right here you got 12 million
and you want another yep so so so again
what we did is we went back and we we
collected cost reports and we looked at
what are the actual costs that these
providers are incurring and when we did
that analysis and looked at every
provider and every contract and what
rate we should be paying them and we
made those adjustments and determined
okay if we're going to pay them for
those costs we'd have to increase the
contracts by X and this is a collective
amount okay and solution is basically a
10 increase is that what you just told
me
um roughly
close to that yeah so it's something to
that well no it would be slightly more
once you take the general and the
federal dollars together 20. but again
it depends upon the type of child and
whether Federal whether federal dollars
are are available for reimbursement
I'm going to pause on this because I
think we need to caucus but
um the family planning on the
first page line 15.
the Earth Amendment replaced by the
Earth Amendment it says this is on hold
but um I think I think your amendment
was basically actually more of a
technical correction
right so is there any opposition to
approving line 15
not on my part any okay so we'll show
hands if you're in favor of accepting uh
or the accepting the deletion of line
15.
oh that's all right so that's
that's good that's one
okay
um
let's flip now to the back of the other
page
uh there's a family planning
representative Earth Amendment
was this also another technique that is
this the same technical adjustment
s so this was the same thing I had left
on under other under other agency
requests Family Planning as the
department requested it but as Nathan
said yesterday that was basically
replaced by the Earth Amendment so if
you voted on the earth amendment I would
which you've already done I would rate
both of these out okay so I'm just going
to say we're deleting this unless
somebody wants another vote as I think
what line was that that it's line four
zero on it's line four zero got it
okay so the Edwards Amendment on family
planning this is the one for a hundred
thousand and twenty thousand dollars per
new awardee
um uh I imagine there's opposition to
this
I don't really think it's going to work
um I would I remove it I would remove it
I removed it I did it though I removed
it ah
just now
okay wow all right all right I still
think it's a fine Theory
um but it's all just Theory and uh I I
think I think
we just need to finish this
so line 45
Governor's Commission on alcohol funding
I I think we can delete this now because
we earlier voted to make sure they get
their full five percent
and that was one of the benefits was we
could delete this yes your earlier vote
your earlier vote encompassed this item
as well
okay so 45 is gone
45 will be grayed out it's it's it was
effectively adopted by your earlier vote
Yes okay
um and then
um
so I had another question on 46 for
representative tolersky
um it's it's kind of there were a couple
ambiguous question answers that we went
through yesterday and neither of them
were particularly critical to me did did
you want to did you have an update on
either though
no
we can move the question
I don't I I don't see it being favorable
so we can move along but um I would like
to just say you know that I'm a big
proponent of prevention
prevention is good yep
okay but I I had I did have a new
question and and I did like the fact
that
this Coalition had a broader Geographic
footprint than I initially imagined when
I first read it and and so overnight I
started thinking well are there other
coalitions that are out there that we
should be considering for funding too
but we happen to know of this Coalition
because of your Association
I couldn't answer that I just you know
you don't know what you don't know no I
don't know what I don't know but I do
know that this group has come together
you know with effective programming
Okay so
we we went over this pretty pretty well
yesterday
um and there was a nice q a on it so
um I would like a show of hands to see
who is in favor of 625
000 for
is before I do that must it be 625
000 could we do a lot of good at a lower
number
open any funding at this point
um with the five I would just say you
know it would be divided amongst all
five
I mean I I don't know how that would
affect I don't think they would you know
say no but this is new money for them
this isn't like a continuation of last
year's State funding
representative Weiler
page five of the so-called Monahan
Amendment you've got several items there
under substance use disorder
some of them have matches
there's a few million dollars there
already
so is your question if we do these rate
increases will it benefit this Coalition
of five it seems to be double spending
yes
they're not providers the coalitions are
not they're not providers they're
educational and training and uh
you know community connected prevention
okay
um I think I think we're going to caucus
okay online
51 development services budget carry
forward and reduce General funds
I think those three are done 51 2-3 yep
51 52 and 53 were taken care of by your
earlier actions today they were all
adopted
okay
so
so what do you have to show us on
Medicaid expansion
to represent walner
I I don't I hate to do this but on line
11 Hampstead Hospital operations that is
a big that's a pretty sizable
um general fund
amount that I think
I would like to know
um what this means to Hampstead Hospital
if they don't if they don't get this I
mean why
I can't remember why we why we had that
why that was there
and why do I mean we won't be able to do
it Hampstead
sorry well we did get a briefing on
Hampstead and we probably got some one
of those coloring books and we got a
budget book and all that feels like it
was a year ago so so no I but
so what would you have us do with this
at this point given that we need to move
on I would just like to ask Mr White
what what this 4.5 million
how was that needed by Hampstead what
what are they not going to be able to do
sure so um out of out of any of the
remaining maybe not have any but um in
this particular one the governor's
budget cut hempstead's general fund
portion uh in half
um so out of a
in in the first year you know we we have
a 34 million dollar budget in the second
year we have a 29 million dollar budget
we're going to be going back out to bid
for the well path contract which today
for two years it's a 52 million dollar
contract based on the revenue and the
expenses that I've seen to date we do
not have sufficient funds to fund
Hampstead in the second year right now
if current trends are range true it's
it's a close to 4 million dollar hole
out of out of any of these
state phase down Professional Care out
of any of these other items that one is
just a particular concern to me right
now
the the the first year is actually an
error that that there shouldn't be any
any costs in the state fiscal year 24
here it's just the second year the 4.4
million in the general funds in the
second year
okay that one went too fast for me I I I
I heard that in 24 the 4.4 that's in
there now we don't need that 4.4 and
your concern is in the second year
and you think we need more money in the
second year than the 4.4 that's shown
there now yes Hampstead is already
proving to generate significant Revenue
at a higher rate than New Hampshire
hospital just as a point of comparison
but to expect that only 10 percent of
all of the expenses are generally funded
and which I think just some quick about
to get back to the envelope map that's
what it would come to I I don't think
that's feasible and I don't think we
would have sufficient funds my other
concern is we have to go back out to bid
and and my experience with going back
out to bid is it always costs more so
what's the number
4.4 million dollars I I think in the
second year that's what I already see on
my sheet here I already see in the
second year that there's 4.4 million and
that we've agreed to that in the second
year
you haven't agreed to it it's I grade it
out because the other day when um the
committee was going through these
requests I had no requests from a member
to consider this item
okay so it could still be it should
maybe still be white we still haven't
decided
okay
it could be okay that's fine I there's
just so much detail here uh it's I'm
having a little struggle so 0 and 24 and
and so 4.4 in the second year and you
think that 4.4 is more than the 10
percent of their costs and but about
right for what we probably need to do in
general funds to supplement their
revenues the the 4.4 is what was cut
during the governor's budget from the
agency well actually it was cut more
than that but but that I I think if we
can get that 4.4 back I would feel a lot
better because otherwise otherwise I
would fully expect Hampstead to run a
deficit in 25.
do you need all 4.4 because it sounds
like there's already something in the
governor's budget I am again with
Hampstead we don't have a lot of history
right the the revenues are looking good
I I mean again compared to New Hampshire
hospital
um however we are we are going to be
implementing the the prtf which will
likely decrease the the revenue that we
can bring in
um so having that 4.4 million dollars
there will provide us with some level of
assurance that I in the event we still
come up short I don't have to transfer
four million dollars from somewhere else
to cover that so so your total request
for both years is still just the 4.4
just the 4.4 do you have any comments on
that you open this can of worms thinking
we were going to cut money and now it
sounds like we just added 4.4
it sounds it sounds like it's really
important that we address this oh okay
okay I I misunderstood your opening
question I thought what you thought I
wanted to cut it out I thought you were
challenging it yes
yeah so I asked us to go back to it I
thought it I thought we I asked this
just to go back to it and talk about it
no representative Waller what percentage
of their uh operations are covered by
Revenue
because I think when they were private
it was all covered
so a little probably about
61 percent was covered
um I I will say though that we have a
very different operating model
um and the facility also came up for
sale so I don't necessarily know if
their past history is a good indicator
of how we should operate it going
forward so maybe they were losing money
is there a proposal on this one
foreign
well I would I would propose that we
um approve the 4.4 million
you're 20 25. for 2025 in the second
year if that addresses Mr White's
concerns and thinks that'll
keep them in operating in good state in
the opposition to The Proposal
so I think we're spending more than the
governor
it it it feels like we might be yes
especially when we get to the
rate enhancements
okay you don't think we have the money
so so we we have we have one big lever
that we haven't talked about yet but so
um so a few are in favor of adding that
4.4 in the second year
uh raise your hand
opposed
all right so it carries can you mark me
down as undecided right now yeah if
we've already accounted for this per
represent or chairman Weiler I'd like to
know that I
I'm in doubt but it's worth betting
okay
um
work supplemental program on six
chairman oh yeah you're going sorry
you're going exactly where I wanted you
to go I was going to point out we hadn't
done number six yet
okay
you had skipped over it and I wanted to
bring it back because I'm the person who
wanted to pull it off and discuss it I
skipped it because I I was obsessed with
the really huge number it's system of
care and I thought if we solved the
biggest problem first then these tiny
things would sort of
so
um
so was this in a prioritized need the
Wix supplemental that was not supported
by the governor yes that is correct it
was in the agency prioritizing its
request
and this goes to families with
like
under under the uh 70 percent federal
poverty level probably
you don't know uh I in my notes I have
provided to low-income families for
Redemption at local New Hampshire
farmers markets and administration costs
associated with administering oh yeah oh
the farmer's market yes okay so this is
is this is this the same thing as a SNAP
benefit that we had negotiated last year
and I I think the reason this is on hold
is because I asked somebody to go find
out what promise I made them last year
I I
and and Mr Ripple I was going to look it
up when we first put this program in
play I got to make sure I'm talking
about the same program this is the
program that was was brand new at the
end of last year and this isn't the snap
extra Farmers Market benefit this line
item is based on a bill that was filed
this year yeah
so I think it's a new program
Sometimes women infant and children so
no okay which is different than snap
it's
so we we were awarded a grant in federal
fiscal year 2022 and this is the
required 30 match
only 30 percent
correct okay
all right so
representative tolersky would you like
us to vote in favor of this
yes I'd like to explain why I've got
this BMI bonnet go ahead and I'll be
quick
um
when we heard
um Miss Tilly come and go through these
line items this one really hit me hard
for the low price tag and for the huge
benefit out of it and yesterday when I
was driving here I was listening to nhpr
and they were talking about the
skyrocketing numbers of colorectal
cancer cases in
um people who are younger
and the
primary thing that they talked about to
prevent this kind of cancer was healthy
Mediterranean eating with high produce
and I thought about this bill and I
thought about the people who utilize
this kind of program their low income
they often live in food deserts their
primary grocery store is the Dollar
Store where there's no fresh produce
I also thought about the fact that this
bill helps our farms and our local
businesses it's a win-win it brings
business to our farms and our farms and
our farmers markets and it helps
Children and Families eat healthy
locally grown foods that again is
prevention that will save us in the long
term when we have a healthy strong
community so that is my pitch and I
really hope you guys can
look at this and representative is going
to give me his counter argument which
thank you for finally listening to me so
they live in a food desert with farmers
markets nearby and that the putting more
money in this is going to change their
culture and they're going to eat
healthier
no that's not what I'm saying what Aang
is for example again using my own
Community our downtown
does not have
easily accessible uh low priced you know
grocery stores a lot of them shop at
these Dollar Trees dollar five whatever
we do have however a City Farmers Market
that is right downtown where these
people where the people live and they
can go and access this locally fresh
produce
and it's supported by this program
all right representative here's my
question I I do like your enthusiasm and
and I wish it were
there's I wish it were so but what we've
been through this several times over the
last few years what makes you think
these people are motivated to go and buy
those because I get the benefits they're
totally you're right totally right about
that but the people have to go and
actually buy them to get the benefit
right
I guess I would say what tells you that
they won't
I thought okay because I haven't yeah I
thought because past experience
representative Weiler
my town has a food program where they
put they go and they buy surplus food up
at the state and they put it out on a
table anybody can come in and and pick
it up so I had extra cucumbers and and
some other vegetables in my garden I put
them on the same table
went back three days later
to add some more and nobody had taken
any of the fresh produce but they take
all this stuff and I remember the guy
that worked in the in the in the food
distribution he said and we looked at
some of the stuff he got up at the state
and he said if they have to heat it up
we'll put it in the oven they don't take
it they just want a box they can take an
open and give to the kids to eat they
don't want to do any kind of work or
even heat it in a pan
and that's that's the population we're
dealing with I think that's excuse me Mr
chairman but I think that's somewhat
anecdotal and I think that if
I mean well I think stating that people
aren't going to take advantage of the
program is not not accurate either as I
think the uh the department wouldn't
have brought it forth if they didn't
think it would be an effective way to
promote health
so I will support this is there any way
you can actually in Europe since this is
local to you apparently
get some feedback on your own that it's
working that people actually are taking
advantage of it
I could talk to the legislators who
actually drafted the original bill I
mean I was not a part of that this
literally is just a seed that's been
planted in me since we heard this a
couple weeks ago
and I'm not I'm not arguing for this for
Nashua I'm just saying giving you the
example of our farmers market our
downtown our food desert
thank you chairman our church
um in Auburn is in the business of
giving away a lot of food some of it
comes from the local grocery stores some
of it right but they every Saturday
morning they open up the facility and
they have a line of cars picking up food
um because there's there's a real need
again Ansel
just a single data point not necessarily
um conclusive or
guaranteeing of causation or correlation
but
a large box of potatoes isn't treated
the same way as a bag of potatoes I
don't understand why sometimes the food
that comes in comes in in a box of
potatoes and they'll leave the box of
potatoes but they'll take the stuff
that's either prepared or partially
prepared or the smaller units I don't
understand why it's just an observation
they don't tend to take the healthier
types of bread they tend to take the
white bread I and I'm not saying I'm not
trying to mischaracterize it I I wish
people bought healthy food it's
important I wish people use just the
outer side of the grocery store the ring
all the way around this the outside that
had Refrigeration which is where the
healthier foods tend to be than the Box
stuff in the center but
up by observation that's not what's
happening and it's a societal issue and
I wish we could figure out how to fix it
so we could continue to talk about it
but the key thing I've heard is uh
representative verf is going to vote for
it so from a practical matter we have
the votes already identified
um so so we can just go to a vote but Mr
Ripple
representative Mooney brings up a good
question
do we have a running checkbook because
we're not really I'm not really sure
she's not really sure we're adding money
here and there but it feels to me like
we've added more money than we have
um
you have no running total for today's
actions I think the other two divisions
are in the same boat and I think once
everybody's done for the day we're going
to go back and see where the overall
budget is at and provide you with an
answer so we if we if we were to say we
love this and we vote for it and we find
out that we don't have the money we're
still going to get one more shot at
getting our numbers back in line if we
have to I think you will yes whether
that's a subsequent division meeting or
the full full committee it feels like a
full committee at that point but
okay so
right
I I think some of what we said here was
felt a little stereotypical but there
was a lot of Truth in it too that within
low-income poverty groups there are
significant pockets of folks with not
good habits bad cultural things and I'm
still just thinking that we can put
money on something but unless there's
some cultural change uh it's only going
to go to a select few
but um but that's not to paint everyone
on the same broad brush it just I think
it's just the culture matters so I I
would like to act on representative
tolerski's request to approve item six
at 300 000 a year
um if you're in favor of keeping it
raise your hand
if you're opposed raise your hand
okay so that's passes like six to three
um that was number six that passed
pardon me that was number six that
passed that was six we've approved six
yes sir
thank you
okay but you just I think you just
killed uh representative wallner's uh
number five
too bad so so let's bring up number five
um
I I'm gonna I'm gonna have a caucus on
this
did we we need to show the back of the
budget because that's going to be the
big lever on the day
so there was a version that I handed out
yesterday and I think I have
I think I have spare copies of that if
not I can print some out there's an
updated version in the works but I don't
yet have it back
and that was based on representative
Earth's input by any chance
yes okay all right then I know what it
is
I I am gonna go see if uh representative
felishman can join us
so I'm going to be away do you do you I
don't know if there's anything there you
can have us talk about five-minute
recess
okay we got a 30 second warning
that was my nice way to say
go sit down
okay
I'm gonna bring us out of recess and um
want to start on
item 27
of the status of actions related hb1
only the chairman of division one who's
extremely busy and was able to find a
few minutes to come chat with us
so uh representative leishman would you
would you you've you've seen this
amendment you and I have been
working on this issue together for quite
a while now I don't even know I think we
started about a year ago when we saw
this in the fiscal committee and started
digging into it but go ahead and tell us
what you want to tell us thank you Mr
chairman and seeing Mr White next to me
I've even had conversations about this
particular board with Mr White so this
um so for the record my name is Peter
leishman I represent Peterborough and
Sharon
so the prescription drug affordability
board first came to my attention sitting
on the fiscal committee about a year and
a half or maybe even two years ago
they initially came in for a request for
about four hundred thousand dollars
I had never heard of the prescription
drug affordability board until he
appeared before fiscal and apparently
this board was established through a an
Omnibus Bill it didn't have the review
that normal bills get from the policy
committee it never came to finance
so I started watching their meetings on
YouTube I actually attended one of their
meetings and I was quite concerned to
find
that they had a great deal of authority
to impose fees impose fines and had
never gone through the legislative
process so representative Edwards and I
are both serving on the fiscal committee
developed the mutual concern how this
board developed and what lack of control
they had so that is I believe led to
this amendment that I'm supporting
representative Edwards may be able to
speak in addition to what I've added but
there is some duplication that we have
learned by the insurance department the
department of administrative services so
perhaps if the board had had the normal
oversight in review that other boards
and commissions have had I wouldn't be
sitting here so that's I guess what I
have Mr chairman thanks for the
opportunity to speak
do you have time for a few questions
sure
okay so
um I I think you I think you said it
that
um uh that they have the power to tax
they can impose work requirements on the
private sector they can go out and
contract
independently without any oversight
there's no nothing in the statute to
suggest they have to go through the
ordinary contract process and then and
then they can Levy fines the ability to
level Levy finds has me particularly
concerned because without any oversight
checks and balances is kind of an
autonomous board they have the power to
demand information from the private
sector and uh and if and and and there's
nothing in the statute that that
denotes what a reasonable demand is from
an unreasonable demand they can
basically demand any information that
they want on any timeline that they want
and it's my understanding that if those
require quests don't get satisfied the
section 10 of this stats statute gives
them the ability to Levy fines of up to
a thousand dollars a day for a total of
twenty five thousand is do you think
that that's accurate and and do you
share my concern about this ability to
essentially legislate on the Fly and and
issue fines
and and not only that do I support that
concern but I attended one of their
meetings when they had already announced
that they were sending out bills to
people and there was a representative
there from the Department of Health and
Human Services where the money was to
come and yet there was no request for a
proposal to have the Department of
Health and Human Services to collect
those fees or fines so just a lot of
moving Parts here and it it's something
that deserves the light of day in my
opinion
and then I think you're familiar with
the gel car Hearing in which
um they they took a look at uh the what
was referred to in the statute as the
fees structure and gel car I think it
was unanimous to include our own
representative hatch on our committee uh
made the observation that the the
structure that was in the statute is not
a fee structure it's a tax structure is
is that is that accurate
well representative hatch was like
recall from looking at the
YouTube video was quite concerned what
was being proposed
and the fact that they were taking on
the authority to again Levy taxes fees
and fines and had proposed doing that
without their rules being approved
officially by the rules commit gel car
are there any other questions on this
um all right because I I would like to
move that we accept Amendment 1088
uh as an hb2 item is there any comment
or uh opposition
chairman of the uh of the board
representative Merchant is here and I
think I I would like to hear him
what he has to say about some of the
things that were just said all right uh
thanks thank you for taking the time out
not a problem
representative mershaw
Mr chairman my mother be proud of you
who she's Canadian
foreign first of all I want to say thank
you to the chair and also to the
committee for allowing me to speak today
um
a couple of things one is I went back
and looked at the transcript of gel car
that day
and in the transcript
was
a comment from Judge Lynn who's now
representative Lynn
and talked about the fact is that we
have
an issue as far as the constitutionality
of the fee but it's a constitutional
decision it was not up to the jail card
to make a ruling on that but basically
to bring it to people's attention there
was a concern it wasn't basically saying
that it was in fact unconstitutional
and that's coming directly from the
transcript from representative Lynn
if you look at also where the board is
today
I'll bring a couple comments which I
heard last Friday which caught my
attention I think caught all of us or
should
the state of New Hampshire is now
spending
per year
290 million dollars for prescription
drugs
let that sink in 290 million dollars
it's approaching 20 percent of the
budget
and we don't have a mechanism in place
at this point in time to try to as a
state
bring some sort of control over that or
at least try to bring the cost down
that's only what we pay through Medicaid
it doesn't include state employees it
does not include counties cities towns
and also school districts
remember that those
or in those positions of funded through
taxpayers dollars so if we're serious
about reducing the burden to the
taxpayer
then we should be thinking about
how to bring down the overall cost of
drugs
I've heard from people saying
this may not work
and it may not
but if we don't try
we won't get there either
so when you think about a 290 million
dollar budget that we're spending as a
state
four hundred fifty thousand dollars is a
drop in the bucket
and what I'm trying to say at this point
in time is with all the state agencies
why don't we find a way to work
collectively with the other ones we've
talked about redundancy I don't think
it's redundancy completely but finding a
way to take and pull together all the
resources in our state we're uniquely
qualified
because we are a small state we can work
together collectively that's the granite
way we roll up our sleaze and we work
together collectively for the benefit of
the whole
and what the board is uniquely qualified
to do is to pull together the resources
of the state to accomplish that
so when you think about Commerce 2 in
Commerce there was two bills introduced
House Bill 130 to repeal the board and
house bill 172.
that was to talk about redundancy
and also talking about putting the board
or suspending it for a period of time
until the report came out
both of those bills
house bill 30.
was voted 17-0 to retain it
no one that I heard in that transcript
during that meeting talked about
the board itself as far as the mission
of the board
there was concerns about the funding of
the board and some of the things we
talked about
in the committee and I testified at the
committee and I'll do it again with you
folks here today
I'll be willing to work with anyone to
fix the legislative issues I'm not
saying there isn't issues out there
but let's work together to solve the
problem through a stakeholder committee
meeting and do it that way so are you
aware that um the the amendment here uh
refers to the insurance department
redundancy elimination report that the
department of insurance and
collaboration with the prescription drug
affordability board shall issue a report
on the elimination of redundancies
related to The Collection analysis and
Reporting on prescription drug prices
between the two organizations including
proposed legislation on such elimination
with the overarching goal of promoting
efficiency in economy this report will
be submitted to HHS oversight the
Speaker of the House the president
Senate and the house Clerk and governor
no later than October 124. so it seems
to me like we're in agreement we're in
agreement in some ways representative
Edwards in a sense that we talked about
that in the Commerce Committee about
pulling together as stakeholder group to
talk about what we can do to address the
concerns that were raised about
redundancy and about how we fund it and
I totally support pulling together
stakeholder community
for the benefit of all of us in to your
point let's think it through slow it
down and do it right and not do it fast
I think that's what this amendment does
and it and it clarifies the the
Constitutional issue on the tax
structure of the of the board by saying
the funding will be General funds that
gets rid of the Constitutional issue
altogether and it also allows for
voluntary donations and contributions to
the board over and above what the state
general funding could be it does um I
just want to bring it to the attention
of this
committee and I want to say
representative Alicia was correct way
back in the finance committee we went to
the finance committee joint finance
committee asking for funds and he was
absolutely right we didn't have rules in
place and we heard him and we responded
and we spent the whole year developing
rules to put that in place one of the
things that gel Carr asked when we were
going through rulemaking there's no
rules in there to accept gifts so at
this point in time even though it may be
in statute we don't have anything in
rules in order for us to accept the
gifts if that was so desired
okay so
um are there other questions
representative Weiler
yes
representative can you point to any
savings that the board has had result
of being in place
I wish I could representative Weller the
board has been challenged with a lack of
resources we've been spending a lot of
our time working on rules which were
required by The Joint fiscal committee
we spend a lot of time trying to at this
point in time get an mou through the
process so we have been trying to build
the infrastructure that we need in order
to show the results
um that's kind of where we are today
follow-up do you know if we still get
rebates from the big pharmas
I would love to answer that question I
don't know but that's one of the things
I think the board's trying to understand
is where the money's going I
at one point we'll be getting as much as
20 million in rebates from some of the
as you say we spend hundreds of millions
in in Pharmacy for all the people that
we provide medication to so we were
sometimes getting some pretty big
rebates
there was and also just to bring it to
your attention you may not be aware of
this but the centene which is one of the
Managed Care organizations that we are
working with in the state of New
Hampshire has now decided to pull out of
the drug business and rationale toys
because they basically got caught with
the hand of the cookie jar
um they put aside nationally 1.25
billion dollars and so far they've paid
back to Stage 750 million
so in the state of New Hampshire did
collect some money on that as well
um I was just saying is that should not
have happened the reason that why it
happened was a colleague of mine in the
state of Ohio working the same capacity
in a sense not per se where the
prescription drug affordability report
but working on this issue uncovered the
issues that were going on and brought
the people's attention and it's now gone
National and that's all because somebody
took the time to look under the hood and
try to find out what was going on
we made good use of the fine money can I
take 450 000 please
so so I follow up on your your question
about uh demonstrated savings there
there I think there were two states that
basically implemented the same model
legislation at the same time Maine and
New Hampshire and all the reports from
Maine indicate that they're struggling
and they're not having much success
getting their program established and
and really working
so that that is correct chairman Edwards
International that they're running into
the state has not funded their
organization of that program either
per presentable did you have a question
representative Wallner
so representative Merchant
all of the work that's gone on in the
last
couple of years with this board has all
been voluntary is that my understanding
it's 100 voluntary we have been
fortunate to some degree working with
the Department of Health Human Services
they've been gracious enough to help
with some of the administrative
functions but it's been for the most
part the board itself all voluntary work
including all of the clerical work and a
lot of the work that's being done you're
looking at it
so uh representative
but to this point I hope uh you should
know that
um rather than trying to kill this
um the this amendment allows it to
continue it allows you to go get
Contract support in the old days I
called them personal services contracts
essentially you know an employee to work
for you to do a lot of the work that
you've been doing on your own so there
is Manpower in here and there is other
expenses and it's all getting paid for
by the general funds on the belief that
we all share the same objective we would
like to find a way to get a good lever
through the use and exploitation of
information to help drive a more
competitive market I think the objective
is the same the issue is just that I've
been worried about is just having it uh
done in a way in which our our own state
government processes
respect the checks and balances expected
of government and operate with the
transparency and the and and the checks
and balances that it should so so I
think we share a lot in common uh with
the way we view this but I I haven't
worked it like you have so I have
um
I'm less committed to the program than
you are as it makes sense thank you for
that Mr chairman I'll say this
I have worked in a space for over 30
years it is very complicated it's very
complex it is a lot of disincentives
along the way that people don't really
understand unless you're in the space my
whole goal here is to bring greater
transparency to the marketplace to allow
the people who are buying prescription
drug benefit programs to understand some
of the things that are going on in the
market so they can become a better
stewards of how they spend the money in
regards to looking at a contract
employee I see this here in the language
Mr chairman in my opinion of all my
years working
contract employees are nice but they
don't end up
costing more money ultimately than
employees themselves we've talked about
this before I think representative
Weiler you brought it up people from
Hitchcock if you're contracted how much
are you actually invested in the process
versus being under contract
um and I have
no from my times together when you have
somebody who's actually working for
who's invested in a program the way they
approach things and how they take on the
passion for their job is totally
different than somebody sometimes under
contract
representative you have a question I was
going to summarize what I heard because
I I think there's part of this it's
Finance but part of this was also rules
and I don't know if the current
amendment is clear enough regarding
making sure rules are in place
and we might need to tweak it for that
so I'm if representative Merchant can
answer yes because if in order for us to
receive
grants or funds outside of the general
treasury we're going to have to have
rules according to gel cart so that's
one of the things again rulemaking is a
long process it's arduous at times for
those who've been on gel car it's nice
because we have a lot of transparency in
the process but it does take time so I
don't want to rely upon grants coming in
to help fund the board because the
likelihood of that happening over the
next 12 months is relatively you know
yes so but but why isn't the the rule
making in here because the rule making
is in the underlying statute and I'm not
changing that oh no and they have over a
year working on the rules already so
go ahead could we not just give them the
ability via statute to receive funds to
this organization I don't see that's
what this amendment does it does two
things it converts the the their tax
structure to a uh General funds and it
opens up an account because we heard new
Futures in AARP say they had such strong
support for this program that they
thought it ought to be funded so we gave
them a vehicle to contribute to this
effort so so the the the funds that the
general fund would is just sort of the
minimum bid and then those organizations
that X that voice such strong support
have an opportunity to contribute to the
effort lines 10 and 11. voluntary
contributions correct but again I want
to point out that in order for that to
happen it does require rulemaking that's
what gel cart told us so therefore in
order for us from a financial point of
view to to begin to even consider taking
those monies into the coffers to help
the board you're looking at at least the
12-month period of time so when you're
looking at funding the first year will
not have any grants coming into it until
we get through rulemaking
any questions representative Waller
when I look at this and I I'm looking at
I guess the budget that was in the
governor's budget the budget that was in
the governor's budget and then I'm
looking at what the board adopted and
now I'm looking at a very skinny budget
of seventy five thousand dollars and
the contract services are sixty thousand
dollars and I'm just wondering
what kind of I mean this feels like to
me I don't know a lot about it but
it feels like to me you need someone who
has a lot of expertise and now we're
talking about this person having to
probably
write rules and I know that writing
rules
is complicated and the department spends
hours and hours and hours and months
writing the rules so what can we get
what are we going to get for sixty
thousand dollars
not very much
um just thinking about again if if the
legislative body is truly trying to find
a strategy and develop strategies to
bring down the 290 million dollar budget
just for the state
on an annual basis not including all the
other dollars we spend on taxpayers
um sixty thousand dollars is not going
to get us very far
I think we need to have somebody who has
the knowledge base that we can hire to
help us understand how to develop those
strategies there are strategies out
there I talked to resident of Holt
earlier they give an example
when you start talking about drug waste
just just an example one strategy to
talk about drug waste folks there's
thousands of dollars that pass through
that never get utilized a lot of the
Pharma companies of pbms
got caught again sending things to
patients without them asked for it was
automatic refills
and Tricare the government stopped it
because people were getting drugs after
drugs after drugs and they were not
utilizing it why didn't they stop it
because the only way you make money in
the pharmacy supply chain is when you
sell something
so there's no incentive to stop the
process at the medical center we had
thousands of dollars to Remicade that we
couldn't use why because they kept
coming even though the patient wasn't
asked to have it and the patient would
die the patient would change the therapy
and we couldn't reuse it we call the
manufacturer and said can we send it
back to you nope
we it's one way only sixty thousand
dollars is a penis so the higher the
reason it's 60 000 is because we
anticipated some higher lag if you think
that should be eighty thousand I you
know I'm fine with that but but the the
uh you know
we should look at this with just a
little bit of humility we are New
Hampshire we're a very small part of the
overall International Global Drug market
we've got the federal government We're
the Chief Executive who said
controlling drug perform prescription
drug prices is a top Administration
whole government issue priority for them
so to think that we're going to stand
something up here in New Hampshire
that's that's going to move the needle
in the context of all the global
economic issues going on and govern
government regulatory is I I don't know
I this is why I think this should just
uh take a pause and really make sure
that this program is is built right and
built in consistently with the other
lovers of government so that we have you
know a unified approach to maximize what
we're trying to do and representation so
with that I'm I think I'm going to just
move on this because we've spent time
representative Edwards you couldn't send
any better than I could I don't disagree
with us sitting down all of us including
yourself over the summer and figuring
how to make it right and do it that way
versus trying to do it here in 10
minutes in this committee
it's been more than 10 minutes this
issue has been going since uh November
and and now we're at a point where uh
you know to get confidence that there's
going to be discussion and a real look
at redundancy we're going to statute
because the comments and requests to
look at it for quite a while were pushed
aside is is not being true observations
that there was any redundancy so I I'm
sorry there's a trust but verify moment
here too
so um
so I would like to get a vote on whether
or not 1088
should be accepted
show hands
those opposed
okay so
1088 has been accepted there's also a
Waller amendment that does something
similar it uh there it's that it's
consistent in the sense that I think you
recognize that we could move this to
General funds but you kept their budget
levels so do you have anything more to
add
I think I can
see with the vote I can visualize what
the vote will look like so I'll just
withdraw it you'll withdrawn okay
thank you representative Edwards and
this isn't the end of this conversation
although it started with the you and me
in November I don't think we're we're
done I mean probably this we're going to
have the same conversation in the Senate
I I hope so
um represent Edwards because
prescription drug costs are causing a
lot of heartburn not just for the
taxpayers but for a lot of people so
what we've been disagreeing about is
whether or not this is an effective use
of resources and if this is the way the
government should behave this was
unlimited power essentially in a very
small group that had no checks and
balances so we have time to look at that
as well I hope thank you so
um what else do we got we have
um where are you at Mr Ripple I asked
you to ignore what we were doing here uh
so that you could focus on that rate
uh let's see so how are you doing on the
rate paperwork do we need to take a
recess because we could take one if you
need some more time to just send your
stuff up off to OLS it would help if you
if the committee took about a
30 minute recess all right any problems
with 30-minute recess what else do I
need to know about your schedules for
today anyone got like a doctor's
appointment or anything okay
you have a four o'clock phone call
okay quick okay so we're going to be in
recess until
405.
I I left it open until eight o'clock I
hope not to be there this long that way
let me take care of your wife happy wife
happy life
um
testing this mic it works okay
foreign
thank you
what what's your status Mr Ripple
regarding having the uh the Medicaid
rate increase Amendment ready to send
over
right it is with OLS and they're working
on it now okay now how when do you think
they they'll have that cooked
I'm honestly not sure I think it's
I'm really not prepared to commit to a
specific time at this point okay so so
anticipating that answer
the next question is do you have enough
information that we can share for people
to look at
so that they can agree on the concept we
can vote on the concept
see it later and then maybe Friday is
nothing more than confirming that it's
written the way we wanted it to be
you don't like that
or you're thinking about it
I think it would be much better if the
committee voted on an actual amendment
in hand okay
so we're anticipating being here until
eight o'clock at night do you think
it'll be done by then it'll be done by
eight I
it'll be done before 8 o'clock
I I would mention to guess
I don't want to give a time but I would
say before six okay all right
um so anyone who can hear me
we are out of recess and division three
is uh is started up
first item of business
there was some discussion during the the
break about and this is a conversation
primarily with uh Mr Ripple anyways so
so Mr Ripple
on on the amendment
1088 Hotel the one that we just accepted
on the prescription drug affordability
board okay
what we'd like to do is amend this
amendment
so that instead of it being 75 and 100
it's 250 in each of the years I know
that's the hb1 amendment yep so but I'm
just telling you the sort of the whole
agreement okay so instead of 75 100 it's
250 250.
instead of the one contract employee
it's one
permanent and I can write this down for
you but
okay so in the house bill one side
it was I'm sorry did you say 250 and
250. yes sir
and and um we can talk about the
breakdown between the accounts uh but um
so so the the first thing we need to
fund
is
um somewhere there was a budget request
where they ask for an executive director
it was a permanent unclassified position
we want to approve the executive
director
position
but we want to Sunset it two years after
higher
so this will also necessitate a revised
version of the hospital 2 Amendment yes
I think so
because we're changing the one contract
employee
so so so I think I think that's uh it's
two years sunset
permanent unclassified executive
director
at the level that was specified earlier
in the budget process
total budget 250 and 250.
that that's going to be my proposed
amendment to the amendment here in just
a moment and I'll explain it
I just wanted to make sure that while I
had time Mr Ripple understood what what
I was trying to do
Okay so
we have everyone back okay so we just
voted 5-4 to accept
hb2 item
1088 that basically had a contract
employee and of 75 000 and then 100 000
in the second year general fund
allocation and the agreement reached
with representative Marshawn was
um that that employee will go will go
back to the executive director who's
going to be an unclassified employee
and the executive director shall be
appointed by and serve at the pleasure
of the board
um we're going to do 250 250 the sunset
on the exposition will be for two years
and that gives him
the capacity the bandwidth to do all the
analysis and all the establishment of
all of the rules for this very
complicated board
so it's it's less it's less of a beating
than what this was and representative
Merchant
and I came to just an agreement that if
he if we did that uh he he would no
longer oppose the amendment
so okay
um rep representative somebody would you
have a question no I was just going to
say thank you for working that out with
representative Merchant I think he
really appreciated it I've worked with
him before Gary and I get along great we
just we're just a little at odds on this
but I I I I think he's legitimate when
he says he wants to work it out
and and like I said we agree on the
intent it's just we have to have the
right government approach to trying to
achieve that result so would you state
what you heard me say about an amendment
to 1088 and the attending hb1 item
please
so you would like 1088 to be revised so
that the board could still employ an
executive director and did you want that
to be an unclassified employee still if
you if you go and look at one zero eight
eight you'll see the strikethrough okay
so just reverse the strike through this
reverse the strikethrough
yes but Sunset the position two years
after higher yes all right
and and so that kind of a position will
generate
salary line and benefits lines and other
benefits lines and whatever is left
after that can be put into sort of a
general that General expense line okay
and so on the hospital one side in
addition to that
allocation between the the personnel
class lines you want the total to be 250
000 per year of General funds yes okay
could we put one dollar in the uh other
Revenue under contributions
sure because I'll give them a buck
but but AARP and
new new wave new Futures whatever it is
sounds like they may want to give them a
bunch of money yeah but where are they
going to put it representative Edwards
they're going to figure it out these
guys build accounts all the time
okay
okay all right
if you put a dollar in via the budget
the account has to be created yeah so
we'll do a dollar
all right um
with that amendment can I just go ahead
and do a a vote show hands all those in
favor of amending the pdab amendment as
I just described please raise your hand
those opposed
okay good thank you
um
so we had a discussion on item 10.
and I think what we want to do on item
10.
is to to take those numbers
oh you know what
we I think we wanted to cut the general
funds by 60 percent
but is what happens to the federal match
if we cut
at 60 percent on the system of care
will that get reduced 60 percent as well
it probably right
I didn't consider that
in our caucus
looking at this line item line
yeah
um likely yes again some of the
complexities around these contracts is
that the funding source is contingent
upon the individual
whether it's Medicaid title for e Foster
Care or other federal funds
okay so so Ms Fox we have a a proposal
to reduce the general funds numbers to
60 of what's currently shown which is
year one uh 12.4 essentially in year two
again 12.4
the director of
the behavioral health
um I know there were questions earlier
about this be happy to answer those
questions but directly
um
to your point we put the this request in
based on experience for contracts that
we had never had in place before in
funding services that we hadn't funded
before and so we now have better numbers
and this is the request that reflects
those to provide support for a Workforce
that would not be captured in the
Medicaid rate increase
questions representable so is it
possible for you to break out what of
that 12.4 was pre-existing contracts and
what if that is new
so that all of the system of care
contracts those were enrolled providers
through dcyf which has a different
enrollment than Medicaid otherwise every
single contract was brand new and the
funding was new as a result of
legislative actions in previous years
so there is no history because we just
got these contracts in place within
about a year ago I believe yeah these
funds would be brand new because after
our experience we found that the
providers are short in order to have the
capacity they don't have the workforce
and this would provide that funding that
has been identified as needing to be
able to fully
use the capacity the beds that they have
and to fully staff and utilize those
beds
so
looking at this maybe
um when what year did we have the bucket
with all the holes in it that stuff was
draining out anyway that was a
transportation bucket if I recall get
the mic just a little closer my hearing
is getting worse one year we had a
bucket that had a bunch of holes and
stuff was a pouring throw if we're
trying to fill in the gaps right now in
the overall budget and we're starting up
new programs with new contracts
unfortunately that that's an area that's
unfortunately makes higher high on the
list of things that might be an area to
try and find some money so I'm guessing
my question to you is if we were to to
cut it back to 60 of the state they
anticipated ask
what can you do with that
um is 60 or roughly 60 the right number
is there a particular set of contracts
that you guys would say these are the
ones that we want and these are the
three or four that are really important
to us we take these over the others
the contracts are underfunded because we
had the lack of experience to determine
what the cost was going to be again that
we have those three buckets of funding
and we're finding that many of the
children that need these residential
services
are not dcyf involved so we can't use
the federal funds that come for dcyf
they're not for Medicaid expenses
Medicaid billable expenses and in fact
we're going to be coming to the fiscal
Committee in April asking for a transfer
of funds into this line item to help
support shortfalls in these contracts
no no this is good information that's
representative Waller
thank you for thanks for you for being
here
so before you came Nathan said that this
is probably affects about four to five
hundred
people I think children and
what I want to what I'm interested in I
all of these programs are 24-hour
programs they're all running they all
have
children in them and
what happens if this rate increase is
not in place
and we know what the cost to take we
know that this is a very expensive
service are these are these providers
going to be viable do you have a feeling
that any of them would leave
the field and not not be able to take
care of some of our kids
so I don't have hard data on that so I
want to make sure that I give you that
context however there are providers that
are struggling mightily and may choose
not to continue to provide the services
to the state
and if you recall I think we did a
presentation talking about the different
levels of care and so we're finding that
the levels of care that are needed in
the community are it's based on Acuity
and so the level three and level fours
are the ones that you start ratcheting
up the Acuity level and so that requires
a staffing ratio if those children
aren't getting the services through
these programs I think that we could
speculate on where they would end up and
what would happen with families with the
Youth Detention Center
Etc
representative Waller
thank you
did the did the governor's people give a
reason why they didn't fund this
we we didn't receive any specific reason
my assumption is like many of our
prioritized needs they were working
within their revenue projections
thank you
so in other words the governor didn't
have the revenue to fund it it was
considered and at this point we're
starting to think that we may have less
money than the governor so so this is
this is not an easy decision are are
there any you have a representative how
many facilities are you talking about
for these four to five hundred beds I
have the notes I'd have to go back and
um just check it oh
so
um we I think we have uh
we have 31 programs I believe so when we
talk about programs then we talk about
the actual contracts I I want to get the
accurate number and not um State
something erroneously but I can get that
information a question for either of you
do there are the contracts cost uh cost
base or are they fixed rate uh with a
point in time with after you've done
cost analysis you re-review the rates or
or something else
typically with these contracts it's cost
reimbursement but Nathan's scrolling
through the contract to see what the
payment terms are
so it could be we've been making
payments and
um on a projection basis and then the
cost reconciliation is coming up with
something different no so so the the
governor and council is extremely
adamant about never paying in advance
95 percent of our contracts are cost
reimbursement if they're not cost
reimbursement they're payment upon
deliverable I'm just verifying that that
this is cost reimbursement
um
so
we
yes yeah we we we follow the the the
same process whereby we receive invoices
before we make payment for for these
individuals and because of that so they
need to have a bed filled in order to
bill and if they have Staffing shortages
they're unable to bill because
um and so that makes it precarious for
them and and puts them at risk
we don't pay for empty beds
so it's one of the possibilities of a d
of a non-funding of this uh this request
just a reduction in the number of
available services or beds with this uh
which would free up enough money to
raise the rates but uh dramatically uh
reduce our capacity
I think the answer is yes
and Mr chairman to your point asking
about the reduction by 60 percent I
think that
um
oh 60 so 40 reduction
so I you know I would advocate for any
funding that you could provide and find
room in um as you do your projections
and your funding
um knowing that it still will be short
but it's better than nothing
more comments questions representative
hold that you have a proposal
I think I'd leave the proposal what was
discussed and start there and just I
guess can you
prioritize some of the programs because
it's not 60 percent of the rate increase
right that doesn't help because that may
not attract the staff as necessary it
might be that certain certain facilities
or programs
see a larger increase but you don't fund
all of them
I think we want to take that back but
yes that would be something that we
would consider okay so I thought the
proposal I was expecting was that you
were going to ask us for a straw vote on
taking this line item and making it 60
percent of the request that's what I
thought you were going to say I I will
gladly make that request so Mr chair
would you please do a straw vote on line
10 at 60 of these numbers I will that's
surprising uh so all those in favor of
reducing line 10 to 60 percent of the
ask raise your hand
opposed
okay
um all right so I want to talk about uh
representative walners Amendment we've
already passed one of them
uh this one I want to talk about next is
um
the seven million dollar one one zero
nine three
I have on my note that we want to I
wrote Sunset but I didn't say what I
meant about that what do you recall what
we were going to do on sun setting this
is there any component of this that we
said we we could Sunset I think you I I
thought when you said it I thought you
were saying that
um it would at the end of the biennium
it would have to be Revisited
I okay I like that I just didn't want to
misremember something so
so my
motion if if you'll accept this is I'd
like to go ahead and accept your
Amendment as is with the provision that
this expires at the end of this budget
okay all those in favor raise your hand
okay that passes
oh so now we're going to talk about line
item five sorry could I just ask which
amendment number that was yes sir that
was uh the one zero nine three okay
thank you
so it was all fine except we just need
to position it so it expires at the end
of this budget cycle
okay are you are you caught up
yes and just to be clear so you did not
take
you did not take a similar vote on one
zero nine zero we have not okay Mr chair
did we agree on the language that it was
going to be instead of 85 350 percent of
FPL
I thought we did
I I think we did but uh I'm it
do you mind if what did we decide on
that one I I would like to try to get
consistent language across statutes so
that legislators can compare apples to
apples you know so when we know we're
doing something in program X that it
should be related to program y
is what do you think about that in this
case I think it turns out to be more
money if you if you make the eligibility
a different you know the the comparable
FPL number is it fed language that came
along with a match
this I did this is the federal language
okay but but there are many programs
including child care at this point that
use
percentage of poverty so I mean I think
it can be either way I think it will
cost a little more if you do the 350.
so if this is compatible with the
federal language I don't want to make
that more complicated I want the federal
language to be easily interpreted okay
okay great
all right it's a little less I think too
sure so
um so I think did we do a strong vote on
that
yes okay so then I was getting ready to
talk about line item five why not line
item five without an eruption is the
home voting formula grant
visiting because my eyesight is not good
home visiting formula grant
uh representative erf do you have a
recommendation on this or was that
representative Mooney that was going to
talk about this
yeah
so we're gonna
not approved in the governor's phase
my con
okay thank you Mr chairman I would move
to delete then that line
the conversation around deletion of line
five
do you know how I feel about no so okay
so motion on deletion of line five Raise
your hands if you're in favor
uh opposed
okay so we're going to delete that line
okay
now we'll go to the walner amendment
this one had an effect of about 2.9
Million
we wanted to make sure that this Sunset
so that it was just during this budget
year
were there any other changes in there I
see notes on our discussions but I don't
see anything else that needed to be
tweaked
you see anything else that we'd agreed
to tweak no I see nothing else okay so I
propose that we accept
one zero nine zero
with a provision that this will sunset
at the end of this budget cycle
right
okay all right all those in favor raise
your hand
opposed
okay
Mr chair did we already do one zero six
zero I think we did
yes
okay so let's come to the sysc line
representative hole did you have
something you'd like us to vote on
so
um
as proposed before right we should
include the three right we should ask
the department to put in the body
scanner I did look it is an x-ray system
but it is versus millimeter wavelength
but it is not something that's going to
create issues I still would leave the
funding at the 1099
sorry the 999 10 million dollars total
um which is approximately a 2.5 million
dollar reduction in the overall budget
and so that includes the flexibility to
be put in the footnote to to go buy that
piece of equipment
correct and it includes the flexibility
to move money around within the accounts
as appropriate
go ahead so I think if you're reducing
the entire budget to 10 million per year
then I don't really have any detail on
how to reduce the individual line
numbers unless you want a proportional
reduction so if you're going to go that
route it might be better to just do this
as a house built too appropriate I know
you've already voted to take it out of
House Bill 2 but it might be better to
do it as a House Bill 2 appropriation of
a straight 10 million per year couldn't
can't we keep it in HP one with a
footnote that the department can move
between expensive items without fiscal
approval but all of the individual class
lines add up to 11 million one hundred
twenty three thousand in the first year
and eleven million four hundred nine
thousand in the second so
so just do a proportional reduction to
get to 10 million okay and with a foot
now and that way it still lives in hb1
okay
that would mean none of the class lines
are budgeted accurately because the
personnel class lines are to the dollar
based on people in those positions today
or if they're vacant they're funded at
step one so you're saying you you want
to keep the Personnel line item the same
and the benefits the same and that any
modification to get to the 10 million
should come from the other expense lines
uh the the medical staff is also a
contracted line
um I I mean if I I think if it's the per
if it's the intention of the committee
to reduce it to 10 million at this point
in time
um just just given the time we have I
mean I don't know if you just give an
hb2 provision as Kevin was suggesting to
provide a back of the budget cut for
those years
I you you trailed off because my hearing
is bad the last sentence about the next
year what did you it I I mean I I think
at this point in time just just get
given where we're at and I won't
necessarily have time to work with the
finance team and and Joe ribsum to
determine which lines we should reduce
whether it's an hb2 provision that
essentially directs the department to
cut to cut
State fiscal year 24 by 1.1 million and
1.4 million dollars in say fiscal year
25 as an hb2 provision if that would be
the best way to go so that we're not
creating class lines that are that are
inaccurate
the majority of the money is in
personnel
he doesn't leave it in hp2
I know but we spent so much time talking
about getting from hp2 to HP one so
future budget committees can have of
continuity and
I get it but if we're gonna do this
that's the recommendation it makes sense
all right
okay so do I understand this correctly a
house bill 2 appropriation of 10 million
per year stating that of that 300 000
shall be used for the purchase of a full
body scanner
um
I I would almost prefer something like
uh not to exceed 325
000 or you know so that if they if they
get a deal for 260 you know they can
they can use the change
an amount not to exceed 325 000.
and we think it's going to be three
hundred thousand I've heard it could be
as low as 250. I just don't want to like
whatever excess money can be reapplied
somewhere else I wanted it available
got it uh representative Wallner or do
you have a question representative
Mooney you almost never speak do you
have something to say
thank you you had mentioned Mr White
that there are contract agreements
perhaps maintenance agreements and the
like are the figures we're tossing
around now about this body scanner going
to cover all of the expenses not just
the purchase thank you
well we would be reducing the entire
budget by 2.5 million dollars so
um
to hit those numbers we would probably
have to hold positions vacant or
find find funding from somewhere make
certain assumptions through a transfer
process to to figure that out
so
I'd like to recess for five minutes
[Music]
okay
um we're gonna come back out of our
caucus recess and um representative hole
what do you have to say
um after much discussion
um instead of adjusting the entire
budget and moving it to hb2 will reduce
what the reduction that we're talking
about and take out the one million
dollars which is the 500 000 per year in
overtime leaving the rest of the budget
where it is but allowing the flexibility
to still move money amongst accounts if
you need to do overtime
okay
so
any further discussion on that do you
understand Mr Ripple you got it
I do so zero out the overtime
allow add a footnote allowing
flexibility to move between accounts
without going to fiscal and also
allowing for or requiring up to 325 to
be spent on a scanner right
the 325 comes out of this total
somewhere wherever
yes not in addition to it's part of it
yep representative walner and the
flexibility to move between lines
includes personnel
it would be all lines if it's written
the way I expect it to be written okay
all lines I think that was the intent
was all lines right we're trying to give
them an operating budget
okay
thank you
all right so
um if you're in favor of the new whole
proposal raise your hand
if you're opposed to the whole okay
so all right so we're going to go with
the whole proposal please
let's bring up
um the Earth amendment to line 24 the
back of the budget Personnel reduction
do you have that
is what that was was the earth Amendment
passed out yesterday just one moment you
had so you had a version
um my version and then there was a Nerf
amendment I believe well this one is
also in your name and I do have it back
God he's good at it
Mr chair is 0.927h still in play though
for this for the purpose of discussion I
I I'm sort of lost what was the purpose
of that
that was the same
that was the same back of the budget I'm
not sure the difference real quick I'll
look at it
okay
so I believe that's what we're talking
about 11 49 first
go ahead are you ready for me okay all
right so this is limiting three
categories of head counts
and then eliminating then the money the
revenue the general fund freeing up is
coming from eliminating the positions
above those head counts so in the case
of full-time permanent it's restricting
it to 3 000 which Nets out to
uh
213 full-time permanent positions I
guess we're above that that were funded
fully funded
I'm not mistaken is that is that a read
that or 22 full-time what is my how do I
read that Mr Ripple
oh
there are 22 full-time temporary
positions that are currently funded that
would not be funded as a result of this
amendment okay so 213 permanent flow
time would not be funded 22 temporary
full-time would not be funded and 84.
a temporary part-time would not be
funded is that accurate
yes okay over the two years so the net
result of removing those positions is
the 27 million nine hundred thousand
dollars you see
the reduction in general funds
is that accurate
that with these Personnel limitations
the net effect as we'd expect
27.9 million that's correct although
that figure is an estimate
um it assumes on who gets I I get it
it's yes
and to be clear at least from my point
of view yeah
um I can't speak for anybody else
um the idea behind this is again to
boost the Medicaid uh the funds
available to the Medicaid um
right enhancements
from my point of view
right I I I I agree anytime we can find
any money I I want to put it into the
Medicaid rate
um
all right so representative waller or
norgren either of you so
the 213 positions are they filled
positions are they
positions where some are unfilled that's
a great question representative I
apologize I should have been much more
clear about that I don't have my notes
so funny but they're definitely not
filled positions in fact they even in
all three cases they leave uh quite a
bit of Headroom um off the top of my
head they're about a
they still have
quite a few vacancies up to 80 percent
of their current total hundred percent
in each of the three cases
so in no case it was any was that it was
a person a field position a person a
position filled with a person filled I
eliminated that didn't happen at all and
they're also still empty fully funded
positions in each of those three
categories
thank you
so let me just expand expound on that
but uh okay so when we did something
similar last budget at the time the
department had something like 3200 and
change authorized full-time permanent
employees
they had only 2 650 that were actually
filled
so when we set the limit at 3 000
the the working logic at the time was
that gave them the ability to prioritize
the higher of 350
employees up to 350 new employees
and given the workforce vacancy rates
across the state
it didn't seem like that was going to be
a harsh limit that they were going to
have trouble filling all those anyways
at least that was what was in my mind
and so
this this continuation of effectively a
3 000
limit ceiling
I don't know what the actual bill rate
is this time around I think I've asked
I've probably been told three times but
I I I I I think they probably have
somewhere in the 2000s for actual fill
so they probably still have some room
between the fill that they're at and and
three thousand
yes so could Mr White do you have any
comment to make sure so just just to be
clear so the the 213 positions and the
22 full-time 84 part-time that assumes
those positions are 100 General funds
very few of our positions are 100
General funds so like some really quick
back of the envelope math we have about
350 360 million dollars of personnel
costs and that includes OT part-time
full-time class 10 class 12.
some quick quick math you take 50 of
that you're like you're you're basically
about 174 million dollars in general
funds so and then you take the 27.9
and you apply that to that this would
force us to have a minimum vacancy rate
of what I'm estimating I'm just doing
some quick math here 15 to 16 of our
positions so we had a we had a 21
vacancy rate in November the
commissioner has been pushing HR to
develop very clear strategies for hiring
we're currently 19 this is going to hurt
the department in a really bad way if
we're targeting positions the people are
the heart of the department and when it
comes to New Hampshire Hospital
Hampstead the path Center when I you
know basically if this goes through come
July I'm going to tell Joe ripsom hold X
number of
um of of child protective service
workers vacant for the biennium I'm
going to tell Melissa Hardy pulled X
number of Adult Protective Service
workers and you know for this biennium
it's 22.6 million dollars and for New
Hampshire hospital that equated to over
three million dollars in general funds
positions so it's going to be that much
higher higher but dcyf that's the area
where the positions BFA that's area with
positions New Hampshire hospital
glencliffe all of these areas that's
what we'd be targeting
I totally recognize the difficult place
that you are in because you you know you
and you you guys probably say same thing
about me but it's not lost on me by any
means but but I think to Target the
Personnel I don't think and I spoke with
the commissioner about this earlier we
we don't think that's a good way to go
about this at all if you want to give us
a back of the budget cut fine give us a
back a budget cut but the 3 000
positions in the 213 they're meaningless
because we actually receive a much
deeper cut when we're targeting General
funds and personnel only
so so what's your offer on the back of
the budget dollar cut
I mean a worse or I don't know it's it's
kind of like like lemon juice or salt in
a wound yes and so if we're going to put
salt in the wound I'd rather just have a
back to the budget cut and not Target
Personnel I'm just asking you for the
number now
a number
we're going to do a back of the budget
cut so so what would that number be
I I I think that's really a policy
decision I mean we we submitted our our
agency budget and I mean that those were
our priorities can I ask a different
question go ahead uh oh representative
go ahead sorry when I looked through
your budget I see a lot of contracts
that go out others
what percentage do you think is going
out in contract in your budget some of
the lines I look at it it's almost 30 40
percent going out in contracts sure
um it is a significant number
um our Personnel is about 10 of our
budget
um I mean we we have accounts like we
have the DD account that's 400 and some
odd million dollars each year we have
our MCO you know that our 7948 our class
line is 400 million dollars you know for
for our managed care I don't have that
figure off the top of my head but it
would probably be north of a billion
dollars if you looked at our class 102
in class 74.
thank you I also see that as a place to
save sure
representative
so a couple comments I understand your
position
as noted
um I'll just note that these positions
have never been well I should never
might be strong but certainly I would
say in your tenure Benfield in the case
of the full-time not permanent you've
got 45 or 110 filled right now as I
understand in the case of the part-time
247 and 419 in the case of the permanent
full-time those positions have been
vacant many of them since 2018 at least
we've gone back that far but let's go
with your approach and we just name a
number
um
back of the budget cut or reduction
whatever will you not fight to get that
eliminated in the Senate because it's a
non-specific reduction because in the
past we have been admonished as a
committee for not being specific about
areas that we want to see reductions in
foreign
I think you already know that of course
we're going to Advocate not to have the
back of the budget be cut because
um like for for this year alone there's
I think an estimated 89 million dollar
agency lapse and typically the state
looks to us for about half of that so
for the current biennium you've probably
heard me at fiscal we've had to reduce
our Personnel by 22.6 million dollars
and so for this past biennium I think
our expenditure lapse was roughly 26.4
million dollars
um because we're traditionally our lapse
is often coming from from some of those
Personnel but it was a little bit
different a little bit different this
year and I um you know I I respect and
understand the position that you are in
and that that criticism that you have
faced I I just
yeah I'm I'm really concerned about
how this kind of it it's it's not
consistent with what what the
commissioner has been saying publicly
has been
um talking to the public about talking
to the staff about about her priority to
try to get the Staffing levels back up
to where they should be just because
well the pandemic does feel like a
really long time ago you know we lost we
had a quite a bit of churn through that
um and you know we're we're still
feeling those effects I just did a staff
survey for my division uh it's still in
process but the feedback that I'm
getting still is they still feel
overworked they still feel pressed
um and you know we're doing things to
change that but but I'm just really
concerned about another Target to the
Personnel I just don't think in the long
run that's going to allow us to
effectively you know implement the
Medicaid rates Implement uh the the
mental health
agreement efforts and and all the other
projects that that we want to do for
um for the citizens of New Hampshire
so here's what I would have proposed
that we stick with the
only putting the cap on the full-time
permanent positions which I think is
another amendment that folks mentioned
earlier
um so don't so we don't constrain them
like on the flexibility with regard to
the
the temporary positions that have
different
um ratios but again these positions have
not been filled it's nothing to do with
covid going way back before covet
they've not been filled
so so let's let's act on that and and
shift the conversation over to zero nine
two seven which is I think the amendment
you were referring to
and this is 23.4
based on
continuing the imposition of the same
ceiling that we've operated under the
current year
or representative Stringham did you want
to look at this before you asked your
question you had one earlier well let me
let
um if it's okay before you jump to that
but
um you know we have roughly 3 000
employees 213 would be about seven
percent I'm just wondering if the 360
million dollar in
um
uh Personnel cost or did we do two years
in one of these in one year for the
other or are you really looking at
fifteen to sixteen percent uh reduction
oh I I apologize I was just doing some
very quick quick math here but but the
way that plays out though and I think
we've talked about this before is we
never even have an opportunity to post
those positions so it effectively
creates that that that vacancy rate
because it constricts us there I I again
I think that if we can have
more if if we do have a back of the
budget cut more flexibility in what that
looks like and um you know I think
representative Earth is accurate
particularly with the part-time
employees there have been positions that
have been vacant for some time I mean I
think that's certainly an area that we
would likely lapse from
um I I think it's just trying to find a
balance between recognizing the fact
that we will still have vacancies but
also recognizing the fact that there are
a lot of very clear conservative efforts
on the part of leadership to fill those
positions to get us closer to where we
should be
uh just a follow-up to we're kind of
unique among states I think one of your
first presentations uh compared the
number of employees per dollar of spend
that we have in health and human
services and there's a pretty unique
structure in New Hampshire compared to
all all of our comparables and that we
do a lot more work and do a lot more
spending with fewer employees and rely
uh substantially more on
um
as
chairman Weiler mentioned on contract
cases so would it be easier for you to
work
with with dollar constraints rather than
Personnel constraints
yes
so so the question that representative
Rays though is if we put in a dollar
amount without being able to back it up
with some sort of change in operations
that I guess by protocol is frowned upon
and and and and and and and and not is
respected in the other body so so
completely disjointing these two things
and just doing the money it probably
exposes the money part of it to uh easy
being assailed easily so I think that's
what I heard representative Weiler
it's been a few years since I walked
around your offices in the various
buildings
but even when it was back around 2200
2300 employees
and we said you could go to three
thousand
I don't see how you could have done that
without
leasing another building
have you had any more buildings in the
last couple of years so DHHS has
embraced uh the the technology that that
came available during the pandemic and
most areas use a hybrid model so before
I took this role I was running the
contracts Bureau and what we did there
is we actually implemented death share
programs so that people would share
desks some would be in certain days
someone be in other days to try to take
advantage both of the of really the
benefit of of
um you know staff morale and retention
with those programs but then also just
recognize the fact that we do have
limited space and that's how we've been
able to do that and dphs has been doing
that for years congratulations thank you
representative Holt thank you so I guess
oops
go ahead representative Waller we
representative hole is deferring to him
okay
um
I guess I I know you reviewed this and I
want to review it one more time so I
have it
straight in my head when we do a back of
the budget cut like this whether it's
Personnel or just an open-ended back of
the budget
we risk losing federal funds
often it's a 50 50 so 23 million becomes
really 46 or
maybe somewhat less depending on the
match of whatever you decide to reduce
the budget by so
that service
to our to our citizens we're losing 50
million close to 50 million dollars
worth of service
and I know you and I talked about this
and I think you just alluded to it but
in every budget in the last several
bienniums
there has been a lapse requirement
how much lapse requirement have you had
on top of these back of the budgets
which also means you'll be probably
losing federal funds
sure so so as I indicated earlier
generally speaking
um so the lapse is technically in the
Surplus statement it's not in hb1 it's
not an hb2 it's the assumptions upon
which the legislature uh balances the
budget
um in 22 the LA the the total lapse for
the uh state was 64.8 million dollars in
the general education trust fund and
89.5 in state fiscal year 23 and so you
take half of that and that's what's been
expected from DHHS
so you had to lapse on top of the back
of the budget
you had to lapse an additional 32
and an additional 45.
yeah that that that's been the general
expectation yes
and
most of that
also entailed you losing federal funds
um
so it it certainly could I I think one
thing just to recognize is that if we do
receive federal funds or we do receive
an appropriation of General funds to
implement a program if we if we don't
have the Personnel available or we can't
fill those personnel and we can't spend
those dollars we may either lose that
match or we may actually not spend the
federal dollars or the general fund
appropriation lapse that back to the
federal government or lapse that back to
the general fund coffers
so we lose it and we end up losing it in
both Federal and general fund services
one way or another
thank you well let me just challenge
that that logic for just a moment though
um
at some point
we have a limit on how much General
funds that we're even able to spend well
there you know if the theory was that
every dollar in general funds that we
spend that we're going to get more
Federal money we we could go to infinity
and the general funds and get infinity
times 2 back from the feds so there is
some natural upper limit to how many
General funds we can invest
we know that right now the governor's
budget is counting on more Revenue than
we are projecting at this point and
we're getting warning signs from the
Senate that it's going to be even lower
than the house version so somewhere
along the line we have to worry about
where our general funds are going
we're not going to be losing if we if we
if we take this
23.4 million
I think we're gonna we're trying to move
it over to the the Medicaid rate
targeting
if we're in the Medicaid rate targeting
we may actually get reimbursed at this
the same level we would have if it had
been in this account but we may actually
get a higher yield from the feds by
putting it through Medicaid rate
expansion so so so the part of your
argument I'm challenging is that we're
going to lose Federal money
we're just going to get the same or more
Federal money by putting it into
Medicaid
tax rate or excuse me rate hikes than if
we kept it in headquarters people
go ahead
representative Wyler
many of the items we see in fiscal
are moving the date of a of a Federal
Grant
oh so so we're going to give it another
year or so so if if we move money out of
something that was going to be a Federal
grant we didn't get to use it up at this
at the rate we thought we would we quite
often the feds let us keep it and move
it to another year so a lot of this
losing all these federal funds doesn't
happen they've already written off the
funds they sent to us and give us more
time to spend them that's why we have so
many items in fiscal saying the lap
State shall be changed to such and such
see that all the time thank you who is
next representative
we're not losing any federal funds match
because these positions that were
reducing the funding for are not going
to be filled as I said this has nothing
to do with covid these positions have
been vacant for like six or more years
the the ceiling of 3000 is the same as
the ceiling in this past budget so so
this is not money that got spent in the
last budget and and we this would just
continue it into the next budget so
there's kind of no change at that level
we're
was was there another over here
representative whole
sure comparing the differences between
927 and 1149 right and this is to to Mr
White
if I heard him correctly he'd rather
have a dollar value than us kind of
meddling with full-time
temporary part-time temporary positions
I guess my question for him is
if we kept the 27.9
as the cost reduction
and allowed it to go to Personnel
related class but expanded line six
in 927 to Personnel related class
reductions and and maybe contract
and then use the explanation of deleting
the 213 unfilled right for some period
of time positions as part of the
justification could you accept that
right I guess I'm making a change said
another way to 927 of increasing Line 6
to 27 9.
and allowing you beyond just personnel
class lines maybe some additional places
you could go in contracts to find that
money
so so
you you just to clarify So you you're
referring to 1149h only
like that that I'm okay so we can use
either one as the Baseline if we use
11.40 no we can't we're talking about uh
927 all the conversations okay so let's
use 927. okay right change line six to
27.9
but change also on line six
that the reduction could be Beyond just
Personnel related class lines
to allow you some contract lines to have
access to because you might find savings
there
so you're going to increase the amount
that we have to lapse
with the flexibility that it can come
from other places correct I I honestly
don't think that
it's I I mean I would probably need to
speak with a commissioner about that
option I I mean I don't think either one
is a great option and moreover the
the 200 the 3000
position count it it's it's fairly it's
not it's not meaningful because when
we're talking about 27 million or 24
million dollars of General funds again
most of those positions are 50 50 and
it's going to be a lot more than 3 000
like like it's I I quick math it's
probably closer to 2 800 that we
wouldn't be able to fund so so the I I
don't think
I I I think
the most benefit comes from focusing on
the dollar amount of of what we of what
you want to do there
um I I mean I think my position is is
pretty clear it's gonna it's going to
hurt us one way or another it's just to
the extent that it does because as
representative walner pointed out
we still have to find whatever the lapse
ends up being you know whether the
whether the committee conference assumes
two percent or three percent or four
percent
all those contract dollars that aren't
spent are still going to probably need
to go towards that lap so if if we have
the back of the budget cut and the labs
whether there's flexibility here or
flexibility on the laps we're going to
have to intentionally hold positions
vacant one way or another
Mr Ripple what is the current lapse in
hb2 do you remember
foreign
well there's a back of the budget
reduction in the current House Bill one
of 22.6 million that's related to
Personnel glass lines
but if unless I'm mistaken there's no
lapse called for in the current budget
is that right that's correct the lapse
is not the lapse expectation is not
written into law right so we did not
require a lapse we did just the yeah
back of the budget reduction of
full-time permanent positions correct
but but the way that the Surplus
statement has historically been
interpreted even though it's not
technically part of state law that's
That's the basis upon which the
Department administrative services and
the governor's office looks to DHHS and
other agencies when they're looking for
their lapse at the end of the year
that's on you so to speak not on us the
the the reason again going back to the
reason of this is not just to say we
want elapse money it's to say let's
release these General funds so we can
apply them into the Medicaid rates and
hopefully get above that 40 million
dollar uh threshold we're talking about
for Medicaid rate increases 40 million
dollars per year for Medicare rate
increases
Mr chair I'd propose that we move 927
hotel as we have in front of us
Mr chair
representative Norton
effect sure okay
we'll we'll vote when we come back
five minute recess thank you
second warning
this one was actually close to five
minutes
yeah
all right
um we're we're back out of recess uh
representative erf would you would you
would you bring us up to speed on uh
recommended changes to zero nine two
seven so Mr Ripple is actually working
on a clean version so you all can read
it but here's and I discussed this with
Mr White as well
so looking at 927
starting towards the end of line five
whereas that is hereby directed to
reduce Personnel related class lines
change that to is hereby director to
reduce state general fund Appropriations
by same amount and then delete in
general funds because the GF is
mentioned in the Clause before
for the biennium ending June 30 2025 and
then
on line seven to lead all the way up to
the period so that so the period would
fall at the end of line six
the 3000 limit would still apply
but it wouldn't be directed for the
funding to come out of the
full-time person full-time permanent
Personnel loans
first of all does that just make sense
does everybody understand the word to
rep or Mr Ripple it looks like you want
to say something
um no
I can I can make copies of what
representative Earth just described if
you're willing to tolerate my
handwritten scroll let's do that okay
so
the idea is to provide more flexibility
to
the department
while still being specific about what
we're trying to accomplish
and hopefully still being able to use
these funds to apply to the Medicaid
uh rate
um increases
thank you Mr chair
Mr chair is the intent intent to
um just have that so we can look at it
are we going to vote from a him I'm
feeling like I'm going to vote on it but
to vote on it I want you to be able to
see exactly what just got verbally
described
um and uh you know the part that's not
going to be written is our intent is
we're looking for money
to move into a higher priority to I
think of uh Inc increasing the Medicaid
rate hikes
because I think our number one problem
in the state from a health care
perspective is the ER boarding that's
the symptom of a tremendous amount of
dysfunction throughout the state to the
extent that we can address that we
should be a healthier happier state so
I'm just saying if I can going to spend
money on Personnel in the department
versus
Medicaid money to build out the delivery
system I I think where we're at I I
would prioritize building out the
delivery system
foreign
you haven't gotten any sort of update
from OLS on the Medicaid expansion okay
to so I would just observe that that
this language initially came from what
what we did in hb2
basically word for word with what we did
in hb2 last term
and with these changes that
representative verf is proposing this
actually is more permissive than what we
are doing in the current year
so I think everyone's had an opportunity
to read this language I I don't think
it's changed anyone's positions except I
think it's made
the prevailing position probably more
flexible for the Department
so if there's no further discussion I'll
I'd like to go ahead and take a straw
vote on this
all in favor of accepting zero nine two
seven with the handwritten changes done
by Mr Ripple please raise your hand
opposed
okay all right thank you
so so somebody everybody should check me
because I think
we're down to one last item and that is
the Medicaid rate
targeted rate hikes
that's the last issue is there anything
else I still have my Amendment hanging
out there in The Ether
oh
let's do you yours now then
does HHS give you overtime
oh okay so so
um look for representative tolerski's
Amendment it was basically adding 625
000 to a coalition for sud issues
do you recall the number 8 it's an HP
one Amendment
it's an HB one Amendment oh HP one okay
a list of five Regional
groups
oh I have one I actually found a piece
of paper
all right
so
this is representative tolerski's
proposal
is there any discussion on this proposal
representative Mooney thank you Mr chair
I'm wondering if perhaps we could reduce
the amount considering the circumstance
we're in
to forty thousand dollars per
organization
listed here
in the hb1 amendment description
so we're changing the the proposed
change of 625 to 200.
correct
that's my motion
any any discussion on that proposal
okay so uh we're gonna
I was just going to say I was planning
to vote against it but at this level I
think I support it
so your your opposition I'm just curious
about what your opposition was at 625.
well it it's just that it's uh it you
know it's a select group of of providers
and you know
um
rather than
kind of put out for wider distribution
whether it's the right group or not but
they have been fairly well organized and
and they do good work so at this level
I'm comfortable putting some support in
yeah thank you for sharing that any
other comments representative Weiler
do these groups get any money from like
United Fund or any of these other
charitable funds puke trust or anybody
I know that the United Way actually is
the Fiscal Agent for the National
Organization I don't know if that's all
of them or not
thank you but but yesterday we had a
discussion I think on the that there's
some match money that the organization
is going to attempt to solicit and that
the match money is somehow meant to be
um comparable to the general funds at
least this is what I'm thinking I
remember it was a little unclear I think
after our conversation and looking at
the questions it was unclear
on the answer
okay so being honest so so the part of
it that is probably clear though is that
there they have an internal expectation
that they're going to go raise
supplemental funds
and I would assume the fact that they
can say that they've gotten some general
funding could help prime the pump for
their fundraising if if they Market it
that way
all right so uh all those in favor of
accepting the the tolersky hb1 amendment
at 200 000 versus 625 a year please
raise your hand
opposed
okay
so
oh you don't know what exhausted is
welcome to finance
all right
so representative Mooney you handed me
this for a reason and I'm not sure what
this is for yesterday
it's up to you so so we're discussing
just so you know it says irf on it and
it's an hb2 item
and it's number
is uh one zero five three
it's related to construction funds
I I don't I don't think that we need to
pick this up because what the finance
committee passed and what the floor
amendment is for this week
I think has already taken care of the
construction fund issue I don't I don't
know that this adds anything because
we're going to pass something
go ahead
putting aside what happens
on the floor or anytime this basically
goes back to the
10 million dollars of General funds
which is currently in uh being taken
pulled out of FY 23 it's
I I didn't know if we voted on it or not
voted on I'm trying to find it on the
list
um
but but I know where it appears on my
list I I thought we had voted it said
someone to make everything come from
I thought we voted on it too but if
you're bringing it up maybe we didn't no
I I I think the appropriation was 21.6
and it was all meant to be arpa unless
they ran out arpa in which case the
governor would come back and request
General funds but I note that on your or
on the sheet that Mr Kane produced for
us this morning he still shows the 10
million sununu funny money on there you
know that how he produces that
um I thought he took off the 10 million
for the sununu center
uh however I think I think he was
planning on carrying
6.6 million in general funds uh if House
Bill 49 becomes law assuming 15 million
arpa and the remaining 6.6 in general
so where it says 10 now we we'd strike
through that and make it 6.6
the well effectively yes the 10 would be
removed and there'd be 6.6 million
associated with house bill 49. and why
is that
be
that's if you that's if you voted to uh
undo Amendment 1053 that's
oh is that we're voting dude to undo
1053 now right now we're discussing
1053. have we previously approved it
you had approved it previously
okay
so I I it's it's backwards in my head
I I am predisposed to thinking that 49
in one way or another is going to pass
the house and it's going to go to the
Senate and the appropriation amount is
going to remain
21.6 with the use of arpa money first
that any Gap can be picked up by General
funds
so why wouldn't we just put like
6.6 of General funds into an hb1 budget
line item so that we're not surprised if
they have to come back from for General
funds I I don't think you need to do
that the Surplus statement that Mike
Kane produces will show 6.6 million in
general funds associated with house bill
49. I think what representative erf's
Amendment which was adopted previously
was designed to do is eliminate the hit
to the general fund At All by requiring
that the entire 21.6 B arpa
which is consistent with what ended up
with the finance committee voted that
out and the floor amendment is keeps the
same language so so
why why do we need this hb2 item
the the language in House Bill 49 does
not require that everything be General
funds it allows the governor to use arpa
to the
sorry does not require that everything
the arbor funds it allows the governor
to use arpa funds to the extent
available
this would require the exclusive use of
arpa or federal
I have to look up the exact language but
it would require the exclusive use of
arpa funds okay so what happens if he's
out of arpa funds
these General funds
and and if this is in law what happens
it reads including any funds which have
previously been allocated by the
governor but which have not been
expended so if gopher had allocated arpa
to a different purpose but they hadn't
been spent the governor would have to
find the money there
what if he can
and this is in the fact what what what
happens then then there's there's no
alternative
it's arpa or nothing under that
Amendment
but more importantly I still don't
understand why there would be some money
left in general funds if this has
already passed and been accounted for
there wouldn't be if 1053 remains
in-house Bill 2 there would be no
general fund expense associated with
this new center replacement I I think
the discussion is whether to keep 1053
or do something else with it well that's
what I'm thinking I'm thinking that we
we could recovery I don't know what
value this is adding it keeps
so new new funding General funds out of
the budget so we have more money
available more General funds available
for what we're doing
so if you look at the and this is what
we I thought we'd already done all this
but back to the
um FY 23 Surplus
there's a line in there for sonuna that
says 10 million dollars
and this that's General funds coming out
of surplus right now this this year
this took that away so that that goes to
zero which frees up 10 million dollars
of General funds along with what
everything everything else we've been
trying to free up here okay and we've
already voted on this I thought so all
right
okay so just to clarify please make sure
Mr King has removed it because I'm
pretty sure it's on today's version it
was still there the 10 million
I think he had a line associated with it
but I think he showed it as a a division
three savings compared to the governor's
Original House Bill too
okay so that topic came up because I'm
encouraging everyone to take a look at
all of their notes
because I believe we've done everything
except for the final thing on the
Medicaid
tax rate hikes
there's that and there's one other item
that I'd like to discuss with you if
you're willing to take a five-minute
recess
we're in a five-minute recess
foreign
everybody's had an orange Lifesaver
except for urban center Orange
Lifesavers Okay so
so we're going to go ahead and come out
of recess
and with that
we are
is this the first time we've looked as a
committee uh at Medicaid expansion
so this is we've talked about it a
little bit but this is the first time
we've seen it he uh Mr Ripple would you
hand out 11 28
.
laughs
why are we doing this instead of waiting
for the Senate bill
so that we have a house position because
we've got a few things that we want to
put stakes in the ground so that in a
committee a conference our position is
known
and and Mr Ripple go through it so
you'll you you may not agree one that we
want those to be our house positions but
we do have some house positions in here
okay no do that I I'd appreciate an
independent comparison so representative
walner is running off to get her version
of the Senate Medicaid expansion bill so
um
yeah
so Mr Ripple what you're getting up now
the Senate primarily with some other
house Geniuses looking at it to tweak it
but it's it
the footprint is the Senate
that's representative Waller asks the
same question
yeah yeah it's the answer to her is
because if we don't do this the house
does not have a position if we go into a
committee a conference this established
this if we pass this this would
establish a house position on the
committee a conference
and so Mr Ripple would you go through
and and I think the key thing you intend
to highlight are the distinctions
between this version and the Senate
version or would do you think we ought
to go through the whole thing I'll
highlight the distinction between this
and Senate Bill 263 as passed by the
Senate all right
so everything about the commission on
page
one and page two is the same
um on page three
down at the bottom section six you can
see that it extends the repeal of the
program not permanently as the Senate
bill would do but until December 31st
2025 so it extends it for another two
years
everything else about this page is the
same and it may look familiar because
you've already passed all the other
language on page three in the context of
the alcohol fund amendment that the
committee adopted earlier
on page four
likewise there is some more language
that was included in the earlier alcohol
fund Amendment
but on lines 12 and 13 there's bolded
language that is not included in the
Senate Bill 263 that reads the
department shall include the cost of the
program and its biennial budget requests
under rsa94 the intent of this is to
require the program to appear in the
operating budget going forward rather
than be off budget as it currently is
and and and that's in the next budget
not this budget cycle that's correct it
would first appear in 2627.
and the other new language starting on
line 21 uh Liquor Commission fund
transfers this language was lifted
directly from the alcohol fund amendment
that you adopted earlier today uh that
requires the transfer of liquor funds to
the alcohol fund uh to be reduced by the
amount of the final donation from the
hospitals and that was added to make
sure that everything that impacts liquor
funds and the alcohol fund is identical
between what you did earlier and and
this amendment so if we were to pass
this amendment to keep things neat and
clean should we come back and back some
of those earlier decisions out
I don't think you really need to be
because it's duplicative of everything
that you passed earlier we would only
include it in The house's version of
House Bill 2 once it would read as it
does here
all right so so in summary
this is either identical to the senate
or similar to the treatment we've
already voted on with the exception of
two things it establishes a suspense or
a Sunset date of two years and it
directs that any future
medicated it may be not called expansion
in the future but Medicaid expansion
Beyond budget instead of off budget as a
separate project
so the second item I think we just all
agree if we're going to be doing this
over and over is probably just good
policy
the part that we probably see
differently is the two-year Sunset is
there discussion on that
representative hole
no I have a clerical question for Mr
Ripple page four line 26
sections two three four six seven eight
have an effective date instead of
section five but I don't see section one
was that a clerical
issue
yes section one should have an effective
date let me see what it is in Senate
Bill 263
oh
um
it would be upon passage and actually
that's okay because the way House Bill 2
was drafted every section that doesn't
have a specific effective date is upon
Passage
thank you
okay are there questions comments about
the proposal
let's go ahead and do the two halves
you can and we'll start with ever
whichever half you want to the two
things I'd want to talk about since
we've already seen and agreed to all of
this but those two issues the two-year
Sunset and requiring It Go on budget
maybe we could limit our conversation to
those two things first
but can we ask Mr Lipman for comment
thank you uh for the opportunity
um
appreciate uh that the decision as to
whether it's two years are permanent is
really a policy decision that uh
um and in terms of uh page four line 12
uh including it in our budget is really
again I think it was a policy decision
originally outside of the department to
make that so we're we're agnostic with
respect to
it's wherever you'd like it to be we'll
make it there
um I just had a question on 21 if you
could just
um on line 21 and Page four just could
go over that one more time so I'm
following what you did there
so this is the same language that was in
the earlier alcohol fund amendment that
was adopted today right well and that
was consistent with what was in the
Senate version in terms of how it
treated that
um the Senate version of Senate Bill 263
did everything the same as this with
respect to the alcohol fund and the
treatment of liquor funds except it did
not reduce
the transfer from liquor to the alcohol
fund by the by the amount of the last
remaining Hospital donation so that's
what this section is
okay
now if that's helpful perspective I mean
I think really the the two things uh you
know from a historical standpoint I
think the reason I think five years was
picked last time was just the
the the uh churn on legislators part in
terms of having to do it every two years
so but we're in the game for whatever's
needed to be done if you will
comments questions representative stream
uh this may be picky Yoon but since the
meeting first meetings of the Commission
in section one start in this biennium
and and legislative members get mileage
do we have to have an appropriation
okay the other did other questions
comments
represent tolersky I'll just make a
quick comment that I know for a number
of people in my caucus this is a very
very high priority and I think they
would have expected to have dealt with
this when the Senate bill came over
after crossover and would have the
ability to discuss it have a proper
public hearing receive input and and
take it as the policy change that it is
so that is my big opposition to this is
I don't I don't like the uh
tacking it on without having the entire
house take a look at it individually
it's just too important so you know
we're mid-stream though I I think I can
agree with you that we want our policy
committees involved when that Senate
Bill comes over it's going to get worked
through the policy committee they will
come out with a position the house will
come out with a recommendation and
depending on the timing of that that
will inform anybody that's involved in a
committee a conference on what the what
the policy-based house position is but
but but this basically sets up
a point of view on what the house
position ought to be I understand what
you're saying and my only point is that
there are members of my caucus that this
is hugely important to them and they
want to be a part of the conversation
and I feel establishing this as a house
position without letting them have their
their time to be a part of the policy
making I just I don't think it's it's an
appropriate way to do it
if in the worst case scenario the policy
committee can't get a position out of
the house for whatever reason
you know that is a possibility at least
there would still be a house position
that we could talk to the senate about
and we can change this based on the
policy decision if that's sort of a
leadership decision so everyone who
thinks this is important which is pretty
much everyone in the house
respects the policy committee and their
input
I I don't think this is a roadblock to
that but I can understand how people
might feel that because I just have my
own way of looking at it I I think I
think two things can happen in parallel
but uh representative Waller do you have
a comment
well I was going to say that I think
people are going to be
Maybe not maybe not on your side of the
aisle but I think on our side of the
aisle I do think people are going to be
surprised to find it in the budget
without having any um
any input into it and even
it wasn't I mean it wasn't even there
for people to comment in the public
hearing that we had
so
um you know I'm concerned about that
just that particular process and I guess
I could I just asked the department a
couple of questions about the um being
included in the in the budget
yes okay I you know I I think from the
standpoint of being able to really
understand the program every two years
when we do the budget I I think it is
good to have it in in the budget but how
much work is what's going to how how is
the department going to handle that I
mean when is that going to be when is
that work going to be done and how much
work is there going to be to doing that
and
just explain to me how it's going to
work sure so we we already have all of
the numbers and and the figures um it
would really just be
adding it to our our agency budget
requests
um it's not it's it's you know but
logistically it's it's not that
difficult frankly okay so do we stay
offline
during I mean obviously we don't have it
we don't have any numbers now so we stay
offline all of this
biennium this upcoming biennium and then
we start with the numbers in the next
biennium
yes yes so it's not going the num the uh
cost of this program is not going to be
reflected in house bill one or two
not unless an additional amendment is
proposed
thank you that helps me understand that
I think to the other point
there's people in the house on the GOP
side of the caucus that want to pass
Medicaid expansion and the fact that
we're offering to our members
that there is a two-year Sunset where we
can keep getting data and keep making
sure that this program is on track this
helps us get votes too so
um so that that that that is a reason
it's in here
all right
I this there's not a whole lot to
discuss on this
representative Holt thank you Mr chair
furthermore there was some discussions I
mean this is a large dollar item that is
off budget and there are people who
would like to see the transparency of
government and and honestly wanted this
in hb1 not an hb2 so there was a
compromise on our side at some level as
well
are there any other comments questions
of the department
I'll even take comments from the
audience is there anyone sitting back
here it's uh it's past six o'clock so
anybody want to speak up
foreign
I'm Jim Monahan with Dupont group um the
kind of the same Coalition that has been
working around the Medicaid rate
increases has also been working with
others have been working on the Medicaid
reauthorization around 262 and so three
um
yeah okay uh I was saying that the same
Coalition that has been working anyway
uh just uh Paul will talk about it I
suspect you know the minute
representative was Edwards observed
there were two differences between
Senate Bill 263 in this amendment I
think there's three
um the third one is that the
um Senate Bill 263 does not Envision the
hospital's voluntary contribution as a
part of the um
uh the governor's commission mechanism
that was there
um and I think could you draw our
attention to the line item so that we
can see what you're saying yeah why
don't I turn that piece over to Paula
um thank you Paula minahan Hospital
Association so I think it starts on page
four its um item 9 9 21 The Liquor
Commission fund transfers and I
apologize this is the first time we're
seeing this as well so maybe I'm just
misinterpreting this but
um unless Mr Ripple did you say this is
just
what was passed earlier
today relative to adjusting
the okay
um so this is really for
what you passed earlier relative to um
what happens in the for the remainder of
the
um Governor's commission funding the
voluntary contributions but this is
unique to this bill
um and that is not in 263. that is not
in Senate bill 263. is my
I believe I I think Jim's right so I'm I
guess I'm not seeing it I'm looking at
page four I think you said line nine
oh line see I really am losing it okay
let me let me look at that
this may not be in 263. this is you're
saying it's not in SB 263 and I think I
think what we should have made clear is
that lines 21 through 25 were items that
we voted on earlier right
um this Division and we're trying to
clean up the relationship between what
the general funds and other funds ought
to be doing to pay these obligations and
get sort of the shell game out of here
with the hospitals having to make
contributions to the alcohol and drug
commission and sort of the movement of
that money so this is I think the intent
is to just do the cleanup to get
these different organizations
independents
Clarity of responsibility into some
transparency
we just wanted to point out that it was
stated there were two differences
between 263 and there are actually three
you agree with that Mr Ripple
I agree section 9 is not in Senate Bill
263. all right and Miss Ripple pointed
that out when he was presenting it as
well so I probably made it confusing I'm
probably the guy that said too
all right and then uh with regard to the
the two-year duration of the
reauthorization what you'll hear in the
hearing on on 263 and you know I've been
part of this conversation with the uh
for some time on it is that
um uh
or many providers this is really
important for the SD sud providers for
example uh these are businesses that
need some expectation of Revenue going
forward
um and it and I do a lot of emphasis I
think belongs here and the the sub
providers who maybe 80 percent of their
Medicaid businesses from the granite
Advantage Program trying to build a
business hire staff have predictability
buy buildings for residential units for
residential beds and things like that
poses a lot of risk and if you don't
know on a two-year cycle uh if your
funding is going to be there or not it's
disruptive to the development of this
important industry that's going to be a
wad of what you'll hear in 263 so I
don't know if this two-year Sunset is
just to line it up with House Bill one
and two being a two-year package or if
it extends beyond that into the the
policy realm of whether or not we want
predict stability in the state as a
payer through the program I I don't
think it's to line it up with the budget
cycle I think this is more to just
ensure people who will vote for this
extension because a lot of people didn't
want this to happen in the first place
and aren't interested in extending it
this is a way to say
we're going to revisit it so this isn't
permanent we're going to continue to
revisit it so so I think that's that's
what the intent on this is and then
if if this were instead of two years
four years would that substantially
change the mindset of those building
their business plans or would it
effectively just be the same
confusion and ambiguity
it would be less bad
all right representative hold did you
have a comment
I was going to take a slightly alternate
view than you right we are put the some
of people wanted to see this as an hb1
item in the budget which would
automatically put the two-year sunset in
because it's right so
um it's kind of a
it's that proverbial swing set that was
designed and envisioned by one person
and built by somebody else and when all
was said and done you had the swing set
not hanging on the branches if you've
seen that Meme this is the same so what
happens in the process which is why the
two years is in there right now I think
I can understand that when you're
building million dollar 100 million
dollar plus programs that you need some
clarity of where things are going I
don't see
um I don't see a difference whether it's
two years four years or infinite in
terms of the next two-year runway for
each I I understand the ability to look
beyond that but if you were talking to
businesses in January of 2020 and they
were putting forecasts together no one
would have seen the anomaly that
happened in February and March so there
is some level that we need to take into
account we can see a couple years into
the future we can plan for a couple
years every year we do that and if we're
putting it on budget right some of us
want it on budget this year we can't do
that but we're trying to get there
no I I understand I mean if you know the
community mental health centers are in
the same situation 80 of the funding
comes through Medicaid and every two
years it might not be there but because
it's been around for a while there's
been some certainty it's in state law
that they they exist and so I think for
again for the sud providers you know
when Provisions like this make it harder
to go to a bank and say
can we borrow three million dollars to
build a residential treatment facility
um by the way you know there's some
doubt there's more doubt you hear what
I'm saying represented absolutely but
there is also I think the program
started in 2014 or thereabouts so
there's yeah we're eight years into this
at this point right so
um getting it on budget for the first
time is an important metric in where you
want to go
um and while we may disagree what the
dollar value and all of that but it's
baby steps so so well I just hope we
have the opportunity in 263 to make the
case for for you know more permanency to
the reauthorization so I really do
appreciate the perspective you added
because I I hadn't thought through the
residential treatment facility needing a
business loan that's just an example I
it just hadn't considered it
representative Weiler
we forget that this is an evolving
program and the first page
talks about appointing this very lengthy
Commission
to evaluate the effectiveness and future
of the New Hampshire granted Advantage
Health Care Program so that presupposes
there will be big changes if this
commission decides that that it needs to
do this it needs to do that and so on so
we we're going to get their report
within the year hopefully and it gives
us a year to make changes or so on so
that going forward we may adopt there
may be some great recommendations come
from this commission that want to be
adopted so that's why you don't want to
say oh yeah just go on forever and yeah
in 2018 when the legislature
reauthorized
um through how Senate Bill 313 it also
included a commission commission meant
many times they concluded the work this
summer and one of their recommendations
was
permanent reauthorization
and so in full disclosure uh Mr chair my
boss uh I I am a member or was a member
of the uh of this commission that's been
established and I was a signatory saying
it's my idea or my recommendation that
we make this permanent so
so there's that so we I do have a
history of sometimes agreeing with
representative Waller
so and I just would like to make one
comment about
um those individuals that are on
Medicaid
um
um expansion that they they go on and
off quite frequently because this really
is an opportunity for them if they're if
they lose their job or are struggling
um financially to get on and get
assistance and so that they can take
care of themselves and their families so
that they can get a job and we have
statistics and I know
um Mr lippman has this data that again
we will be sharing in full transparency
during the public hearing on 263 because
a lot of work has been done and a lot of
data has been collected individuals do
not stay on this for very long I do
um I I do I worry a lot about doing this
every two years there is um that would
really impact I believe them as well not
knowing whether or not this would exist
um in the future
maybe the commission made that
recommendation so they wouldn't have to
go back and study this again
now the commission would continue under
263. yeah yeah
thank you thank you is there any more
discussion on this
I I so with that
I I don't I'm not seeing or hearing any
proposed
changes to this but but I think it's
implied for all those who are in favor
of approving
1128 please raise your hand
those opposed
okay so we'll put that into the budget
at this point I'm going to say it again
and probably be wrong again but I think
we're down to just one item is that
correct and I think the one item is
coming from OLS dealing with our
rate hike recommendation
that is correct and I do have the
Amendments but I'm going through them
now and I'd like to run each one by the
respective sides before you discuss it
so you need 10 minutes for quality
assurance to make sure you think it's
right I think so yes all right so let's
recess for 10 minutes
all right let's uh let's come out of
recess while we were away
um representative Weiler kicked over a
rock with Mr lippman and something came
out that she wants to tell us about and
talk about she says she needs 60 seconds
what did I say
walner won't no no no no no no I I'm
it's just uh I'm fading I think I I'm
not a young man anymore
um
so we'll kick over that rock and and you
can tell us what this is yeah well let
Mr lip Moon explain it to you I just I
just think it's information I know we've
already voted it's it's going to be in
the budget Medicaid expansion is going
to be in the budget but I just think we
need to be aware of the pitfalls that we
might be falling into okay because it'll
come out later and then you'll say oh I
didn't know that I hate to be
wishy-washy but if this is really
important we just voted on her we could
maybe come back so I mean I I'm not ever
committed to doing something stupid just
because we did it
we I just think it's good good to know
before the public tells you right okay
Mr Lipman
so similar to the issue that Jim Monahan
raised there's a similar issue in
procuring the MCO contract you may or
may not know that our contract expires
August to 24 so we're going to be doing
a re-procurement uh
starting September of this year so that
we can get something in place for
September next year what I see
potentially is that they could it might
affect who bids based on the uncertainty
and whether we get as many bidders with
just a two-year
reauthorization that's I think an
important thing when you talk about
where can we maybe get Contract savings
you know if you only give a one-year
commitment we may lose
um you know the field that would bid for
it otherwise
question for you okay if if we change
the sunset from two years to four years
that would effectively give you three
years to to run the contract is three
years a nice bite at the contract Apple
I I think that's much better than than
that situation I think you know in terms
of I think is it more reasonable
certainty that that they have a chance
to you know get it set up and be able to
you know have you know several years if
you're for example if we're able to
attract a new bidder you know it takes
them 18 months to stand up their their
program so so so what's what's the
standard length of the contract five
years you really want to have five to be
normal
that that's that's what we've done um
the last two procurements so if we were
to do that it would have to be six years
the way we're lined up now yes
all right so that's all interesting data
any thoughts on that interesting data
are you open or proposing a
reconsideration with a tweak to the
sunset I'm open to reconsider the sunset
if if there's discussion and thought on
what we just heard
I would be more than willing to make a
motion to reconsider the vote if we can
look to extending the sunset from two
years to six years which would allow the
better procurement of the contracts and
uh put the department in a much stronger
position to get
um you know competitive bids
comment
well I don't know this is new data so I
didn't know if the new data would
influence your viewpoint
I think that the expanded Medicaid
Program has been on
effectively
fixed cycle
budget requests I think the first time
was two years if I recall and then it
was was it two years again and then five
years I'm trying to rank it was two two
and five two two and five so I I think
the providers can handle a two-year
window in terms of quoting it's been
done twice before there's a track record
now on nine years so there is some
expectation that it's going to go
forward
um I in the business cycle it's possible
to do a two-year contract
they can't do your contract because this
one expires at a point in time in which
if we put two years in they can only do
one year correct and if we do four years
it can only do three years if we do six
years it can do five years that's this
is what I'm hearing
Mr Lipman if I understand correctly I
think the current contract is a December
31st expiration date yes no um it is in
August of 24. okay thank you
representative Weiler do you have any
thoughts given the confrontation with
this new data
I thought we didn't want to make this
permanent but basically we're getting
around to it
so what I think I just heard you say is
that you would want to maintain the two
years and you wouldn't be open to
considering four years for example
I'm open if if that's what people want
but you know obviously in the past we
have had
two-year contract but as he said that's
really only is one year because it takes
them so long to ramp up but what about
the ones that are currently doing this
isn't it easy for them to continue
without ramp up
wouldn't okay to get another two-year
contract wouldn't we at least need to do
a sunset of three years
yes
so for those people who really love two
years is three years kind of acceptable
just to just to give them I would just
leave it where it is you would leave it
yes
we're not creating a law today we're in
the process of creating a two-year
multi-billion dollar budget there's a
lot of opportunities to have this
discussion I think we should stay at two
years
well I I hate doing things that I don't
think make sense and I I I think based
on the I had never considered or
factored in the contract windows
we have experience doing two-year
contracts we don't have experience doing
one-year contracts is that right
MCO procurements have been five years
each each time yeah so
so a lot of Manpower gets burnt going
through the whole contract
that's a that's an expensive process
where we don't see the dollars but the
the Manpower gets consumed
and I do think that there there is some
impact in terms of
how they have to factor in their startup
cost recovery when when they make a bid
and I think that
having the opportunity for other
entrants to to at least be interested in
it
helps you know over a five-year period
it's over six billion of spending and so
I think that that that
um
having some more competition helps the
state get a better deal on what it's
going to be getting if if we were the
last stop in this process and not the
first
um
I I would I would eat up everything you
just said and and and and and try to
deliver but this is the first step in a
process so so I I don't think I'm open
to reopening the vote we voted on two
years and
um
what
go go go ahead
okay thank you Mr chairman it just seems
from the discussion and I knew this
would be a sticking point
it seems like four years would be an
appropriate starting point and so I'm
wondering if the committee would
consider a four-year
time frame on this particular Amendment
and while I have the mic I just want to
point out too you brought up a very good
point that it is important to have this
in the budget to keep it alive in case
anything goes wrong with the Senate Bill
version
263. so I would put out there four years
based on this new information based on
previous based on where both sides are
differentiating on this
four years is my thought
I hate to do this but I I think we need
to caucus another five minutes
all right we're we're out of recess and
um we uh have already voted on
um the amendment I think it was 11 28.
or whatever the number was it was the
one with the two-year sunset this is an
early step in a one path to the
completion of this and so I let's just
be done with it we've already voted
let's let's move on
um with that
representative Stringham is going to
take the First at-bat on explaining your
Medicaid rate hike proposal and then
representative hole and Earth will take
us through another point of view
well great
um an amendment is going to be handed
out I don't know what the amendment
number is
um but uh you know the process of uh we
were we were
originally brought
uh hb2
with
with uh across the board rate increases
for the Medicaid services at 3.1 percent
uh since that's been done we've been
working on the process of of uh
determining really how much increase we
needed and also uh where we could Target
it to be the most effective
and during that process we we got a
substantial amount of input from from
many different providers
receiving Medicaid funds and through the
services
on both of these questions the level of
funding that would be
necessary to close some of the gaps and
services because often
are artificially low rates were so low
that essentially they couldn't find
providers to do things so
increasing the budget without increasing
the targeted or the rates for some of
these Services uh was was a high
priority for us as a committee
uh so
um
uh with that we the request came in for
our for as low as zero percent uh from
the hospital inpatient and outpatient
industry uh for a hospital inpatient
outpatient services uh to Upward and
over 25 percent uh so uh I offer
um uh Amendment uh 1154 H which
um
uh you know was was the result of the
concerted effort uh by stakeholders as
well as the members of the committee
themselves from both parties uh uh
requesting approximately
175 million dollars in Appropriations
roughly 75 million in the first year and
100 million in the second year
uh the the numbers uh written in this
amendment include the figures that were
originally provided or the 17 million
per year that was in the governor's hb2
budget so we did that even though
there's still a separate line item in
there there's wording in there to say
that taking into account the other uh
monies that would be appropriated under
existing what was lined 232 in hb2 this
is the total amount of money that we
would need I got I have two clarifying
questions one for you and then one for
Mr Ripple so
am I right to then think that of your
175 million the 24 million that's
reflected in par in paragraph one under
the appropriation that's part of it so
your your increment Above This across
the board 3.1 percent is 151 million
exactly all right so the the second
clarifying question Mr Ripple you you've
you've seen these and if on a side by
side is are the the structures of these
two amendments identical except for the
dollar amounts
yes with the exception that
this amendment 1154 h
outline specific ambulance codes on page
three line 16 through 20. thank you
and
also on page three
lines 27 through 32 are in this
amendment but not in the other Amendment
okay did you say page 2 27 through H3
lines 27 through 32.
okay now that I know what I'm looking at
this this is this is only in this
version and not in the other that's
correct okay
Mr Ripple so lines 21 through 26 on page
three are also not in the other
Amendment a I believe they are
hmm
I'm not sure where they they are in
their
hmm sorry just just one second
they they are in there but in the other
amendments which which I can hand out
momentarily they relate to different
line numbers because the the line
numbers are different between the two
amendments
thank you
okay as far as structure goes
um
representative a whole and
representative erf
it feels to me like the ambulance code
Edition on this version
may be helpful if we were to pass the uh
that version you we don't need the
ambulance codes in there so I was
speaking with Mr Lipton about this and
you might just want to ask him directly
but he said this makes their life a lot
harder
okay go ahead comment on that that uh Mr
uh Lipson pointed out to me that uh
yeah we'll we'll get them all right one
way uh the um representative Waller
Weiler
the the
um uh ambulance codes uh in in most
jurisdictions and and in Medicare they
have urban and rural rates uh but
Medicaid in New Hampshire does not so uh
my Amendment uh this latest Amendment
actually went down to just having one
rate for ambulance uh Statewide rather
than rural and urban which was the
complaint uh that we got about the um uh
or the concern that uh was brought
forward about having an urban and rural
so he would have had changed the
structure I I don't know these codes uh
so so is the one unified State rate the
a0425 and then the others those are
those are different ambulance services
the 13 that represents a mileage rate
for an ambulance service and then uh on
top of the you take the mileage times
the number of miles and then you add
whichever service is appropriate uh and
depends on how much medication and how
complex the ride is for the ambulance
provider one of the three codes actually
is of the three remaining codes is
actually not even covered under Medicaid
provision but there's no reason that it
it might not be in the in the future and
most ambulance fee schedules have
something in for that value okay so
after talking to Mr ribbum or Lipson uh
yeah it's your position that lines 16
through 20 should remain that they those
add value right is that right Mr
representative Stringham and now we're
going to hear Mr lipman's perspective
director
red
[Music]
excuse me representative
um Earth and representative Stringham
have two different points here one is
um in terms of targeting the codes
specifically I think and and keeping it
simple to to having one code for the
state that I agree with that approach I
think what representative erf I had
mentioned to him is that when you put
something into statute if you know
federal government or other coding
changes
um then you you run the risk that that
this becomes sort of outdated if you
will I think that
um you know it's workable either way I
think having
the role in urban would have create
would have delayed us implementing
something because we would have to
create a new methodology
and I hope I didn't make it more
confusing but so I'm going to summarize
what I just think I heard you say is
that the idea that these code rates be
included is fine your concern is that
we're using specific codes and those
specific codes can change over time and
it's that sort of thing that could cause
a problem in the long term in the short
term no in the long term yes I think
that having just one one of these each
of these codes here is the better of the
two options that if you're going to
include this some so just from a utility
perspective the uses of these codes is
sort of a one and done anyways you're
going to go in and and program these in
and let them go and then two years from
now we're going to be talking about this
completely new the codes could be
different and these codes now won't
matter what we put in here
yes in in one respect but I think that
if there's if for example a future
legislature says do a two percent across
the board and the codes don't exist
anymore that's where it so so Mr Ripple
is
is this
is this amendment
only valid for the two years or is this
ongoing statute
I believe yeah everything in here
relates only to the biennium to your
budget so correct next time we look at
this in two years
we don't care what these codes are that
we say today because we're going to be
looking at something different
is the way I'm interpreting this and so
it so it's feeling fine to me to leave
these codes in because they provide
information they're one-time use they
don't interfere with what we would do in
the next budget cycle that all sounds
reasonable and good to me
representative irf do you have a
different point of view
well I think we just want to slip and
say if next time around they say oh just
increase everything two percent that's
where there could be an issue if the
codes themselves have gone away
so I I'm not you know I'm not going to
suggest we change this right what I'm
trying to do is if this is good
structure I I might suggest that we pick
it up and put it in the other one as
well I'm just trying to keep the
structures aligned
yeah all right so thank you anything
else while you're sitting there
okay
um
so what are we doing with lines 21 and
26 why are tell me again why these are
uh in in this version and isn't compat
not the same as what was in the other
version
lines 21 through 23 is in your version
It's just in a different place that
relates to the Granite State
um request is that right it is yes and
and if I could the reasons 21 through 26
are bracketed is because I got the
amounts wrong it should have been 1.5
million and 3 million online 21 and the
amount on 24 should have been the the
handwritten number that you see here so
that's that's why you have The
annotation
okay so I'm just trying to keep the
structure as you so this is a different
structure than the other Amendment and
I'm just trying to understand why we
need this and we didn't need it in the
other version those Roman 20 and 21 are
in the other version
so
so with the exception of the ambulance
codes this structure is identical it's
just the dollar amounts that are
different the ambulance codes
the provision online is 27 through 28
that says each of the individual
Appropriations shall be reduced by that
provider type share of the lump sum
appropriation made in section one that
12 million per year figure
and section three that begins on line 29
is also in this amendment but not in the
other Amendment
so 27 through 32 has two different
components that are unique to this
structure yes
you know what does what does 27 and 28
add to the discussion what what why is
is this something we should maintain in
both structures is there Logic for that
what what
I that's a choice for the committee but
the intent behind this and
representative Stringham can correct me
if I'm wrong was to rather than adding
the entire 24 million to the sum of all
of these it was to reduce that by
these providers share of the 24 million
okay and then 29 through 32.
did we not have in the other version
anything about adult medical day
Services you don't have it in the other
version no so we just missed something
in theory
I think there was a
it's not included all right yes okay
all right representative walner
so over the weekend that was one of the
that was one of the areas in the Monahan
um
sheet that had it no
no information so I did reach out to
someone who is pretty familiar with the
service and actually
um has I think been a service a provider
um at Easter Seals and
the issue was that their rate is lower
than the CFI rate for for medical day
day service for uh
the for buying a day of service
um the CFI rate is 75 a day and the
state planned rate is
52.34 cents so it's it's a service that
not many providers want to provide and
so it was in very I mean I had no way of
figuring out how many units of service
they even have ever purchased because
the rate is low so you're deeper into it
than I am I'm still at a kind of a
higher uh simple level I think this is
the only paragraph that we can associate
a cost to right and I had no way of
figuring that out maybe the department
could have figured that out but at this
point it was sort of we were trying to
put the amendment together I I just
wonder if we need a cost because Mr
Ripple in the in the LBA team is going
to try to go through and count up all of
the places that we've spent money so
that we know what we're obligating and
this paragraph I don't know if this is
so tiny it's irrelevant or if we need
some sort of uh a wag
foreign
I don't know that you need an
appropriation if it passes without we
would send it to the department for
their inputs and we would put that into
a fiscal note
okay
Mr chair representative Hull
so
I understand that we have an amendment
number 1153 well we haven't gotten to it
but could we put at the end of one of
these amendments that the department
could move money over to that line item
if they needed to as a
subsequent provision
it was zero in the Monahan worksheet
that we started with for all of this
yep you can do that
do we have any idea of the order of
magnitude of that
few lines
I don't I I don't I'm not asking you
because there's somebody back there this
is Monahan available or maybe Mr Lipman
could tell us is that is that
are there very many units of this
service that we are providing
I could probably provide something
within by morning time I just I'm not
sure I have anything on my computer here
to give me that stat
um
but uh I think even just an order of
magnitude relative to other expenses is
it I don't think it is a multi-million
dollar item
um
but uh
I'd rather than just yeah okay guessing
I think you know at least having the
provision that represented a whole
talked about in terms of being able to
move money would be a good good start if
it's a minor thing
so if this was goalie locks this would
be small too small and not just right
this is the smallest of the three kind
of orders of magnitude tiny I think it's
in in that
magnitude of not huge okay
not significant
99 years not usually not just right
maybe maybe tiny go ahead in the
Medicaid State Plan home health aids
category right looking at the initial
spreadsheet right Medicaid Meals on
Wheels although showed up as zero
actually had 250 000 and this was
actually left blank so potentially it's
sub 250 000 in terms of dollar value
I'm sorry I I was thinking three
different things are you still talking
about 1154 and you're making an
observation that we may want to consider
a change to 1154.
no I'm observing that when he says the
dollar amount is small if it's less than
the other things in that same category
we're probably sub 250 000. as a oh okay
just so so this paragraph costs us less
than a quarter million correct okay
it's probably a fair
guess because you know this is general
fund so you're talking that's a half a
million dollars I would imagine that
would help fill that Gap pretty close
Mr chair go ahead
um has everybody received 1153 h
just just now I I would I would like to
just kind of if we could just a little
longer stay on structure we'll go
wherever you want Oh but I'm just trying
to make sure we crosswalk the structure
right so I'm I was going to suggest that
if we wanted to we could look at a
paragraph Roman numeral 22
at the end which allows for right the
DHHS can supplement out of right adult
mental sorry adult medical day Services
up to 250 000 out of some other
Department's funding or something
broadly speaking so we're
we've at least have a section in 11 53 H
that is similar not exactly the same
verbatim as 11 54 H in terms of covering
all the categories
did you follow that
um no
so my proposal is right on a lines 1154h
which is the Wallner proposal for this
they fund at some level the adult
medical day service so give me a page
and line number that's your page four
page three lines 29 through 32
32. take that section instead of
duplicating the text do what I mentioned
to Mr Ripple earlier which is give the
department the ability to fund up to 250
000 dollars through some other means
right give them the ability to pull out
of another fund to fund this if they
want to is that easier than just copy
and pasting lines 29 and 32 into the
other document
I'm fine with that too I know I have no
heartache in making moving lines 29
through 32 over to this and so
okay do you do you have any issues with
moving lines 16 through 20 over on the
ambulance codes do you have any issues
I'm asking you primarily because you
spent more time doing the number drill
nope
it looks to me like line 21
is actually
already line 12 page three that is
correct
so we're not moving it and the numbers
are aligned between the the left and the
right version correct
it so then when we get to
the bottom one there's a substantial
difference in the numbers there right
but the structure is the same correct
okay
so just in one second
so
so Mr Ripple
could we get this I'm going to propose
it and then you can tell me if it's just
not worth
sending it back to OLS this late because
we're not going to be able to finish
this
right any change we do at this point
we're not going to turn around tonight
I think that's correct
um if there are changes that you won't
make to this
what I was going to see just anyway is
that at the end of this meeting you
recess until Friday morning in case
which the other two divisions are doing
as well in case there are any changes
that need to be made to anything
at this point this is the only potential
change that I've I'm aware of I think so
yes Mr chair yes if I took a pair of
scissors and cut lines 29 through 32 out
and the amended analysis and photocopied
it on the bottom starting at line 17 and
we handed that out as an amendment to be
drafted would that meet the requirements
of at least conveying the information of
a joint Amendment
I I I I I I yes
but I I want to know are we going to
keep the ambulance codes or not oh right
okay FairPoint
that's a little bit harder to merge in
actually it's not it's just another take
the scissors and cut the ambulance codes
and paste it over there I think
nonetheless this is a
this is a big Amendment and maybe you
want to see the final
the final version of it
um so if you recess until Friday morning
anyway division three is meeting on
bills anyway I can give you the revised
version at that time
okay should I ask that question go ahead
so in the meantime you may have some
other numbers on the on the gef freed
upside that we could also consider on
Friday
well and I think the purpose of all
three divisions holding Friday open is
for that very reason
so the answer to that is yes yes okay
awesome uh representative walner and
ripple and irf do we have fiscal
committee Friday morning
this Friday afternoon do we have
anything going on Friday morning
what
we have four bills
and what time are we meeting on the
bills
10 10 o'clock I believe
so it feels to me like we want to
convene recess this until 8 30 Friday
morning
that way we have an hour where we can
look at this representative pilersky is
that a issue with you
no I've just been wanting to ask a
question for a number of hours oh for a
number of hours yes a number of hours
ago I wanted to ask representative a
question and you said not at this time
we're staying on track and it has to do
with his Amendment and how they brought
got to the numbers and I just would like
a clarify no go for it
thanks
so
when representative hole was running all
of his numbers and you were talking
about the ratios and can we just be
clear that we you know we or the
approach of how we're doing it my
question was
you started the day with
now I forget your term about five or six
things that you said we're gonna hold
constant hold constant and then as in
the Monahan numbers would stand and then
the rest would be a ratio based on what
they are so my question was were your
numbers in this amendment developed with
those cherry-picked categories on a hold
and everything else
fluctuated at a different Ratio or was
everything done on the same sort of
balance did you take our numbers and
then go down a percentage no I did it
the way I described or we did it I
actually said it rubs on a hole did it
based on the philosophy I explained to
you so those whatever was half a dozen
categories I think whatever they were
they were fully funded at whatever
numbers were in there
that was what I meant by hold constant
so they were funded at their relatively
low levels and that was that as far as
those go
the others were then proportionally
adjusted within the remaining 40 million
dollars per year it's minus the part
that we'd already
appropriate does that make sense that
does make sense and I guess I just
um don't know if we ever got an
explanation on how you picked which ones
were held we can do that yeah right now
no it isn't it's too late now why is it
too late my dog
where we're at I just wanted to
understand no no it's a very simple
explanation though I mean they're
basically small ones that's and I did
say that this morning as well it was a
long time ago so I apologize that's okay
no that's no problem so they were
relatively tiny amounts
like The Midwives the ambulance
um
the community health centers uh and then
there's the specialized one which is not
so
um low the 3-3 which was uh Mr lippman
um helped me hear the granite
the GS
and and that one was special as I
understood it because of the particular
Services they provided and how few
people will
uh uh do them I think the biggest one
you kept constant was the rebasing at
six and there was a rebasing exactly
that's the other thing which as I
understand it had to happen at that
level
so so there was some cherry picking but
it wasn't without some discretion it was
more they were the smaller amounts and
and the rebasing
okay
that was my question and I thank the
committee for indulging I thank you for
holding on to that question I do too
this time I would have exploded 12 times
already you
no I apologize I thought I had explained
I didn't do a very good job and I that
was my that was my bad okay so so let's
let's let's walk over to
11 53 a second
the uh section one is the same it's the
12 12 and both amendments the the first
paragraph is the same amount of money 24
between the two years
in the 1154 Amendment I heard
representative Stringham say that they
allocated another 151 million across all
of the paragraphs and we're now at the
point where our paragraphs are the same
paragraphs as between the two of them
you did 151 million plus the 24 to get
the 175 you mentioned right so let's
let's do the same numbers on on the 1153
how much What's the total of this I
think Mr Ripple you did some homework
mm-hmm
so the total
the fiscal 24 appropriation the fiscal
25 appropriation and the the amount
that's available to the department to
expend before January 1st if possible
is about 70.2 million dollars so and of
that 70.2 million
the 24 that's in Section 1 is that part
of the 70 so our Delta is more like 40
something or is the 24 on top of the 70
for 94. the 24 is on top of the 70.
okay so Apples to Apples then we
we I'm sorry 1153 invests
70.2 million in the
yes two million in individual ratings
and the 1154 does 151
so you know we're only off by a factor
of two
so that's that's I for a while I thought
it was going to be a factor of four so
this is pretty good now I don't I don't
I don't think these numbers are locked
either in either category because we're
going to come back at 8 30 on Friday
we're going to see the new scorecard
we'll have a little bit idea of whether
or not we can toy with the numbers but
at this point the structure is set and
the the basic math is set and if we have
extra money or God forbid less money we
at least have a way to apply like an
algorithm to get to what the number
needs to be based on the availability
funds right yes representative can you
just repeat for me
um I was right I wrote it a certain way
on the walner amendment is we had the
original 24 in section one and then we
had 151 for a total of 175 on your
Amendment you have the 24 and then what
was the next amount that
70.2 so our total is
94.2 and yours was 175. thank you I
appreciate that it was the going back
and forth I lost it okay
all right so while we're in session
what what do you propose on these do you
want to like do anything to these two
amendments or or just wait to us for
Friday so
here's what here's what I would suggest
I would suggest taking a vote today with
any changes that you would like me to
make
um and we'll accept that as as the as
the division's action and I'll bring
back to you the revised Amendment on
Friday and if you want any changes to
that you can vote to have those made
then so so we're going to send you one
or the other not both and we're going to
tell you any number changes that we want
to make that's correct okay
so
we've nordgren representative nordgren
yes ma'am
how are these funded
we don't know yet yeah but but you know
some of the big chunks we we we got we
started with sort of 40. so there's
money as they came out of the DD
accounts
there's the back of the budget issue
related to General funds uh appropriated
by to the state
um there's
the sununu centerpiece 10 million
dollars if that's still ours or is it
only if there's only less than that
the construction of a Noosa new center
yeah that was a 10 million so that's 10
million
um and then there's a variety of smaller
ones one and a half million here three
million there a bunch of those that we
were kicking out and even some smaller
than that 400 000 that sort of thing
my impression was we we funded 1153 by
going through all these things you
brought up but 1154 needs more money and
I don't know where it's coming from
do you have a comment representative
stream well yeah
at least my understanding
you mean 1154 needs more money to get up
to
well our budget you spent more money in
1154 than we spent 1153 but
representative era found lots of places
to save money to put into it right so
you would need to save more money to put
in more money and I don't see that where
they come from
so so can I summarize that I I I think
representative erf basically just
explained that we probably can account
for our 94.2
in terms of finding Bill payers for them
and and if if if you had those same bill
payers then you're you're you're still
short about uh 80 million and if you
came back and said okay we can get this
80 million by reducing these other
things I I I don't know I'd I'd be sort
of open to that discussion
representative erf so that's one
way to view it the other way to view
which I have been viewing it is the 40
million with just a plug number
to build a structure
and when we total up all those other
pieces which is what's going to happen
tonight I believe
so we'll know before Friday what that
total is I Envision that that total
would become the Top Line the
replacement for the 40 million I believe
it will be more than 40 million I don't
know the number though I don't know that
it'll be as high as 100 million per year
but but that's sort of the way I was
envisioning this whole thing oh okay so
so we have to be picked between uh 53
and 54.
and I what I what I I told
representative Stringham we'd consider
his Amendment first so I I think we can
take a straw vote on uh whether we
support 1154.
all those in favor of supporting 1154
opposed
okay so all those in favor of supporting
I'm gonna I'm gonna throw the disclaimer
in on 11 53 I'd like to do those cut and
pastes or not I'd like to see the
structure the same as 11 54. okay Mr
chair I just kind of sketched in right
where we are grabbing sections from 1154
lines page three lines 14 through 20
starting it notwithstanding and then
grabbing subsequently lines 29 through
32.
and those get amended into this so we
have a document that we're working with
I I think we're looking at it the same
and we're gonna we don't have to use our
imagination because Friday we're going
to see a document at 8 30 that has these
numbers but the structure of 1154 so
it's right
it'll be this amendment it'll be 1153
plus the ambulance rates and the uh
foreign
at the end of 11 50
oh four okay you uh represent Waller and
when will
I'm sorry when will we see how much
has either been saved or
spent I mean yes yes ma'am I think the
answer is Friday morning at 8 30 because
I think the LBA is going to take all the
work of the divisions and put it all
into the compilator and and turn it into
uh a balance yeah okay
okay
yes we are going to do that
um and Mike Mike handle send out a
revised sheet I'm not sure when that
will be I think it'll be before Friday
morning
and based on that we're going to have to
adjust fire to to hit the number I think
yeah and so we're coming back at 8 30.
on Friday
representative norgren comes a long way
and she's going home late yeah could we
maybe meet at 9 30 in we we have a 9 30
pre-fiscal so I I I'm trying to make
sure that I'm sorry
um
now we started off with an 85 million
dollar difference then we've added a lot
more 50 bills that wanted to spend more
money
so
we started off trying to make cuts
and trying to get inside of that 85
million so we were closer to the figures
we had to eliminate a lot of things I
don't think we've eliminated as much in
this division as the other divisions
have so
we're not we're not making many Cuts
here
that's true uh I think that's true
representative hole
um chairman Weiler fiscals meeting from
one two do you have any idea
it's it's a fairly extensive uh of
course a lot of its consent calendar and
then there's three
um
audits or two of them are management
letters it's going to be
two and a half hours likely I I was only
asking in respect to representative
norgren if we went for can we meet at 4
30 instead of 8 30 a.m make Friday night
a little bit late
um no I think there's we got to do this
Friday morning we there is no such thing
as Friday afternoon to turn around
changes is there
we have to do this Friday morning I
think
I I think if a Friday afternoon worked
best for the committee you could do that
um but Friday morning would be ideal
right now our exact sorry right now our
exec starts at 10. do we expect that
will go all the way through to lunch or
one o'clock could we we only have four
bills
I'm not seeing a lot of controversy uh I
you know I I could imagine us being done
we we never go as fast as I imagine but
I think we'll be done in 90 minutes or
less could we start at 9 30
then stop to do our exact at 10 and then
return and finish up before lunch or is
that too confusing we still have
pre-fiscal at 9 30. oh I'm sorry I
missed I forgot that my
it's enough on the schedule it might
take an hour
so eight 8 30 is a problem
you sure is it light when you drive when
you get here at 8 30.
at nine and we don't finish in half an
hour then we couldn't we just come back
after our morning bills which would
still be before noon I think
sure but I I just want to wrap things up
and be done but you know this will just
restrain your talking
well because you would just talk a lot
anyway if we came in at 8 30. I might
talk a lot no matter what time we show
up right so does it helped to constrain
that yeah
[Music]
all right go ahead
I think that representative has a great
suggestion I don't think our exec
session will last too long at 10 o'clock
this Friday and I think then we can
continue our work immediately thereafter
okay so people want to start at nine
right I'll be
I'll be you'll be you won't be here at
nine
could we review the amendments
knowing rep representative Weiler will
be returning to vote afterwards yeah
I'm
sure so we'll meet at nine o'clock
for all of us who can meet at nine
o'clock then a bunch of us have to leave
at 9 30. so hopefully we can do what we
need to do in those 30 minutes and then
we'll have some recess opportunities
later in the day if we have to
okay all right so
um
so we have not actually voted on 1153 I
think there's an implication but all
those in favor of 1153 raise your hand
well
as amended yeah
okay opposed
Okay so
so now we've done all of the voting we
need to do today
I think we've done all the voting we
need to do you've got all of the input
that you need
yes
okay all right so you want to remind
everyone yes I'd like to remind everyone
tomorrow's session starts at 9 00 a.m
that's 9 00 A.M
yeah all right I I just want to tell you
I think we should feel good about
ourselves to a very large extent because
we just no what we just did was the
governor
he didn't do any of this additional uh
rate hikes he said the house could take
that on and we actually have
framework that we've agreed to it's just
the dollar amount we've got to finalize
thank you Mr Monahan for your work yeah
yeah thank you thank you thank you
so all right thank you
and the always the LBA
okay we we are
and Mr wine oh he's still here
yeah all right all right thank you
word adjourn